GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ARE
CO-CHAIR IS ON THE WAY. FOR THIS
HEARING. I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR ATTENDING TODAY'S JOINT
HEARING ON THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF S¼ B 150. THIS
GROUNDBREAKING LEGISLATION THAT
WILL HAVE A FAR-REACHING IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS IN THE
TRANSITION TO A GREEN ECONOMY.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED. THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME SLIGHT CHANGES IN
OUR AGENDA TODAY. UM WE KNOW
COVID IS STILL OUT THERE AND R
èC, THE èC E Ó OF SPARKS.
SANJEEV MATRA IS UNFORTUNATELY
UNABLE TO JOIN US, UH, FOR THE
HEARING TODAY, UH AND WE WISH
HIM A HEALTHY RECOVERY. UH I
WANTED TO, UH, LIFT UP THE FACT
THAT, UM DOCTOR MAHARA HAS
SUBMITTED HIS WRITTEN TESTIMONY
FOR TODAY'S RECORD, AND WE WILL
INCLUDE IT IN OUR ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IN THE
MATERIAL A GERMAN IF HE WANTS TO
READ HIS TESTIMONY, AND WE THANK
HIM FOR PROVIDING THAT, UH, TO
THE COMMITTEE. S¼ B 150 IS THE
LANDMARK INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
SIGNED INTO LAW IN JULY OF 2020
THREE THAT WILL SUPPORT AT LEAST
$40 BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDING
II. IRA AND CHIPS ACT. DOLLARS
THIS PACKAGE INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
AND GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE, AND IT
WILL IMPROVE OUR STATE'S ABILITY
TO COMPETE FOR VALUABLE FEDERAL
FUNDING, AS WELL AS ENHANCED
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE TRAINING
PIPELINE. THESE EFFORTS WILL
BRING HIGH TECH MANUFACTURING TO
OUR STATE AND IMPROVE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHILE DECREASING
THE STATE'S RELIANCE ON FOSSIL
FUELS, THUS ENSURING EQUITY AND
COMPLIANCE OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. S¼ B 150
, ALONG WITH THE ZERO EMISSIONS
JOBS ROADMAP, FUNDED IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WILL MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE COMPETITIVE FOR
THESE FUNDS. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WE FACE IS
STRATEGIZING NOT ONLY HOW TO
CREATE HIGH QUALITY UNIONIZED
JOBS, BUT ALSO HOW WE ENSURE ALL
COMMUNITIES BENEFIT FROM THESE
OPPORTUNITIES, ESPECIALLY OUR
MOST DISADVANTAGED IN
CALIFORNIA. LET'S BE CLEAR
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A POVERTY
CRISIS. MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
OUR STATE'S RESIDENTS ARE LIVING
AT NEAR AND BELOW. THE POVERTY
LEVEL. THIS REALITY IS EVEN MORE
SEVERE FOR THOSE FROM
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. LAST SUMMER, THE BUREAU
OF LABOR STATISTICS REPORTED
THAT 90% OF UNEMPLOYED U S¼
CITIZENS ARE BLACK AMERICANS.
WITH CALIFORNIA, REFLECTING
SIMILAR UNEMPLOYMENT DISPARITIES
. IT IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL THAT WE
LEAD ON THIS GREAT AS A GREAT
STAY ON THIS ISSUE AND ENSURE
THAT SB 150. THE POLICIES WE
PASS ARE COMPLIED WITH TO CREATE
EQUITABLE JOB OPPORTUNITIES,
CAREER PATHWAYS FOR OUR HARDEST
HIT COMMUNITIES OF PREDOMINANTLY
POOR PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS
AND WOMEN. S¼ B 150 IS THE NEXT
STEP IN OUR LONG JOURNEY TOWARD
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACTUALIZING THIS
VISION WILL REQUIRE OUR STATE
AGENCIES TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THAT CONTRACTORS STAY
ACCOUNTABLE AND ON TRACK WITH
THEIR EQUITY GOALS. ENSURING
LABOR STANDARDS. WE WANT TO
RETURN TO AFFIRMATIVELY AUDITING
AND ENFORCING NONE
DISCRIMINATION OBLIGATIONS ON
CONTRACTORS RECEIVING FUNDS
RATHER THAN PUTTING THE ONUS ON
WORKERS. TO POLICE EQUITY
STANDARDS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT ON POTENTIALLY
RESTORING THE OFFICE OF
COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS, A UNIT THAT
WAS GUTTED BY THEN GOVERNOR PETE
WILSON AMIDST THE LARGER ASSAULT
ON AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND OTHER
POLICIES THAT DARTS EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE. STRONG CLEAR
AND ENFORCEABLE STATE STANDARDS
ARE IMPERATIVE TO ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC FUNDING CREATES GOOD JOBS
AND EQUITABLE PATHWAYS TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ONE OUR HEARING
TODAY. WILL EXPLORE HOW SB 150
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED. WE WILL
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM STAKEHOLDERS
ON THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
MAXIMIZING THIS OPPORTUNITY, AS
WELL AS OUR AGENCY DEPARTMENT
PARTNERS ON HOW WE ARE
INCORPORATING THOSE IDEAS INTO
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE PLAN. NOW
IS THE TIME TO TAKE ACTION TO
POSITION CALIFORNIA TO COMPETE
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS AND TO CREATE
HIGH QUALITY JOBS ALONG THE WAY
THAT BRINGS OUR ECONOMIES
TOGETHER. WITH THAT. I'D LIKE TO
INVITE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE ON THE DÍAS TO SAY A FEW
WORDS BEFORE WE OPEN UP THE
PANELS. SENATOR Dð RASO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I
JUST WANT TO, UM REMIND US S¼ B
150 REALLY IS THE RESULT OF
YEARS OF WORKING ON THESE ISSUES
. IT IS A VERY SIMPLE THING. WE
HAVE BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WILL BE SPENT ARE
BEING SPENT BY THE STATE BY THE
FEDERAL THE LOCAL LEVEL. UM AND
THERE ARE NOT IN MOST MANY CASES
ANY ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS AS FAR
AS CREATING JOB QUALITY. UH, THE
QUALITY OF THE JOBS, UM, LIKE
THEIR WAGES, THEIR BENEFITS, UH,
WORKING CONDITIONS. UM AND WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THESE ARE TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THEY
TAXPAYERS EXPECT THE MOST OUT OF
THEIR DOLLARS AND MOST MEANS,
INCLUDING ALL COMMUNITIES. THAT
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THOSE JOBS,
UM HAVE GOOD JOBS SO, AND JOB
CREATION IS NOT AT THE MINIMUM
LEVEL HERE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
JOB CREATION OF GOOD JOBS. UM
AND I ALSO WANT TO MAKE THE
OTHER POINT THAT ANOTHER VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS B 150
THAT IN LINE WITH OUR
CONSTRUCTION JOBS, WHERE WE HAVE
MUCH MORE, UM, CAPACITY AND, UH,
EXPERIENCE AND FA WITH HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT CONSTRUCTION JOBS
ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS, THE UNION
JOBS UH WE HAVE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT EXPERIENCE AT THE STATE
LEVEL WITH OUR NON CONSTRUCTION
JOBS. WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT. WE'RE MISSING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD AND
MANUFACTURE AND PRODUCE AS WELL
AS THE LONG TERM MAINTENANCE AND
SERVICING JOBS. ALL THAT
TOGETHER. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING HOW THE COMPONENTS UH S¼
B 150 WILL LEAD TO A MODEL
POLICY AND WE CAN APPLY IT TO
ALL OUR STATE PROCUREMENT. SO
WITH THAT, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
WHO'S PARTICIPATED IN THIS OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. BRIEFLY I AM
HERE BECAUSE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE TOPIC. UM I THINK TO THE
STATE AND TO ME PERSONALLY, AND
I KNOW THAT WE CAN DO THIS AND
THERE ARE SOME GOOD EXAMPLES OF
IT, BUT WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE
OF IT, AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT AND EXCITED TO BE
HERE. THANK YOU. OK IF THERE ARE
NÓ OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK, WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN AND WE WILL HEAR PANELISTS
AS THEY APPEAR IN THE AGENDA
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT, SO LET'S BEGIN BY
ASKING OUR PANELISTS TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THE FIRST PANEL IS
ON RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REDUCING
POVERTY THROUGH HIGH QUALITY
JOBS AND TRAINING. UH AND THAT
INCLUDES, UH MADELINE JANIS, CO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF JOBS TO
MOVE AMERICA AND ELDER SOLOMON
POLICY MANAGERS FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BLACK WORKER
HUB. THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING
US. CAN YOU HEAR ME? OK, NOW CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW? OK, UM SO I.
HAVE THE. POWERPOINT. DO I OH,
HELLO. MY NAME IS MADELINE
JANICE. TRY MINE. THE RED LIGHT
IS ON. SHOULD I MOVE OVER HERE?
YES.
HELLO. THIS IS MADELINE JANICE.
NÓ. I HAVE THAT QUINTESSENTIAL
LOW FEMALE VOICE. THAT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY CARRY IN HEARINGS.
BUT THAT DOES NOT INDICATE A
LACK OF PASSION ON MY PART. SO
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL HEAR ME. YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR ME. UM AND
AS. UH, I WOULD. I DO WANNA PUT
UP. IS THERE ANYTHING I NEED TO
DO HERE TO PUT UP THE SLIDES? OK
SO MY I WOULD JUST, UH THERE WE
GO. SO, UM, I AM I AM A LAWYER
BY TRAINING. I AM THE CO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF JOBS TO
MOVE AMERICA, WHICH IS A
NATIONAL, UH, ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS AROUND INDUSTRIAL POLICY
AND ORGANIZING MANUFACTURING
JOBS. UH AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
UNIONS, INCLUDING UAW. UM UH, ON
OUR BOARD. I'M GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE CAN TAKE THIS
MOMENT AND MAKE IT ONE THAT
REALLY SETS UP HISTORY TO SHOW
THAT WE CAN HAVE GOOD
MANUFACTURING JOBS IN THIS
COUNTRY. NOW I THINK MY VOICE
CAME ON, UM UH, HOW WE CAN DO
HOW WE CAN USE THIS INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU ALL HAVE,
UH, AS AS OUR LEADERS IN THE
SENATE, UM AND IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THE MONEY
THAT YOU ARE SPENDING ON THAT WE
ARE SPENDING AND TURN THAT INTO
A REAL WIN WIN WIN. UM I ALSO
SERVE, UH, AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX
CREDIT COMMITTEE. UH AND I HAVE
SERVED IN THAT CAPACITY SINCE
2015. SO I HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE ON THINGS THAT HAVE
WORKED AND THINGS THAT HAVE NOT
WORKED. UH, SO AND I WILL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. SO NEXT
SLIDE. UM. GIVE UP ON THE
POWERPOINT THING. HERE WE GO.
YOU SPACE PARK. BASE BAR. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, I'M NOT GONNA WASTE
TIME. I WILL JUST GO KEEP GOING.
SO I JUST WANNA TAKE US BACK TO
THE GOALS. THE CENTRAL GOALS OF
SB 150, BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR YOU ALL AS YOU
GET TO THIS MOMENT IN TIME WHEN
YOU'RE GONNA DECIDE WHAT TO DO.
AND REALLY WHAT S¼ B 150 DID. IS
IT KIND OF SET UP THE WIN WIN
WIN? THAT WE ALL ASPIRE TO
ACHIEVE, WHICH IS AND THE CORE
PART I'M TALKING ABOUT IS THE
PART THAT DEALS WITH PERMANENT
JOBS AND MANUFACTURING JOBS.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO WORK WITH
WHEN IT COMES TO CONSTRUCTION
JOBS, ALTHOUGH THERE'S STILL A
LOT MORE TO DO, UM, AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE, UH, BUILDING
TRADES WILL TALK ABOUT, UM, BUT
THE GOALS OF S¼ P 150 REALLY ARE
ABOUT CREATING EQUITY AND HIGH
ROAD UNIONIZED MANUFACTURING
JOBS AND CLEAN TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. UM BUILDING UP
COMMUNITIES FOSTERING ACCESS AS
THE CHAIR AS MADAM CHAIR YOU
TALKED ABOUT AND REALLY YOU HAVE
TWO TOOLS. AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THIS IS NOT THAT
COMPLICATED. UM THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT MAKE IT SOUND
COMPLICATED, BUT AS A LAWYER WHO
HAS BEEN WORKING ON PUBLIC
PROCUREMENT FOR DECADES, I CAN
TELL YOU YOU HAVE TWO TOOLS. ONE
TOOL IS PUBLIC PROCUREMENT IS
THE MASSIVE NUMBERS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT THE STATE WILL
BE PURCHASING THAT CITIES
COUNTIES, SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
BE PURCHASING TO MEET A CLIMATE
GOALS THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THAT
YOU HAVE SET FOR US. UM THE
SECOND TOOL IS SMALLER. BUT IT
IS THE LOANS THAT SUBSIDIES THE
TAX CREDITS THAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN HELPING BUSINESS TO
BUILD THE KIND OF INDUSTRY WE
WANT TO SEE. SO WHAT CAN YOU
ACCOMPLISH THROUGH THESE TWO
TOOLS? PUBLIC PROCUREMENT, UH,
AND SUBSIDIES? SO THAT'S WHAT IN
AN S¼ B 150. WE HAVE ALL BEEN
HOPING TO SEE. LET'S ENGAGE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS. LET'S
FIGURE OUT. WHAT CAN YOU DO
AROUND PROCUREMENT? WHAT CAN YOU
DO AROUND TOOLS LIKE HOW
COMPETES AND OTHERS? UM
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PROCESS THAT
WE'VE SEEN SO FAR HAS NOT BEEN,
UH, IN INCLUDED IN THE IN THE
INCLUSIVE, DEEPER DIALOGUE THAT
WE WERE HOPING FOR, AND JUST TO
BE DIRECT. STRAIGHTFORWARD WITH
YOU. HEARINGS THAT TOOK PLACE IN
DECEMBER WERE AROUND THE
HOLIDAYS. THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF
NOTICE. THERE WAS NOT. THERE ARE
NOT A LOT OF GROUPS THAT WERE
ABLE TO ATTEND OR PARTICIPATE.
UH AND THE PRESENTATIONS WERE
REALLY MORE ABOUT WHAT IS
ALREADY BEING DONE RATHER THAN
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THE WIN WIN WIN GOAL
OF S¼ B 150. AND I JUST WANNA
PUT THE STAKES UP THERE FOR YOU
BECAUSE IT COULDN'T BE CLEARER
TO MANY OF US WHO ARE TALKING TO
WORKERS AND VISITING THESE
FACTORIES. IF WE DON'T USE THE
PROCUREMENT POWER TO ENSURE THAT
COMPANIES THAT ARE RECEIVING THE
MONEY OR OR GETTING CONTRACTS
ARE CREATING GOOD JOBS AND
EQUITY AND OPPORTUNITY WHEREVER
THEY'RE BEING BUILT IN THE
UNITED STATES. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A SITUATION LIKE WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW WITH A COMPANY, FOR EXAMPLE,
LIKE HYUNDAI NOW HYUNDAI SELLS
THE CHEAPEST E VÆ S¼, UM AROUND
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE
SHOPPED. HYUNDAI UM, IS BASED
THEIR NATIONAL HEADQUARTERS IS
IN CALIFORNIA, ALTHOUGH THEIR
MAIN MANUFACTURING FACILITIES
ARE IN ALABAMA. UH, THEY'RE NOW
BUILDING, UH, FACTORIES IN
GEORGIA. HYUNDAI HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATED REPEATEDLY FOR THE
USE OF CHILD LABOR THROUGHOUT
ITS SUPPLY CHAIN A AND, UM, AS
WE'RE SEEING, THERE ARE
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE SOUTH
THAT ARE LEGALIZING. THEY'RE
LOWERING REPEATEDLY THE AGE AT
WHICH CHILDREN CAN WORK. SO IT'S
NOT EVEN THAT HYUNDAI IS DOING
SOMETHING ILLEGAL. ALTHOUGH THEY
ARE IT'S THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SET THE STANDARD
FOR THE COUNTRY BASED ON WHAT
YOU BUY. SO RIGHT NOW. WE ARE WE
HAVE ALL THE STATE AGENCIES THAT
ARE THERE BUILDING UP. THEY'RE
PURCHASING. THEY'RE GETTING
READY TO MOVE AND WITHOUT STATE
ACTION, WE ARE GONNA BE LEAVING
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS ON THE
TABLE. SO I JUST WANNA GIVE YOU
THE LAST THING I WANNA SAY IS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS TEED
UP A PROGRAM FOR YOU TO USE THAT
IS AVAILABLE FOR STATES TO
IMPLEMENT SO THE UNLIKE ON THE
CONSTRUCTION SIDE, WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHERE
CONGRESS PUT IN THINGS LIKE
PREVAILING WAGE AN
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS ON THE
MANUFACTURING SIDE, THERE IS
NOTHING IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
WILL GUARANTEE ANYTHING,
NOTHING. HOWEVER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS, UM TEED UP
SOME AMAZING TOOLS FOR YOU TO
USE. UM, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY HAS
DEVELOPED SOMETHING CALLED
COMMUNITY BENEFITS PLANS, WHICH
ARE BASED ON THE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS AGREEMENT THAT WE MADE
UP THAT WE CAME UP WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. UM THEY'RE GIVING
20% CREDIT ON ANY GRANT OR LOAN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE. WHY
AT CALC PETE'S WERE STARTING TO
SEE A LOT OF SEMICONDUCTOR
PROPOSALS. UH BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE IS
REQUIRING A STATE MATCH AND THEY
HAVE GOOD JOB STANDARDS. SO
COMPANIES ARE APPLYING TO OUR
STATE AGENCIES. SO YOU HAVE
THOSE THINGS LAID OUT AND SUPER
EXCITING. WITH THE HELP OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP, AND I HAVE A LITTLE
A LITTLE HANDOUT. THE WEEK OF
MARCH, 11TH. THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL BE
RELEASING. AN UPDATED VERSION OF
THE UNIFORM GRANTS GUIDANCE,
WHICH ARE THE RULES THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MUST FOLLOW.
IF YOU'RE IF AND WHEN YOU'RE
USING STATE MONEY, AND THESE NEW
RULES ELIMINATE, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE HISTORIC OR THE TERRIBLE.
UM, LONG, LONG STANDING
PROHIBITION ON LOCAL HIRE. THEY
ALLOW FOR JOB SCORING IN THE
PURCHASE OF MANUFACTURED GOODS
THEY ALLOW THEY ENCOURAGE THEY
ENCOURAGE TARGETED HIRING EQUITY
SUSTAINABILITY. THESE NEW RULES
WERE GONNA ARE GONNA BE MADE
PUBLIC AND FINALIZED THE WEEK OF
MARCH 11TH THERE YOU HAVE IT.
YOU WILL HAVE A WHOLE PROGRAM
SET OUT FOR YOU TO USE NÓ LEGAL
ISSUES AT ALL WITH YOUR FEDERAL
DOLLARS. IT'S REALLY UP TO YOU.
WE'RE COUNTING ON YOU TO MAKE
THESE POLICIES A REALITY SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE THE KIND OF HIGH
ROAD FACTORIES THAT WE HAD 75
YEARS AGO. WE NEED THEM AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MS APARICIO FOR THAT,
UH, PRESENTATION. NOW WE WILL GO
TO THE SOLOMON WITH A BLACK
WORKER HUB. GOOD AFTERNOON. CAN
YOU HEAR ME? GOOD AFTERNOON.
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE. I AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ELDA SOLOMON
. I AM THE POLICY MANAGER OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BLACK WORKER
HUB FOR REGIONAL ORGANIZING,
WHICH IS ANCHORED BY THE LOS
ANGELES BLACK WORKERS CENTER AND
IS IN A NETWORK OF A BLACK OF A
DOZEN BLACK, LEAD AND BLACK
CENTERED ORGANIZATIONS SERVING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION.
THE MISSION OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BLACK WORKER HUB IS
TO EXPAND THE FIELD OF WORKER
ORGANIZING TO UNIFY BLACK WORKER
VOICE, UM AND POWER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND. WE STAND
AS REGIONAL AUTHORITY ON THE
COMPLEX. AND MYRIAD ISSUES AND
EXPERIENCES THAT BLACK WORKERS
AND OTHER VULNERABLE WORKERS
FACE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF OUR LAND, LONG
STANDING WORK, COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING AND ENGAGEMENT WITH
COMMUNITY AND OUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH FEDERAL, STATE AND LOCAL
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
POLICY. THE SOKAL HUB CONTINUES
TO BE DEEPLY ENGAGED IN NATIONAL
AND STATEWIDE COALITION SPACES
WITH FOLKS LIKE JOBS TO MOVE
AMERICA, UH, THE BETTER FOR ALL
COALITIONS STEERED BY UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS UNITED AND THE NATIONAL
BLACK WORKERS CENTER, WORKING TO
ENSURE EQUITY STANDARDS
THROUGHOUT THE BIDEN HARRISON
ADMINISTRATION'S ONCE IN A
GENERATION INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BLACK WORKER HUB,
WORKS CLOSELY WITH REGIONAL
BLACK WORKER CENTERS AND ENGAGE
WITH THOUSANDS OF BLACK WORKERS
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION IN ORDER FOR THE STATE TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN CREATING GOOD
QUALITY JOBS. WE BELIEVE IT MUST
ADDRESS THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF
ENSURING THAT COMMUNITIES
HARDEST HIT BY THE CENTURIES OF
ECONOMIC EXCLUSION AND RECESSION
, PARTICULARLY BLACK WORKERS
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO THE HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF TRADES AND
CONSTRUCTION INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS
THAT WILL BE CREATED IN THIS
COMING DECADE AND BEYOND. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL GIVEN THE
HISTORICAL AND ONGOING
DISCRIMINATION AND EXCLUSION OF
BLACK WORKERS IN THESE KINDS OF
INDUSTRIES AND TRADES THAT HAS
LED TO THEIR CURRENT AND SEVERE
UNDERREPRESENTATION FROM THE
PUBLIC WORKS, CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND OTHER PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE UPCOMING
INVESTMENTS FROM FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
TRANSFORMATIVE WORKFORCE
ADVANCEMENTS AND, AS A RESULT
SPUR ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR BLACK
FAMILIES, BLACK COMMUNITIES AND
OTHER OTHER REPRESENTED WORKERS.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THESE
UPCOMING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
MAKE INTENTIONAL AND REASONABLE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR BLACK
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE SHOULDERED
A LONG HISTORY OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION AND EXCLUSION IN
THE WORKFORCE. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALREADY BOLDLY
TAKEN THE POSITION THAT
REGARDING RACIAL AND GENDER
EQUITY, UM AND IT'S PROFOUND
EFFECT ON THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND ON THE WORK. AND
BEYOND. WE CAN CONNECT A NETWORK
OF BLACK WORKER CENTERS IN THE
REGION. THE LOS ANGELES BLACK
WORKERS CENTER, THE INLAND
EMPIRE BLACK WORKERS CENTER, UH,
AND THE SAN DIEGO BLACK WORKERS
CENTER WITH TWO NEW BLACK WORKER
CENTERS AS WELL IN THE HIGH
DESERT AND LONG BEACH. UH, THE
LOS ANGELES BACK WORKERS CENTER,
OUR LONGEST STANDING HAS BEEN
ORGANIZING THE BLACK WORKER
COMMUNITY SINCE 2009 AND HAS
CREATED A NUMBER OF PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC BARRIERS
THAT KEEP BLACK WORKERS FROM
QUALITY. GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
THEY ARE READY TO WORK PROGRAM
IS A SERIES OF WORKSHOPS AND JOB
SKILLS TRAIN. AND INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC MENTORSHIP TO BLACK
WORKERS FILLING IN THE GAPS OF
TRADITIONAL W Ó PROGRAMS AT A
TIME WHEN THE STATE IS DIVESTING
FROM WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDS. FOR BLACK WORKERS,
EXCLUSION FROM THE TRADES AND
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIES OF
CENTURIES LONG AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN GOOD JOBS OR
OPPORTUNITIES IN THESE
COMMUNITIES FOR DECADES AND
GENERATIONS AND CENTURIES. FOR
EXAMPLE, THE U S¼ BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS INDICATES THAT
WHILE BLACK PEOPLE COMPRISE 12%
OF THE WORKFORCE, THEY MAKE UP
ONLY 6% OF THE WORKFORCE IN
CONSTRUCTION NUMBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN RELATIVELY UNCHANGED FOR
THREE DECADES. BECAUSE OF THIS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPACT OF
CENTURIES OF DISCRIMINATION AND
EXCLUSION, THE STATE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT INVESTMENTS MUST
BE STRATEGIC AND INTENTIONAL.
THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN SYSTEMICALLY EXCLUDED
FROM THE WORK FORCE ARE UNIQUE
AND INCLUDE LONGER TRAINING,
TIMES, MENTORSHIP TRAUMA,
INFORMED CURRICULUM AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE FOR YOU KNOW, CARE
PROVIDERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STANDS AS ONE OF THE
LARGEST ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD
AND SIMILAR TO MANY OTHER
AMERICAN CITIES, WHERE INDUSTRY
HAS HISTORICALLY REPRESENTED A
BULK OF ECONOMIC PRODUCTION AND
OPPORTUNITY. MANY REGIONS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE RELIED ON
INDUSTRY IN THE PAST CENTURY AND
INCLUDE AREAS LIKE SOUTHERN
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES, WHERE
WE'RE SEEING DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGH LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
POVERTY. WE HAVE REACHED A
CRITICAL FORK IN THE ROAD. THE
ECONOMY IS SHIFTING FROM SERVICE
TO GREEN ECONOMY. AND WITH THIS
ONCE IN A GENERATION INVESTMENT,
WE MUST BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT THE
WAYS WE SHOW UP FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN WELL REPRESENTED
IN THE WORKFORCE AND IN THE
LUCRATIVE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
SECTORS THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY
PAVED A WAY FOR MIDDLE CLASS
LIFE. FOR MANY OF AMERICANS AND
CALIFORNIANS. AN EXAMPLE OF THIS
TYPE OF SHIFT IS IN SOUTH
CENTRAL, UH, NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
WAS ONCE THRIVING WHERE THE
NUMBER ONE EMPLOYER WAS HEAVY
MANUFACTURING, SHIFTING FROM
REGULATED WORK, UNIONIZED WORK
TO DEIONIZE WORK AND ACROSS THE
STATE. REGION AND MET OTHERS
LIKE IT HAVE EXPERIENCED A
SIMILAR SHIFT. UM WHERE WE'RE
SEEING INCREASINGLY, UM, YOU
KNOW, BEING DESTABILIZED BY A
SERVICE ECONOMY THAT IS LOW WAGE
, NON UNION UNREGULATED AND
DANGEROUS, FRANKLY FOR WORKERS
AND THE IMPORTANT EFFORTS TO TRY
AND RECTIFY THESE CHANGES BY
RAISING THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
RAISING STANDARDS FOR WORKERS IN
THIS INDUSTRY ARE NOT ENOUGH.
AND THAT IS THAT IS NOT TO
MENTION JUST HOW THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED THESE
ALREADY EXISTING AND CONVERGING
ISSUES AND CRISES AND THE HAVOC
THAT IT HAS WRECKED ON THE
ECONOMY, PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
WORKERS WHO DO NOT HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
THE FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCES OF
BLACK WORKERS AND CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ALSO DEMONSTRATE THE
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION THAT
PERSISTS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
SECTOR, AND THAT ALSO PERSISTS
IN OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT HINDER
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
WORKFORCE. THIS IS JUST ONE
ACCOUNT FROM ONE WORKER, JAMES,
A 40 YEAR OLD BLACK JOURNEYMAN
IN THE SHEET METAL INDUSTRY, HE
SAYS ON THE JOB AT THE W HOTEL
IN HOLLYWOOD, THERE WERE MORE
THAN 100 WORKERS ON THE PROJECT,
AND ONLY FOUR OF THEM WERE
BLACK. I'VE BEEN ON JOBS WHERE
THE PROJECT MANAGER
SUPERINTENDENT AND FOREMAN WERE
ALL RELATED OR THE CREWS ARE
MADE UP OF FAMILY FRIENDS, MANY
OF WHOM WHO SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE. IN OTHER WORDS, TOO
OFTEN THERE ARE CULTURAL
PREFERENCES THAT EXIST IN THE
CULTURAL IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. AND WHEN I GET SENT TO
THE JOB, IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF
TIME BEFORE I'M LAID OFF WITHOUT
CAUSE. THIS IS JUST ONE STORY
AND ONE EXPERIENCE, BUT IT
ILLUMINATES A LARGER PATTERN AND
TREND THAT BLACK WORKERS ARE
EXPERIENCING AND AGAIN THESE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE MEANT TO AND
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT FOR WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES. AND WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN THERE. THE LOS ANGELES
BLACK WORKER CENTER PLAYED A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN ENSURING THAT
BLACK WORKERS IN THE CRENSHAW
DISTRICT HAD ACCESS TO JOBS ON
THE BUILDING OF THE CRENSHAW
METRO LINE IN WORKING WITH THE
LOS ANGELES BLACK WORKERS
CENTER, L, A COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION ADOPTED THE P
CONSTRUCTION CARRIERS POLICY AND
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT, PL TO
ENCOURAGE CONSTRUCTION,
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES TO THOSE WHO
RESIDE IN ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREAS ON THE METRO
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. THE
AGREEMENT APPLIES TO CERTAIN
LOCAL FUNDED AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED CONSTRUCTION PROGRAMS
WITH A CONSTRUCTION VALUE
GREATER THAN 2.5 MILLION. IN
THIS HISTORIC CAMPAIGN,
RESULTING IN STRONGER FEDERAL
CIVIL RIGHTS, LANGUAGE AND
DISADVANTAGED WORKER CRITERIA,
AS WELL AS OTHER STRATEGIES FOR
DIVERSITY IMPLEMENTATION
AGREEMENT. WE SAW AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF BLACK WORKERS ON
THE CRENSHAW LAX LINE FROM 0 TO
20% IN 2015. THE CIVIL WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER ALSO
THE MODEL SET BY THE FEDERAL OCC
P, THE OFFICE OF FEDERAL
CONTRACT COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS AND
THEIR MEGA CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
AND HOW WE CAN UTILIZE SIMILAR
AGENCIES TO BE IN FACT,
IMPACTFUL IN ENSURING EQUITY ON
THESE PROJECTS IN THE PRE BID
PRE JOB PROCESS. UM WE RECOGNIZE
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DIVISION
DEPARTMENT AND HOW IT UH, CAN
ONLY PLAY A PART IN ENFORCING
DISCRIMINATION POLICY, BUT ALSO
CONTRACTING PROCUREMENT
EQUITABLY TO MAXIMIZE MAXIMIZE
BENEFITS TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS WORK, UM AND POSITION FOR
THE AGENCY WOULD EXPAND èC R
D'S ROLE IN THAT REGARD, UM,
WHERE WE SEE THE GREATEST
COMPLIANCE FROM FEDERAL
CONTRACTORS AND OTHER OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING ON THESE
FEDERAL CONTRACTS? UM WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT SEES THE GREATEST
OUTCOMES OF CONTRACT COMPLIANCE
AND ROBUST EQUITY STANDARDS IS
IN THIS MEGA CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT WHERE Ó FCC èC P
PROVIDES SUBSTANTIAL
INTERVENTION TO ENSURE THAT
CONTRACT PROCUREMENT OCCURS
EQUITABLY AND BENEFITS ALL
WORKERS. WITH PARTICULAR
CONSIDERATION FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY AND SYSTEMATICALLY
EXCLUDED FROM CONSTRUCTION. AS
COMPARED TO CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT ARE NOT PART OF
THE M èC P, WHERE COMPLIANCE IS
UNDER MONITORED AND UN ASSURED
AND SO AGAIN. THIS IS JUST ONE
MODEL WHERE WE SEE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOING WELL. IT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT MADELINE HAD
MENTIONED DOING WELL TO SHOW US
WHAT YOU KNOW WE CAN DO TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE AND EQUITY.
SOLOMON YOU HAVE 30 SECONDS
LEFT. OK, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. UM IF WE WANT TO ENSURE
EQUITY, WE MUST FIR FIRST ENSURE
COMPLIANCE AND COMPLIANCE TOOLS
ARE DRASTICALLY NEEDED AND
SHOULD SEEK TO ESTABLISH,
COLLECT AND DISSEMINATE DATA
SETS, FORMS REPORTING AND
TRACKING PROCESSES OF WORKFORCE
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
PROCUREMENT ANALYTICS. THE STATE
MUST BE DILIGENT IN BUILDING A
REAL PLAN TOWARDS EQUITY, ONE
THAT USES MODELS OF SUCCESS THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED WILL WORK TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS. WE NEED TO
MECHANISMS OF ENFORCEMENT THAT
ARE RIGOROUS EQUITY FOCUSED AND
PRODUCTIVE. WE URGE THE
GOVERNOR, LEGISLATURE AND STATE
AGENCIES TO THAT THERE IS NÓ
COMPREHENSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT WITHOUT A
CONSIDERATION FOR EQUITY ACCESS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISS
SOLOMON FOR THAT TESTIMONY, AND
I WILL NOW TURN TO, UH, MY
COLLEAGUES. DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL LIST? THANK YOU. UM I
WANNA THANK SENATOR SMALLWOOD,
CUEVAS AND FELLOW COLLEAGUES AND
PANELISTS AND STAFF FOR ALL THE
CO ORDINATION AND PREPARATION
FOR TODAY'S JOINT HEARING. UM,
THIS IS MY FIRST HEARING AS
CHAIR OF SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE, FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY, THE JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION. AND SO I WANT TO
SHARE MY EXPECTATIONS OF TODAY'S
HEARINGS IN PARTICULAR, UM I
KNOW WE ARE HERE TO GET
INFORMATION FROM YOU ALL, UM OR
AND WHERE WE ARE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS AND
ONGOING CHALLENGES AND MOST
CRITICALLY RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ACHIEVABLE AS YOU SAID, UH,
POLICIES THAT CAN MOVE FORWARD.
AFTER TODAY'S DISCUSSION, I WILL
SAY THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
RECEIPT OF A $50 MILLION
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
SB 150 IMPLEMENTATION. I EXPECT
TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT PROPOSAL
IN OUR THIRD PANEL, BUT, UM I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
CONVERSATION AS A WHOLE. THE
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I DID HAVE
FOR YOU ALL. UM YOU KNOW, I
COVERED EQUITY FOR BLACK WORKERS
IN CONSTRUCTION. AND YOU
POTENTIALLY, UH, PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF, UM,
RECOMMENDATIONS. UH, THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE IN REGARD TO
CONSTRUCTION AS ONE PIECE, BUT
WHEN WE ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE
SPLINTERING OF JOBS AND KIND OF
CONTRACTING OUT NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO IS, UH I'M GONNA SAY,
UH. YOU KNOW, TECHNOLOGY KIND OF
TAKING OVER SOME JOBS, AND WE
SEE EVEN WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MODULAR CONSTRUCTION WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IMPORTING
FROM NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES. SOME
OF THESE THESE POTENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION SITES AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO ADVANCE,
LET'S SAY HOUSING AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS AND REDUCING COST WOULD
EITHER OF YOU GUYS BE ABLE TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT KIND OF
THE DEBATE IN REGARDS TO THE
FUTURE? OF CONSTRUCTION.
TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT, IS MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE HAVE JOBS. I AM
HAPPY TO, UM I'M HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT THE PRACTICAL TOOLS THAT
YOU HAVE AT YOUR DISPOSAL BASED
ON WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS ALLOWING, AND PERMITTING AND
ENCOURAGING. UM, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY MOST OF THIS MONEY AND
NOT ALL OF IT BUT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THIS MONEY IS COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
THERE'S A YOU KNOW, SOME OF US
REFER TO IT AS THE $1 RULE, BUT
BASICALLY $1 OF FEDERAL FUNDING
FUNDING TOUCHES THE POT. THE
FEDERAL RULES APPLY. SO THE
QUESTION IS, WHAT CAN YOU DO? TO
ENSURE THE BEST OUTCOMES IN WHAT
YOU'RE PLANNING ON EITHER
PURCHASING OR INVESTING IN SO IN
CONSTRUCTION, AND UH AND I. I
KNOW THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE HERE
WHO HAVE A LOT OF REALLY GREAT
EXPERIENCES, UM, INCLUDING MY CO
PANELIST, BUT IN CONSTRUCTION,
THE GOAL I MEAN, THERE ARE
SEVERAL GOLD STANDARDS. UM THE
GOLD STANDARD IS PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT, ALSO KNOWN AS A
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENT
THAT BUILDS IN TARGETED HIRE. SO
. YOU HAVE A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT, WHICH BASICALLY SAYS
THAT THIS PROJECT WHATEVER THE
BIG INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IS
GOING TO PULL FROM
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GAINING THE SKILLS,
AND THEY'RE BECOMING JOURNEY
PEOPLE, AND IT'S TURN
TRANSITIONING FROM A TEMPORARY
JOB TO A PERMANENT JOB. UH,
BASICALLY TO, YOU KNOW, ONGOING
JOB AND YOU HAVE TARGETED HIGHER
BUILT IN WHICH MEANS THAT 20%
FOR EXAMPLE, UM, OF ALL THE
PREMISES. COME FROM HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. NOW IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE PROP 209 SO
WE CAN'T SAY BLACK WORKERS. BUT
WE CAN SAY, UH, FORMERLY
INCARCERATED OR RETURNING
CITIZENS. WE CAN SAY SINGLE
PARENT FAMILIES. WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF GOOD WORK TO COME UP WITH
EUPHEMISMS OR BASICALLY
DESCRIPTIONS OF MARGINALIZATION.
UM, THAT HAVE PASSED MUSTER. SO
ON THE CONSTRUCTION SIDE, AND
ELI METRO'S THE L, A
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES CONSTRUCTION CAREERS
POLICY, WHICH IS THE P. IT'S A
MODEL. IT'S AN AMAZING MODEL.
IT'S HAD TREMENDOUS SUCCESS. I
MEAN, 20% WOMEN. I MEAN, WOMEN
ARE EVEN SCARCER THAN THAN
PEOPLE OF COLOR ON CONSTRUCTION
SITES ON THE PERMANENT JOBS AND
NÓ. WE ARE HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THINGS LIKE A I AND WE'RE HAVING
TO DEAL WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES,
BUT THERE ARE ALSO A TON OF NEW
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT. THERE'S
EVERYTHING FROM, YOU KNOW ALL
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AROUND, UM
ELECTRIC VEHICLES MINING LITHIUM
LITHIUM VALLEY NOW, UH, TWO
BATTERIES TO ALL THE COMPONENT
PARTS. THERE'S UH, COMMITMENT
THAT, UH, THAT ONLY YOU CAN ONLY
PURCHASE WITH BUY AMERICA. UM
CONNECTION. SO IN OTHER WORDS,
THERE'S ALREADY A PUSH FOR
EVERYTHING TO BE MADE IN THE U
S¼. NOW IT'S MADE IN ALABAMA. OR
IT'S MADE IN ARKANSAS. BUT YOU
CAN INCLUDE STANDARDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE GOOD JOBS
WHEREVER THEY ARE. AND
INCREASINGLY NOW, WITH THESE NEW
RULES, YOU CAN ACTUALLY SAY BY
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THEY ARE
TAKING OFF THE RESTRICTION ON
GEOGRAPHIC PREFERENCE. USED TO
BE THAT YOU COULDN'T SAY AND IT
IS NOW YOU CAN'T SAY IN THIS
PURCHASE. WE WANT THE, UM THE
EQUIPMENT TO BE MADE IN
CALIFORNIA. UM, BUT NOW, WITH
THESE NEW RULES, YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO I, UM,
THERE ARE THERE'S A MENU OF
OPTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. TO CHOOSE
FROM, UM, AND IT'S NOT PERFECT,
BUT IT'S GONNA GO A LONG WAY IN
CONSTRUCTION. RIGHT NOW. THERE
IS A TREND WHERE THERE'S A LOT
OF GENERAL CONTRACTORS THAT
RECRUIT FROM OTHER STATES,
SPECIFICALLY PAYING THEM LOWER
WAGES BY CALIFORNIA STANDARDS
BUT PAYING THEM LET'S SAY HIGHER
WAGES BY OTHER STATES STANDARD,
RIGHT? UM HOW DO WE CIRCUMVENT
THAT? BECAUSE THAT YOU KNOW,
THESE ARE LOOPHOLES THAT WE
CONSISTENT SEE WHERE, UM. LET'S
BE HONEST PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR PROFITS AND
STRETCH EVERY DOLLAR. UM, AND
YET EVEN WITH THIS IN PLACE,
RIGHT? UM BY THE STATEWIDE
STANDARD. WE DO NOT HAVE A P IN
PLACE, THE STANDARD, RIGHT WE DO
NOT HAVE, UM, CITY OVER CITY
OVER CITY AND WITH STANDARDS. WE
ALSO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT, UM,
EQUITY TO YOUR POINT, UM, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S A LOT OF WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION IN MY DISTRICT
THAT, UM THEY CONCERN IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE JOB, BUT YOU
KNOW, AFTER LET'S SAY A
PREGNANCY, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN'T
NECESSARILY LIFT £50 FOR A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME. OR, YOU
KNOW, THESE ARE THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY'VE SHARED WITH ME. UM,
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO REALLY
PROTECT THEM THERE AND THEN ALSO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE HOLDING THE
GENERAL CONTRACTORS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOME OF THESE MANEUVERING
THROUGH OUR LAWS. WELL, I YOU
KNOW IT. OBVIOUSLY. ALSO LIKE MY
CO PANELISTS TO TALK ABOUT IT,
BUT I THINK THERE IT'S ANY
PROGRAM. WHERE WE WANT TO USE
POLICY. UH AND, YOU KNOW, SET
THE RULES GET THE RULES RIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE AN INSIDE
AND AN OUTSIDE STRATEGY. SO THE
INSIDE STRATEGY IS YOU GET THE
RULES, RIGHT? YOU SET UP THE
REQUIREMENTS. EVERY TIME THERE'S
A REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS, OR
EVERY TIME THERE'S AN INVITATION
FOR BIDS. UH THAT GOES OUT THAT
IT HAS CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE, UH, THAT SIGN YOU HAVE
TO SIGN ON TO THE PL A. YOU HAVE
TO DO TARGETED HIRING. YOU HAVE
TO AGREE TO CERTAIN MONITORING
AND ENFORCEMENT. AND THEN YOU
HAVE OUTSIDE GROUPS BECAUSE
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF. WORKING FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
GONNA BE ABLE TO DO ALL THE
ENFORCEMENT. SO YOU NEED US. BE
ABLE TO DO OUR JOBS. BUT IF YOU
SET IT UP I GUARANTEE YOU ALL
THESE PEOPLE IN HERE, WE'RE
GOING TO BE THERE. WE'RE GOING
TO BE HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AND NOT ONLY THAT WORKERS ARE
GOING TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE WORKERS ARE GOING TO USE
THESE POLICIES AND THEY'RE GOING
TO ORGANIZE UP A STORM. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE THIS STATE
AND THIS COUNTRY. SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL ASPIRE TO. SO UM, II, I
WOULD SAY YOU YOU GOT THE TOOLS
AND WE CAN MAKE THIS CON WE CAN
MAKE THIS CONVOLUTED. WE CAN
MAKE IT CONFUSING, BUT IT REALLY
IS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD. GET
THE RULES RIGHT AND LET US DO
OUR JOB. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT? YES I
WOULD. YEAH AND JUST TO JUST TO
ADD, I THINK YOU KNOW, THROUGH
ALL OF THE CONDITIONS YOU HAD,
UH, YOU KNOW YOU HAD MENTIONED I
THINK THERE IS A DIRECT
REGULATORY SOLUTION AND REALLY,
THE SOLUTION IS TO STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN THE STATE IF
WOMEN WHO ARE WORKING IN
CONSTRUCTION ARE FOR IN FEAR OF
BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OR
BEING RETALIATED AGAINST. WE
NEED TO HAVE MECHANISMS WITHIN
THE STATE THAT BOLSTER
ENFORCEMENT. BOLSTER REGULATION,
UH, CREATE, UM, ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS THAT WORKERS KNOW
THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE THAT EXIST
FOR THEM IN THEIR OWN REGIONS,
AND THAT THEY CAN UNDERSTAND
WILL ACTUALLY HAVE REAL REDRESS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THEMSELVES ON THE OTHER SIDE. UM
TOO MANY WORKERS, YOU KNOW THAT
WE HEAR FROM, UH, JOSE. I FILED
A CLAIM OR I'VE YOU KNOW, I'VE
SUBMITTED A REQUEST OR A
COMPLAINT TO THIS AGENCY OR
THAT, BUT THEY DON'T HEAR
ANYTHING ON THE BACKSIDE OR THEY
DON'T HEAR ANYTHING THAT IS
SUBSTANTIAL OR REASONABLE OR
ACCESSIBLE ENOUGH. AS WORKERS
WHO ARE LIVING IN POVERTY. SO I
THINK YOU KNOW TO CONTRACTING TO
MISCLASSIFICATION TO THE
GLOBALIZATION AND OUTSOURCING.
ALL OF IT COMES BACK TO JUST
NEEDING GREATER PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS AND PROTECTING THE
WORKERS WHO ARE AT THE VERY
BOTTOM MIGRANT WORKERS IN THE
FUTURE OF WORK AGAIN. IT COMES
DOWN TO PROTECTING SAFEGUARDING
WORKERS AND THE ROLE OF THE
STATE AND THE LEGISLATURE AS A
SAFEGUARD AND A WATCHDOG TO
ENSURE THAT TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE NOT ONLY YOU KNOW
IN COMPLIANCE, BUT THAT THEY ARE
BEING PROACTIVE. IN ENSURING
THAT THEY ARE SAFEGUARDING
PROTECTING WORKERS' RIGHTS. SO I
THINK THAT'S THE ANSWER FOR
SURE. THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND
UH, I WANT TO SAY THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS EFFORT OF S¼ B 150 IS
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT GIVE
GUIDANCE. ON THE GROUND TO THE
KIND OF WORKFORCE WE WANT TO
SEE, AND THE KIND OF JOBS WE
WANT TO SEE IN THE NEW ECONOMY I
WANT TO IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THIS PANEL?
WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH. UH,
MISS APARICIO AND SOLOMON FOR
YOUR Tð, JANICE. YOU KNOW ME FOR
SO I KNOW WHY AM I CALLING YOU
BY YOUR MIDDLE? THE 2ND 1ST LAST
NAME. THANK YOU SO MUCH, JANICE.
FOR THAT APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU.
YEAH. ARE WE IF IT'S OVER THREE
DOLLARS UH, SHOW ON THE SCREEN.
YES THEY'RE GONNA SHUT DOWN.
JUST PLAY IT SLOW US NOW, HØI.
OK SO NOW WE'LL HAVE OUR SECOND
PANEL, WHICH IS SUCCESSFUL
PRACTICES FOR IMPLEMENTATION. IN
THIS PANEL. WE WERE HERE FROM
MICHAEL FLORES WITH THE L, A
METRO. AND TOM, HENCE, WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE UNITED AUTO WORKERS. UAW
WELCOME, MR FLORES. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH YOU. AND THEN WE WILL
MOVE. MOVE TO YOU, TOM. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. SENATORS MY
NAME IS MICHAEL FLORES AND I'M
METRO PROJECT LABOR
ADMINISTRATOR AND ALSO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PERSON. I DO HAVE A
POWER POINT THAT I WANTED TO
SHOW THE COMMITTEE AND I'M NOT
CERTAIN IF IT'S CURRENTLY
SHOWING ON THE SCREEN. OK? SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST, UM, WANT TO
START IT OFF. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE. AT IN
REPRESENTATION OF METRO AS A
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
METRICS AND INTEGRAL PART OF LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY NOT ONLY AS A
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION PROVIDER
BUT AS A KEY EMPLOYER, PEOPLE
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE. THAT'S
WHY WE MADE IT AS AN AGENCY GOAL
TO ENHANCE COMMUNITY AND LIVES
THROUGH BOTH MOBILITY AND ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY. TO ENSURE THE
BENEFIT OF OUR PROJECTS AFFECT
THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS. WE'VE
DONE IT THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF MANY WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS, BUT I'M GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO OF THEM FOR YOU
TODAY. PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
AND CONSTRUCTION CAREERS POLICY.
AND OUR MANUFACTURING CARE
POLICY. OUR PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT, CONSTRUCTION POLICY
WAS ADOPTED. AND IN PLACE FOR
MORE THAN 10 YEARS. THANKS TO
OUR AGENCIES PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES. IT IS
APPLICABLE AND METROS
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT THAT HAS A
CONTRACT VALUE OF 2.5 MILLION
AND ABOVE. THE PL SETS TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT ON
PROJECTS TO ENSURE NÓ WORK
STOPPAGES OCCUR. THERE'S
EXPEDITED RESOLUTION OF LABOR
DISPUTES AND THAT METROS
PROJECTS ARE COMPLETED ON TIME.
WITH THE PL A IS THE
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS POLICY.
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
ECONOMICALLY AND SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS AND
APPRENTICES WITH CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES. WE HAVE SET LABOR
FORCE PARTICIPATION GOAL FOR
CERTAIN GROUPS UNDER THE CCP.
40% PARTICIPATION OF WORKERS
FROM ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
AREA. 20% APPRENTICES 10%
PARTICIPATION OF DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS. SINCE INCEPTION. A
TOTAL OF 57 CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS ARE SUBJECT TO THE PP
AND GROWING. THAT IS A TOTAL OF
$8.5 BILLION IN CONTRACT VALUES.
AS I HAD MENTIONED THE P
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENT AS
MENTIONED, WE HAVE ATTAINED
58.10% OF WORKERS FROM
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AREA
IN THE TARGET WAS 40. 21.20
THREE APPRENTICES AND OUR GOAL
WAS 20. 10.89 DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS, AND OUR CURRENT GOAL IS
A 10. AND AS YOU COULD SEE ON
THE SLIDE HERE, THAT'S █28
MILLION CONSTRUCTION WORK HOURS.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF OUR FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES THAT HAD PARTICIPATED
AND WORK ON OUR PROJECTS. TO
KIND OF PUT IT IN A DOLLAR
PERSPECTIVE. WE HAVE PAID 542
MILLION THE TARGETED WORKERS.
101 MILLION PAID TO
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS AND 147
MILLION HAD BEEN PAID TO
APPRENTICE WORKERS. THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN THE LÀ REGION. NOW GO INTO
THE. LOCAL HIRE COMPONENT ARE OF
THE 17 OR 16 PROJECTS THAT I HAD
MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE ACTIVE SO
FAR. 10 OF THOSE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS WERE SUBJECT TO LOCAL
HIRE. SIX OF THOSE PROJECTS WERE
FEDERALLY FUNDED. WE WERE ABLE
TO COME. WE WERE ABLE TO CONFORM
WITH THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW, LOCAL HIRE
HIRING PRACTICES THROUGH THE
UTILIZATION OF PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT, LOCAL HIRE WORKFORCE.
PROGRAM WE WERE ABLE TO DEVELOP
THAT IN COLLABORATION WITH
FEDERAL TRANSIT AUTHORITY AND
FHWA F Dð, A WAS ABLE TO GIVE US
A BLANKET APPROVAL TO UTILIZE
METRO'S PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
LOCAL HIRE THROUGHOUT ALL OF ITS
FEDERALLY FUNDED OR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS FUNDED BY F Dð. FHWA IS
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT. THE FACT
THAT THEY DO REQUEST A. PROJECT
SPECIFIC APPROVAL FOR ANY FUNDED
PROJECTS THAT'S FUNDED BY F HÌ
W. THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THAT WAS
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK FIRST HAND
TO FOR F HÌ W A TO REVIEW OUR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT, LOCAL
HIGH PROVISION AND OBTAIN AN
APPROVAL FOR EACH SPECIFIC
PROJECTS THAT HAD BEEN FUNDED BY
F HÌ W WE HAD WE WERE ABLE TO
SET UP A STREAMLINED PROCESS TO
SUBMIT A JUSTIFICATION
STATEMENT. AND OBTAIN AN
APPROVAL WITH A COMMITMENT FROM
F HÌ W A TO HAVE A QUICK
TURNAROUND OF 30 DAYS OR LESS.
SO FAR WE WERE ABLE TO OBTAIN OR
WE WERE ABLE TO INFORM OUR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT ON FOUR
FEDERALLY HIGHWAY CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS. NOW ONE OTHER
INITIATIVE THAT WE ARE WORKING
FOR L, A METRO IS GENDER EQUITY.
WE WOULD WANT IT TO INCREASE
FEMALE PARTICIPATION IN THE
TRADE, SO WE HAVE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH ARB. èC B S¼ WITH
OUR BUILDING PARTNERS AND TRADE
TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE FEMALE
PARTICIPATION. WE HAD RECENTLY
CONDUCTED A DISPARITY STUDY IN
THE L, A REGION THAT THE FEMALE
MAKEUP OF CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
IS LESS THAN 3. SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT. METRO HAS THE CHANGE
AGENT, BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO HELP AND ASSIST TO INCREASE
THAT FEMALE PARTICIPATION IN THE
TRADES. I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT RECOGNIZE SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AND SENATOR DE
RAO FOR YOUR CONTINUED ADVOCACY
FOR YOUR WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IN
THE PAST FOR THE ADOPTION OF
METROS PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT,
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING. ONE
THING THAT I WANTED TO SHARE
PERSONALLY, IS I WAS THE FIRST
HAND WITNESS FOR COUNTLESS OF
LIVES THAT HAVE CHANGED THEIR
LIVES. ONE PARTICULAR WE WERE
ABLE TO OUTREACH TO A PARTICULAR
VETERAN, WAS LIVING OFF THE
STREET OUTSIDE WEST LOS ANGELES.
HOSPITAL WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THAT INDIVIDUAL INTO A TRAINING
AND SIX MONTHS AGO HE REACHED
OUT TO ME AND SAID I JUST
FINALLY BOUGHT HIS HOME. ANOTHER
PARTICULAR FEMALE THAT WAS
ACTUALLY INCARCERATED FOR 1215
YEARS. THE TIME THAT HE SHE WAS
INCARCERATED. HER DAUGHTER WAS
IN GRADE SCHOOL. SHE CAME OUT OF
PRISON. HER DAUGHTER WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL. SHE WAS ABLE TO MAKE
MONEY TO SEND HER DAUGHTER INTO
COLLEGE. NOW THAT DAUGHTER THIS
ON HER MASTER'S DEGREE. SO
LITERALLY PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT DO WORK. SO ONE THING
THAT I WANTED TO EMPHASIZE TO
THIS COMMITTEE THAT PER S¼ E. WE
ARE HERE AT METRO AS A RESOURCE
OF ALL OF THESE THINGS AND GOOD
POSITIVE THINGS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO DO IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
ANOTHER ITEM THAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IS OUR MANUFACTURING
CURS POLICY. OUR èC E Ó
BELIEVED THAT THIS IS THE SISTER
POLICY FOR OUR CONSTRUCTION
CARRIERS. KNOWING THE FACT THAT
OUR CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE
BEING BUILT OUT BY DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS. WHY CANNOT WE HAVE
THE MANUFACTURERS THAT'S
PERFORMING. ASSEMBLY AND
CREATING OUR ROLLING STOCKS BE
ABLE TO BE THE SAME COMPONENT.
SO IN CO ORDINATION WITH JOBS TO
OF AMERICA. I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE THEM THE RECOGNITION. WE
WERE ABLE TO ADOPT THE
MANUFACTURING CREDIT POLICY THAT
IS APPLICABLE NOW ON OUR ROLLING
STOCK CONTRACT THAT HAS A $50
MILLION IN ABOVE. SO FAR, WE
WERE ABLE TO HAVE A COMMITMENT
FROM THE PROJECTS THAT WE ARE
CONTRACTS THAT WE HAD LAID OUT
OVER 20 MILLION OUTRAGEOUS AND
BENEFIT FOR BASE CONTRACT.
ADDITIONAL █25 MILLION OF WAGES
AND BENEFITS IF WE EXERCISE
OPTION YEARS OVER 14 MILLION
INVESTMENT FOR LOCAL FACILITY
INVESTMENT AND A 10% MINIMUM
DISADVANTAGE. HIRING COMMITMENT
SO I WANTED TO END THIS THAT.
METRO'S COMMITMENT TO CERTAIN
THAT THIS WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS
ARE ADHERED TO THAT, IN THE
EVENT OF ANY OF THE CONTRACTORS
FAILED TO MEET ANY OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS. THEY ARE FINANCIAL
PENALTIES AT THE BACK END. UP TO
A I'M MAXIMUM, NOT A MAXIMUM
AMOUNT, BUT $500 PER DAY THAT
THEY DON'T MEET THEIR
COMMITMENT. IT IS NOT WORTHY TO
MENTION THAT THIS PROGRAMS HAD
CONTRIBUTED BACK TO THE LOCAL
ECONOMY BUT HAD PROVIDED
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
HUNDREDS OF DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MISTER FLORES. AND
NEXT WE WILL HAVE, UH, MR TOM
HEINY WITH THE UAW. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. UM AND AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID, YOU KNOW, PL HAS
CHANGED LIVES. GOOD
MANUFACTURING JOBS, CHANGE LIVES
. UNION JOBS. CHANGE LIVES. UM
SO GOOD AFTERNOON. UH, MY NAME
IS TOM HINSLEY. UH, I'M AN
INTERNATIONAL REP WITH UAW
REGION SIX REPRESENTS OVER
100,000 ACTIVE AND RETIRED
WORKERS IN REGION SIX. OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
JUST TRANSITION TO ENSURE THAT
CHANGES IN THE U S¼ AUTOMOTIVE
INDUSTRY. RESULT IN QUALITY JOBS
THAT BENEFIT WORKERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. UAW MEMBERS KNOW
THAT THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES PRESENTS A KEY
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE AND GROW
HIGH QUALITY JOBS IN THE E VÆ
SUPPLY CHAIN, INCLUDING BATTERY
MANUFACTURING. IN 2020 THREE
AUTO WORKERS AT THE DETROIT
THREE WENT ON STRIKE, UH, ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO WIN RECORD
CONTRACTS AND TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY JOB IS A GOOD UNION JOB,
INCLUDING JOBS IN THE E VÆ AND
BATTERY SUPPLY CHAINS. BUT THE
FIGHT ISN'T OVER AFTER THE
HISTORIC STAND UP STRIKE, UAW
LAUNCHED STAND UP TWO POINT Ó
TO ORGANIZE THE MAJORITY OF AUTO
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY.
NOW WORKERS AT COMPANIES THAT
AREN'T UNIONIZED YET ARE
FIGHTING FOR LIVING WAGES, SAFE
WORK SITES AND WORKPLACE
DEMOCRACY. THIS FIGHT WILL HAVE
TO CONTINUE FOR EVERY PART OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN. AND AS I KEEP
SAYING FROM BATTERY MATERIALS,
BATTERY COMPONENTS, BATTERY
CELLS, SEMICONDUCTOR CHIPS AND,
OF COURSE TO THE ASSEMBLY LINE.
THE TOPIC OF THIS PANEL IS
SUCCESSFUL PRACTICES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. AND I WANT TO
START BY SAYING CALIFORNIA IS
FACED WITH A CHOICE IN THE
TRANSITION TO A GREEN ECONOMY.
WILL THE STATE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO LINE THE
POCKETS OF WEALTHY CORPORATIONS
AND ULTRA RICH èC? E? Ó S¼, UH
OR WILL WE DEMAND THAT OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TRANSLATE INTO
GOOD UNION JOBS THAT HELP
WORKERS AND IMPROVE COMMUNITIES?
WORKERS WANT TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE, BUT THEY CANNOT AFFORD
TO SACRIFICE GOOD UNION JOBS FOR
LOW ROAD JOBS IN THE GREEN
ECONOMY. THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
FOR YEARS IN OUR STATE. UH AND
IT'S AN IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE FOR
WORKERS TO MAKE. THAT'S WHY THE
FASTEST WAY TO TRANSITION TO A
GREEN ECONOMY IS BY CREATING A
WORKER LED INDUSTRIAL POLICY.
CALIFORNIA AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MUST INVOLVE WORKERS
IN THE PROCESS OF MAKING A JUST
TRANSITION AND THE BEST WAY TO
DO THAT IS THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. BY ENGAGING WORKERS,
UNIONS AND THE BROADER COMMUNITY
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY. CALIFORNIA
CAN ENSURE THAT AS WE MAKE A
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION, WE CAN
MAKE IT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
THAT WORKERS AND NOT THE ULTRA
WEALTHY ARE THE ONES WHO WILL
BENEFIT. ONE EXAMPLE IS A
COMPANY THAT IS HELPING
CALIFORNIA MAKE THIS TRANSITION
THE RIGHT WAY AND THAT SPARKS
AND UNFORTUNATELY THEIR èC E Ó
. SANJEEV COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY
. UM SPARKS IS A LITHIUM BATTERY
COMPANY AND BATTERY MATERIALS
COMPANY BASED IN RANCHO CORDOVA.
UAW RECENTLY ANNOUNCED A
NATIONAL NEUTRALITY AGREEMENT
WITH SPARKS TO DEVELOP HIGH
QUALITY JOBS IN BATTERY
MANUFACTURING. THIS MEANS THAT
SPARKS HAS COMMITTED TO REMAIN
NEUTRAL IN THE EVENT THAT THEIR
FUTURE WORKFORCE CHOOSES TO FORM
A UNION. WHEN IT COMES TO
GUARANTEEING JOB QUALITY. THERE
IS NÓ SUBSTITUTE FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT. THIS
LANDMARK NEUTRALITY AGREEMENT
SHOWS HOW BATTERY MANUFACTURERS
CAN LEAD THE TRANSITION TO
ADJUST AND SUSTAINABLE FUTURE
AND SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE CLASS.
SPARKS IS ESTABLISHING A
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AT ITS
FACILITY IN RANCHO CORDOVA. IN
ADDITION TO SIGNING A NEUTRALITY
AGREEMENT WITH UAW SPARKS IS
ALSO DEVELOPING A JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT TRAINING PROGRAM WITH
THE UAW CENTER FOR MANUFACTURING
AND GREEN ECONOMY, WHICH IS A
NON PROFIT TRAINING
ORGANIZATION. THIS PROGRAM WILL
ENSURE THAT WORKERS ARE TRAINED
ON VARIOUS ASPECTS OF BATTERY
MANUFACTURING FROM MAKING
BATTERY CELLS, MATERIALS AND
PACKS AND THAT SPARKS IS ABLE TO
HIRE WORKERS WHO ARE HIGHLY
TRAINED AND THAT FUTURE JOBS GO
TO THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
NEED THEM. THE MOST SPARKS WILL
EVENTUALLY EMPLOY OVER 1000
WORKERS AT ITS FACILITY. THE UAW
SPARKS TRAINING PARTNERSHIP IS
COMMITTED TO BUILDING A
COMMUNITY HIRING AND TRAINING
PIPELINE SO THAT MEMBERS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES CAN
GAIN EMPLOYMENT AT SPARKS. THIS
PIPELINE WILL INVOLVE EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH TO AND RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, AND THE PROGRAM
WILL DEVELOP WORK READINESS
TRAINING SO THAT INDIVIDUALS
WITH BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT CAN
START NEW CAREERS IN BATTERY
MANUFACTURING. ALL INVESTMENTS
IN CLIMATE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS SHOULD INCLUDE OR
SUPPORT THE NEGOTIATION OF
AGREEMENTS LIKE THE ONE HAS WITH
SPARKS THAT ALLOW WORKERS TO
ORGANIZE AND NEGOTIATE HIGHER
STANDARDS WITHOUT THE
INTERFERENCE OR INTIMIDATION
FROM EMPLOYERS. NEUTRALITY
AGREEMENTS, COMMUNITY BENEFITS
AGREEMENTS AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA DISCUSSED
AND PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS ARE
KEY TOOLS THAT GIVE WORKERS THE
FREE AND FAIR DECISION TO JOIN
AND FORM A UNION. THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WORKERS ARE ASKING FOR.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY BY
THE BERKELEY LABOR CENTER.
CALIFORNIA HAS BUDGETED OVER
32.5 BILLION OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS TO INVEST IN TECHNOLOGIES
TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE, HOWEVER
, 40% OF THAT MONEY OR $13
BILLION HAS NÓ STANDARDS TO
ENSURE THAT WORKERS HAVE GOOD
JOBS AND 83% OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
GOING TO MANUFACTURING WHERE $7
BILLION LACKS ANY LABOR
STANDARDS. FROM CONSTRUCTION OF
FACILITIES TO OPERATION
MAINTENANCE SERVICE AND
MANUFACTURING WORKERS WHO MY
UNION REPRESENTS ALL JOBS FUNDED
BY OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS MUST BE
GOOD JOBS FOR CALIFORNIANS. UAW
URGES THE COMMITTEE TO CREATE
STANDARDS FOR ALL TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THAT WILL INVEST IN S¼
AND SUPPLY CHAIN TO ENSURE THAT
MANUFACTURING WORKERS WHO OFTEN
HAVE THE SAME JOBS FOR DECADES
WHO REMAIN IN THE SAME JOBS FOR
DECADES. WE HAVE GOOD JOBS THAT
ALLOW THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
THRIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR HØI FOR SHARING THAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH US AND
INFORMATION. I WILL NOW TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES, UH, ON
THE DÍAS, UH, SENATOR DE RAO. UM
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH, UH,
YOUR HANDS ON REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE MATTERS A LOT. UM I.
I WANTED TO ASK MR FLORES, UH,
AS YOU DESCRIBED ALL OF THE
PROJECTS ALL OF THE MONEY THAT,
UM YOU HAVE WE HAVE ENTRUSTED
YOU TO SPEND WISELY AND TO BUILD
OUT OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT
WERE THE BARRIERS? W. WHAT'S YOU
KNOW WHAT WERE THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT YOU FELT? OH, MY GOD. THIS
IS REALLY, UM GOING TO HURT US
AS FAR AS THE POLICIES THAT YOU
DESCRIBED CONSTRUCTION CAREER IN
THE MANUFACTURING. WHAT WHAT
WOULD HAVE STOPPED YOU? BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THERE ARE GONNA BE
FOLKS WHO SAY I CAN'T DO THIS. I
CAN'T DO IT, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH. YES, AND? AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION, SENATOR.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THERE'S TWO
COMPONENTS THAT I TRULY WANTED
TO ADDRESS. UH, THE FACT THAT
THE LOCAL HIRE COMPONENT THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAD
INSTITUTED A GAME CHANGER. BUT
YET IT'S STILL A PILOT PROGRAM.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE LOOKING
INTO THAT TO SOMEWHAT BEING ABLE
TO HAVE A COMPONENT OR A
LEGISLATION THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
TURN THAT INTO A PERMANENT LAW.
BECAUSE AS WE CONSIDER IT BASED
ON WHO IS AT THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION SOMEWHAT DO
CHANGE THAT COMPONENT. I STARTED
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
WHERE WE HAD A PILOT, LOCAL HIRE
INITIATIVE AND THE CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAD BEEN
REDACTED AND WAS ACTUALLY
BROUGHT BACK AGAIN THROUGH THIS
ADMINISTRATION. THAT CHANGES THE
WHOLE DYNAMIC IN TERMS OF
APPLICABILITY AND LOCAL BENEFIT
OF WORKERS IN THE REGION.
BECAUSE NOW THE GEOGRAPHIC
HIRING PREFERENCE DO COME INTO
PLAY BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE
WORKERS OUT OF THE STATE BE ABLE
TO COME INTO CALIFORNIA MORE
PARTICULARLY IN THE L, A REGION
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WORK.
WHICH ARE LOCAL UNION FOLKS OR
LOCAL MEMBERS COULD BENEFIT FROM
THE TRAINING THAT COULD BE
ADOPTED AND CREATED FOR THEM TO
STABILIZE THAT WORKFLOW
OPPORTUNITY. UH, THAT'S FIRST
COMPONENT THAT WE HAD ABLE TO
SEE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE PROJECTS
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THE
PROHIBITED BECAUSE OF THE
GEOGRAPHIC HIRING PREFERENCE AND
THEN PROJECTS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THE LOCAL HIRE. IT IS
ACTUALLY CREATING A CONFUSION.
FOR THE LOCAL WORKERS IN OUR
BUILDING PARTNERS AND ANOTHER
COMPONENT THAT WE HAVE ALSO IS
THE FEMALE PARTICIPATION IN THE
TRADES. I WOULD REALLY POINTED
OUT THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE MORE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO THE FEMALE, AS
SENATOR WAHAB HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER. THESE ARE KEY FACTORS.
THE FACT THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN
ADOPTION OF GENDER EQUITY
RESTROOM IN THE CONSTRUCTION.
LOCATION THE FACT THAT THESE ARE
SOMEWHAT. EQUITY ISSUES AND ALSO
CHILDCARE. THE FACT THAT YOU
KNOW FEMALE INTO THE TRADES.
MOST ARE THE ISSUES BEING ABLE
TO HAVE A RELIABLE, SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES THAT CAN HELP THEM AND
ASSIST THEM TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THERE IS A MASSIVE
CONSTRUCTION WORKER SHORTAGE IN
THE L, A REGION ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAD BEEN POINTED OUT
BY OUR CONSTRUCTION ARE BASED ON
THE CONSTRUCTION STUDY THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A MASSIVE
CONSTRUCTION WORKER SHORTAGE IN
THE L A REGION TO BUILD OUT ALL
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
SO THAT IS ANOTHER ISSUE, BUT
THINGS START BUILDING PARTNERS
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THAT MATTER AND THEN CONTINUALLY
OUTREACH. TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
THAT ARE INTERESTED BEING ABLE
TO HAVE MORE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
HONE IN TO THE PIPELINE OF
WORKERS THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE.
FOR THIS GOOD PAYING JOBS. THESE
ARE PREVAILING WAGES. UH,
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PREVAILING WAGE. IN
COMPARISON TO THE OTHER STATES
IN THE UNITED STATES. MISTER
PRESIDENT. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE THE INVITATION TO
JOIN THE HEARING TODAY. UM AND
I'M NOT ON THE STANDING
COMMITTEE, BUT IT'S JOINT
CLIMATE COMMITTEE CHAIR. I THINK
THIS IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF
TESTIMONY WE'RE LOOKING TO
GATHER HERE. I WANTED TO DRILL
DOWN A LITTLE FURTHER ON IS IT
MR HÌ ON YOUR REMARKS ABOUT OUR
CLIMATE SPENDING. HE SAID. 40%
WAS THE NUMBER YOU HAD CITED AS
LACKING CERTAIN STANDARDS. JUST
A REFERENCE ON THAT, AND MAYBE A
COUPLE EXAMPLES TO. TO
ARTICULATE FOR US. IS IT LIKE A
BIG? IS IT A CATEGORICAL THING?
IS IT CERTAIN CATEGORIES? DON'T
HAVE THOSE STANDARDS OR IS IT,
UM, PARTICULAR PROJECTS? YEAH SO
, UM, THIS IS A STUDY THAT WAS
PUBLISHED BY THE BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER LAST FALL. AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU, UH,
WITH A REFERENCE TO THAT, UM,
BUT I, I THINK FOR US, YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT STUDY REALLY
UNDERSCORED, WAS SOMETHING THAT
OTHER PANELISTS HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING ALREADY? THAT THERE'S
REALLY, UM YOU KNOW, NOT ENOUGH,
BUT SOME LABOR STANDARDS IN
PLACE FOR CONSTRUCTION FOR NEW
GREEN ENERGY PROJECTS, AND I'LL
LET MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
BUILDING TRADE TALK ABOUT THAT
LATER, BUT FOR MANUFACTURING,
UH, THERE THERE'S REALLY A LACK
OF STANDARDS ACROSS THE BOARD.
UM AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON. AND WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THAT OUR MEMBERS PAY TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THEY
WORK REALLY HARD TO EARN, UH ARE
ARE GONNA GO TO CREATING GOOD
JOBS. UM I NOTICED THAT SOME OF
THE OTHER EXAMPLES IN OTHER
STATES WHERE THEY'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESS AND MORE THAN US ON IRA
HAS THEY'VE BUILT SORT OF THIS,
UM, PUBLIC MODEL, THE HUB MODEL
IF YOU WILL ON MANUFACTURING FOR
ATTRACTING DOLLARS AND NOT JUST
LETTING PRIVATE SECTOR TAKE THE
LEAD. WE FOLLOWED THAT ON OUR
HYDROGEN APPLICATION, THE
GOVERNOR, THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, SORT OF
ORGANIZED A PUBLICLY LED
SOLICITATION. DO YOU THINK THAT
KIND OF MODEL A PUBLIC PRIVATE
MODEL WHERE YOU'RE NOT JUST
LETTING THE COMPANY SET THE
TERMS, BUT THE GOVERNMENT SORT
OF LAYING OUT PARAMETERS AND
BUILDING SOMETHING BIGGER. COULD
THAT WORK IN MORE BROADLY IN
MANUFACTURING? DO YOU THINK
THERE'S MERIT TO THOSE THOSE
KINDS OF MODELS? I MEAN, YOU
LOOK AT SPARKS? YOU MENTIONED
THAT EXAMPLE THAT'S ONE LITTLE
COMPANY SORT OF TRYING TO
COMPETE OUT IN THE WORLD. BUT IF
STATEWIDE, WE HAD A BATTERY
MANUFACTURING HUB. I MEAN, ARE
WE GOING TO BE MORE COMPETITIVE
IF WE'RE TOGETHER? OR IS THAT
NOT HOW YOU SEE THE MARKETPLACE?
YEAH I. I MEAN, I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY INTERESTING IDEA, I, I
WOULD DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES
FROM, UH, THE LABOR CENTERS WHO
WHO RESEARCH THOSE KINDS OF
AGREEMENTS, BUT I MEAN, I
CERTAINLY THINK THE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE TO, YOU
KNOW, WORK BETWEEN GOVERNMENT
AND BUSINESS TO CREATE GOOD
QUALITY JOBS, THE BETTER AND YOU
KNOW, PROCUREMENT IS ONE REALLY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY THAT THE
STATE HAS AS A PURCHASER, WHICH
I THINK YOU KNOW IS SIMILAR IN A
LOT OF WAYS TO WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING. UM YOU KNOW, I WOULD
ALSO SAY, YOU KNOW IF THE IF THE
STATE WERE TO CREATE ITS OWN
BATTERY ENTERPRISE AND CREATE
SOME KIND OF STOCKPILE, THE WAY
THAT, UM YOU KNOW, THE STATE HAS
BEGUN TO PUT ENERGY INTO
STOCKPILING CRITICAL MEDICINES
FOR CALIFORNIANS, YOU KNOW, THAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER WAY TO, UM, I,
I THINK, CREATE GOOD JOB
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU. YOU,
SENATOR W. THANK YOU. UM. SO IN
MY DISTRICT, WE HAVE TESLA.
TESLA OBVIOUSLY HAS E VÆ S¼, UM,
LITHIUM BATTERIES. AND NÓ UNION.
I WANTED TO UNDERSTAND FROM YOU
IN PARTICULAR. WHERE HAVE THE
FAILURES BEEN IN TRYING TO
UNIONIZE A RELATIVELY NEW
MANUFACTURER LIKE TESLA. UM AND
REAL RECOMMENDATIONS. TO MAKE
THIS SUCCESSFUL IF WE WERE TO GO
ACROSS THAT SURE. UM Y, YOU
KNOW, I. I THINK IT'S NÓ
SURPRISE THAT WORKERS HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIALLY CONTINUOUSLY
ORGANIZING AT TESLA. UM SINCE IT
WAS FIRST OPENED, UM AND UAW
REPRESENTED THE WORKFORCE AT THE
PREVIOUS PLANT THAT TESLA TOOK
OVER IN 2010. I THINK IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW, WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WORKERS YOU KNOW, HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ORGANIZE
THEMSELVES. UM AND THAT, YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE THE WHO ARE
LEADING THE CHARGE ON THAT, BUT
I THINK THE STATE CAN DO QUITE A
LOT TO HELP IN TERMS OF CALLING
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY ON FUNDING.
TESLA IS ONE OF THE STATE'S
BIGGEST RECIPIENTS OF PUBLIC
FUNDING SINCE ITS INCEPTION, YOU
KNOW IN IN ONE FORM OR ANOTHER,
TESLA HAS BEEN THE RECIPIENT OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
, UH THROUGH LOANS THROUGH
DIRECT SUBSIDIES THROUGH TAX
BREAKS, AND SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT, UH, POWER THAT, YOU
KNOW. WORKERS CAN CAN HAVE TO
CALL FOR ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THEMSELVES AS THEIR ORGANIZING
TO WIN CONTRACTS FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR COWORKERS. SO
CONSIDERING THAT IT IS NOT
UNIONIZED, AND THERE'S BEEN
MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS, AND YET WE
KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN PRACTICES
THAT HAVE LIMITED THE EFFORTS IF
YOU WILL, RIGHT. UM WE ALSO KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE BEING
BUSSED FROM LET'S SAY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. UM ALWAYS THE
WAY DOWN TO THE BAY AREA AT 4
A.M. ON BUSES RIGHT AND THE
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT CONCERNS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ONE OF THE
THINGS AND I, AND I WISH THAT WE
HAD, UM, SOME SOME OTHER FOLKS
TO SPEAK FROM A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE, ESPECIALLY THOSE
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SOME
OF THE EFFORTS OF, UM YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
TO UNDERSTAND IF WE DO NOT SEE A
UNIONIZED WORKFORCE IN SOME
MANUFACTURE ORGANIZATION, RIGHT?
UM, LIKE WE JUST REFERENCED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE LOWEST
COMMON DENOMINATOR TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING AND
UPLIFTING WORKERS ACROSS THE
BOARD? I THINK IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION. UM, YOU KNOW. FOR US,
UM, UH, COMMUNITY BENEFITS
AGREEMENT IS A IS A GREAT ROUTE
TO GO BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN PACKAGE YOU KNOW,
NEUTRALITY AGREEMENTS OR LABOR
PEACE AGREEMENTS, WHICH PUT
REQUIREMENTS ON COMPANIES, OF
COURSE TO, YOU KNOW, NOT DISRUPT
THEIR UH, WORKERS ABILITY TO
ORGANIZE AND CAN ALSO INCLUDE,
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE WAS TALKING ABOUT
TARGETED HIGHER. UM AS WELL AS,
UM, THINGS THAT THE COMMUNITY
WANTS TO SEE. AND SO I THINK
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENTS
ARE REAL KEY TO BRINGING LOTS OF
DIFFERENT. I LIKE I WAS SAYING
NEUTRALITY PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS TARGETED HIGHER
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS. UM AND
THEN? YEAH WE'RE AN  N S¼
DEVELOPMENT AND HAVE YOU SEEN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR SUPPORT THIS
WITHOUT? YOU KNOW, UNIONIZING.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE LEADERS OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMPANIES SUPPORT THIS SPARK?
SIGNED A NEUTRALITY AGREEMENT
WITH US SO II I WISH UH, THERE
THEIR èC E Ó WAS HERE, I
HOPEFULLY HE MENTIONED SOME OF
THIS IN HIS TESTIMONY, BUT, UM,
YOU KNOW, I, I THINK COMPANIES
SEE WORKING WITH UNIONS WORKING
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE RIGHT NOW,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE KINDS OF
SUBSIDIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM. UM, YOU KNOW, THROUGH THE
Dð Ó E. WHICH IS, YOU KNOW,
INCORPORATED, UM, COMMUNITY
BENEFITS INTO THEIR SCORING. UM
SO THE STATE CAN CREATE, YOU
KNOW, SCORING SYSTEM? UM THAT
HELPS TO CREATE AN ADVANTAGE FOR
COMPANIES THAT REACH AGREEMENTS
LIKE THAT. SO I KNOW WE'VE
LARGELY TALKED ABOUT
CONSTRUCTION AND LET'S SAY THE
AUTO INDUSTRY AND SO FORTH. YOU
KNOW, IN MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR, THERE'S A LOT OF
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES AND
RESEARCH AND, UH WE OFTEN HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING, UH, LET'S
SAY VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES INTO
THOSE INDUSTRIES IN PARTICULAR,
ALSO WITH A LACK OF UNIONS THERE
TO BE COMPLETELY FRANK. YOU
KNOW, HOW CAN WE BROADEN THE
SCOPE OF LABOR IN INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE 21ST CENTURY THAT ARE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THE LAST 50 YEARS. BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY TECHNOLOGY,
UM IS WHAT LEADS BUSINESS RIGHT
AND NEW INDUSTRIES AND WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT LITHIUM. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS HERE. UM BUT WE
ALSO HAVE SEEN HOLD UPS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES. RIGHT WE HAVE SEEN,
UH THERE'S PLENTY OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN POINT TO
THAT HAVE STATED THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO PAUSE ON MANUFACTURING
OF THESE TYPES OF VEHICLES OR
FOR EXAMPLE, HERZ SOLD OFF THEIR
22,000 VEHICLES BECAUSE WE DO
NOT HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. UM SO WHAT CAN WE DO
TO HAVE A FORWARD LOOKING EFFORT
RATHER THAN YOU KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE DOMINATED? YEAH. UM, IF YOU
DON'T MIND, UM WHAT I BELIEVE
THAT TRULY WHAT NEEDS TO DO IS
EDUCATIONAL OR INFORMATION
THAT'S AT THE FOREFRONT. UH, THE
FACT THAT THE COMMUNITY BENEFIT
AGREEMENT DOES NOT REALLY JUST
DICTATE THE HIRING INFORMATION
BUT ALSO THE FACT THAT WHAT THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS. FOR EXAMPLE, WE
HAD. I MEAN, I'M GOING BACK TO
THE CONSTRUCTION SIDE OF STUFF
ON FOR LÀ METRO. WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DO HAVE THE
PURPLE LINE ALIGNMENT THAT'S
ADJACENT TO BEVERLY HILL. THE
DIFFICULTY OF HAVING, UM WORKERS
FROM A VERY AFFLUENT AREA. IT'S
SOMEWHAT NOT AVAILABLE, SO WE
LOOKED INTO THE ASPECT OF BEING
ABLE TO BENEFIT SMALL BUSINESSES
, SO THERE IS REALLY COMPONENT
OF BENEFITING SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT'S THE COMMUNITY NEEDS OR
WHAT WORKERS THAT DO NEED
ASSISTANCE FROM THAT CERTAIN
COMMUNITY, SO BEING ABLE TO
REALLY IDENTIFY OR HAVE A AN
ANALYSIS IF YOU WILL, THAT CAN
REALLY BE USED AS A AS A
LITERATURE OR INFORMATION AHEAD
TO BE ABLE TO DISSEMINATE THOSE
INFORMATION TO THE EXISTING
MANUFACTURERS. PER S¼, E,
PHARMACEUTICAL E VÆ
MANUFACTURERS AND THINGS OF THAT
TYPE. IT'S REALLY NÓ ONE.
APPROACH IF YOU WILL. IT'S
REALLY WHAT THE COMMUNITY NEEDS
FOR THAT PRESENT MOMENT OR
PRESENT TIME MOVING FORWARD. ONE
LAST QUESTION IN REGARDS TO WE
HEARD FROM A PREVIOUS SPEAKER
ABOUT YOU KNOW, WE CAN HIRE FROM
CALIFORNIA OR WE CAN STATE THIS
AND SO FORTH, AND WE'VE HEARD
DIFFERENT TARGETED HIGHER AND
COMMUNITY BENEFITS BEING MORE
LOCALIZED, AND I KNOW THAT MOST
OF THE CONVERSATION HAS BEEN
MORE FOCUSED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN MY DISTRICT, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE AVERAGE WORKER AT
THESE DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES
CANNOT AFFORD A HOME. IT'S ONE
OF THE MOST OF 1.31 0.4 MILLION
OR MORE, LET ALONE RENTS AND SO
FORTH. SO HENCE, YOU KNOW, AN
ORGANIZATION AS I REFERENCED
EARLIER WILL BUST PEOPLE OUT
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY, RIGHT,
WHICH IS A COUPLE OF HOURS IN
THE BUS. I AT 4 A.M. RIGHT.
WORKING 12 HOUR SHIFTS, RIGHT?
UH, TWO HOURS PER EACH, YOU
KNOW, LET'S SAY IF THEY'RE
INSTALLING A STEERING WHEEL OR A
CHAIR OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT, UM
THOSE INDIVIDUALS, ESPECIALLY IN
THE BAY AREA. UH, WE SEE PEOPLE
HAVE SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION
MOVE FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY.
TWO HOURS, THREE HOURS STILL
COMMUTING BECAUSE THE JOBS ARE
IN THE BAY AREA, RIGHT. SO WHAT
ARE WE DOING ABOUT THAT AND
PROTECTING THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NÓ LONGER PART OF THE COMMUNITY
EXCEPT FOR THE WORKFORCE PIECE
OF IT, WHO ARE ALSO COMMUTING.
WE TALK ABOUT CLIMATE WE TALK
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, UH, VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. WE TALK ABOUT
POLLUTION. WE TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF THINGS. HOW ARE WE OPERATING,
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE PROTECTED, HAVE
THEIR RIGHTS OR ABLE TO ABSORB
THE JOBS. RIGHT AND STILL BE
PART OF THIS COMMUNITY AND
BENEFIT IT. YOU KNOW SUCH A GOOD
QUESTION, THE FACT THAT THERE'S
REALLY MANY APPROACHES ONE THING
THAT I HAVE SEEN IN SAN DIEGO
REGION THAT CERTAIN AREAS THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
LOW HOUSING THAT WILL BE
AFFORDABLE FOR THE CURRENT
WORKERS THAT ARE PARTICIPATING
MANUFACTURING WORK OR ANYTHING
ELSE WITHIN THAT TYPE THAT
SOMEWHAT ELIMINATE ANY BARRIERS.
FOR THESE WORKERS TO BE
TRANSPORTED LONG DISTANCE, SO
THOSE ARE ALSO SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE LOOKED INTO IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO USE AS A CAVEAT
THAT BUSINESSES COULD
PARTICIPATE OR EVEN CONTRIBUTE
TO THE COST OF THOSE LOW HOUSING
IF YOU WILL TO BE ABLE TO HELP
OUT THOSE POPULATIONS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR WAHAB, SENATOR
BECKER. UH, SURE. THANK YOU FOR
MR HÌ. WE DID GET TESTIMONY FROM
DR MALHOTRA. SO I REFER TO IT
FOR A MOMENT IN IN, UM I MEAN,
WHAT YOU SEEM TO BE SAYING. AS
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY, AND I THINK
HIS LETTER AS WELL IS SORT OF A
RACE TO THE TOP RATHER THAN A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM. UM AND IN
HIS TESTIMONY, HE TALKED ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF THE èC èC
FUNDING SOME PILOT PROJECTS. UM
AND HE POINTS OUT BASICALLY, R
AND Dð FOR 75 TO 80% OF THESE
COMPANIES IS HERE, BUT THEN THEY
MANUFACTURE ELSEWHERE. IF YOU
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THE èC èC
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY, UM CENTS
FROM THEM ABOUT ANY APPETITE ON
THIS AND THEN, UM, KIND OF
RELEVANT TO SENATOR WAHABS
QUESTION. YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT BUILDING OUT IN A
REGION, RIGHT? YOU THINK ABOUT
MAYBE WHAT NEW YORK STATE DID
WITH WESTERN NEW YORK, WHERE
THEY REALLY MADE A SUBSTANTIAL
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT. AND NOW
HAVE, UM, HAVE REALLY SUCCESSFUL
A LOT OF BATTERY COMPANIES.
SEMICONDUCTOR COMPANIES. YOU CAN
THINK ABOUT THAT SAY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, RIGHT? WE COULD
REALLY, UM UM NÓ, YOU KNOW, PICK
A FEW REGIONS AND SEND FACTORIES
THERE. I KNOW ALL THESE
COMPANIES. I TALKED TO SOME OF
THEM, BUT THEY MUCH RATHER DO
THAT THAN GO OUT OF STATE. IF IT
WAS EVEN CLOSE, YOU KNOW, KIND
OF COMPETITIVE WISE. SO ANYWAY,
ANY OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR. UH ABSOLUTELY
I. I THINK WHAT WHAT WE'RE ALL
TALKING ABOUT IS HOW TO CREATE
THAT RACE TO THE TOP. UM I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW HOW WE FEEL, UM,
THAT TAXPAYER DOLLARS SHOULD BE
SPENT BY CREATING GOOD JOBS AND
BY INCENTIVIZING COMPANIES TO DO
BETTER FOR THEIR WORKFORCE FOR
THE COMMUNITY FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AND SO, YEAH,
ABSOLUTELY. I THINK THE MODEL OF
INVESTING IN CERTAIN REGIONS
COULD BE VERY USEFUL THERE. I
KNOW THERE HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, LITHIUM VALLEY
AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LITHIUM THAT'S GONNA BE
EXTRACTED THERE, UH, WILL WILL
STAY IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT JUST
GET SHIPPED TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
AND DRIVE DOWN THE STANDARDS
BOTH FOR THE WORKERS IN THOSE
COUNTRIES AND FOR WORKERS IN THE
U S¼, BUT BUT THAT IT CAN
ACTUALLY BENEFIT PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND UH YEAH, I, I
THINK THAT WOULD BE A VERY
FRUITFUL AVENUE TO PURSUE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER. I JUST HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. SENATOR
BECKER, UH, TALKING ABOUT THE
RACE TO THE TOP. AND UM, I'LL
START WITH YOU, MR FLORES. UM
YOU GAVE SOME ANECDOTAL SUCCESS
STORIES. HOW HOW DOES METRO
ACTUALLY MONITOR AND TRACK THESE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENTS IN
TERMS OF THE PL A REQUIREMENTS
THE CONSTRUCTION CAREERS
REQUIREMENTS? HOW DO YOU TRACK
THAT? UH, AND CAN YOU SHARE A
LITTLE BIT I SAW IN MY PACKET.
THERE WAS AN ANALYSIS TARGETED
WORKERS. SUMMARY REPORT THAT IS
IT SORT OF ALL THE RECEIPTS ON
ONE PAGE. UM WOULD LOVE FOR YOU
TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
YOU ACTUALLY CAN MEASURE THE
IMPACT ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES USING THIS TYPE OF
MODEL, BUT SAY MORE ABOUT THE
RACE TO THE TOP, THE SORT OF
VALUE BASED CONTRACTING. HOW DO
YOU TRACK IT AND THEN SHARE A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT SOME OF THE
ACTUAL BROADER, DEEPER SUCCESS
HAS BEEN? THANK YOU, SENATOR.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, UH, METRO
HAVE A VERY STRINGENT MONITORING
AND ENFORCEMENT PROCESS WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR PROJECT PROGRAMS,
UM, WE DO UTILIZE WHAT WE CALL
THE THROUGH A CERTIFIED PAYROLL
RECORD THAT IS BY LAW HAS TO BE
SUBMITTED UNDER THE DAVIS BACON
ACT. THROUGH THE CERTIFIED
PAYROLL RECORD INFORMATION IN
TERMS OF LOCAL HIRE.
DISADVANTAGE HIRES ARE BEING
MONITORED AND THEN CALCULATED.
WE ARE INTO A SENSE OF BEING
PROACTIVE THAN BEING REACTIVE AT
THE VERY FIRST HAND THROUGH THE
MONITORING PROCESS THAT HAD BEEN
ESTABLISHED. FROM OUR CONTRACTOR
STANDPOINT, WHEN THEY SUBMIT
THEIR CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORD,
ALL OF THOSE THE DYNAMIC IN
TERMS OF THEIR THE WORKERS
LOCALITY, THEIR PAY RATE AND
DISADVANTAGE FACTORS THAT THEY
HAD ATTACHED AND THEN PROVIDED
THOSE INFORMATION BECAUSE ONE OF
THE CAVEAT OF OUR PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT IS BEING ABLE TO
COLLABORATE WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT DO PROVIDE
REFERRALS OF DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS. DISADVANTAGED WORKERS
ARE BEING REFERRED. THROUGH A
JOB COORDINATOR. THAT'S A
CONDITION OF A WORD ON OUR
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS, AND FROM
THAT POINT ON, THEY GET TRAINED,
ATTEND A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM UPON COMPLETION OF THAT
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM, THEN
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO REFER FOR
EMPLOYMENT ON OUR METRO TO OUR
PRIME CONTRACTORS TO WORK ON
METROS PROJECT SITES, SO
TECHNICALLY, THE P ITSELF CREATE
THAT MISSING LINK. TRUMP. THE
TRAINING PROVIDER. THROUGH OUR
WORKSOURCE CENTERS AND THE
HIRING ENTITY. SO THE WAY THAT I
PERSONALLY WOULD. SAY THIS IN A
SENSE THAT THE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT CREATE THAT LINKAGE TO
ALL OF THE PROVIDERS AND
RESOURCES ARE IN THE COMMUNITY
METRO AS AN AGENCY. WE HAVE TO
DEVELOP A VERY STRINGENT
MONITORING PROCESS IN ORDER FOR
US TO ASSESS ANY LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES AT THE END BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT IT TO BE CHALLENGED
THE FACT THAT THEIR OWN
REPORTING THEMSELVES FROM THE
CONTRACTORS STANDPOINT IS WHERE
WE BASE THE DATA THAT WE PUBLISH
AND BEING TRANSPARENT TO THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND UM AND I WANNA JUST SAY, UM,
ONE OF THE CELLS IN THIS
ANALYSIS SHOWS ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREA, OUR
SUBTOTAL. 60% OF THE PROJECT
WENT TO THOSE DISADVANTAGED
AREAS. I'M JUST READING THE
SUMMARY, AND I AND I AM SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ANALYSIS
THAT HELPS US GET THAT GRANULAR,
UM I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION FOR
YOU, MR FLORES. AND THIS HAS TO
DO WITH THE COMMENT YOU MADE
ABOUT THE F Tð A AND THE F HÌ W.
A UM, WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT
SLOWING DOWN THAT TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE COMMUNITY BENEFITS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE LABOR
STANDARDS, ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
A TRACKING AND MONITORING THAT
THAT WILL SOMEHOW SLOW DOWN
PROJECTS. UH, MAKE THEM UH BE
SOMEWHAT OF A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT
ON THOSE PROJECTS. BUT II I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED BRIEFLY THAT YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND WORKED WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO SORT OF WORK OUT THE
TIMELINE. BUT CAN YOU, UM, SHARE
IN TERMS OF IT SEEMS THAT METRO
MADE A DECISION THAT HAVING
BENEFITS DID NOT STOP YOU ALL
FROM MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS.
CAN YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW YOU DEAL WITH THE TIMELINE?
AND THAT IS THAT, IN FACT, TRUE
THAT THESE KINDS OF STANDARDS
SOMEHOW MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
GET WORK DONE TO LAS. UH FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE FOR L. A METRO
REALLY BOILS DOWN TO THE TOP.
LEADERSHIP WE HAVE THE FACT THAT
IT IS OUR PRIORITY TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO MAKE AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
TO THE REGION THAT WE SERVE.
THEREFORE WE TRY TO FIND WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS ANY
MITIGATING MATTERS AND THEN LOOK
AT IT AT THE VERY FOREFRONT, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE FACT THAT F HÌ W A
IN THE PAST WE HAVE. TO REALLY
SIT DOWN AND THEN COME TO THE
TABLE AND CREATE A PROCESS TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE THEIR
APPROVAL PROCESS. THOSE WERE
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED FIRSTHAND AND
THEN COMMUNICATED WITH THEM. SO
IT'S REALLY A COLLABORATION FROM
THESE PUBLIC FROM THIS FUNDING
AGENCIES. ONE BENEFIT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO COME THROUGH OUR
SUCCESS STORIES THAT WE HAVE WAS
GAVE METRO A BLANKET APPROVAL.
TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE ITS
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT LOCAL
HIRE ON FEDERALLY FUNDED FTA
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT FW THE PAST
SOMEWHAT. NOT PROHIBIT, BUT WE
HAVE TO REALLY BE ABLE TO GET A
JUSTIFICATION OF PROJECT
SPECIFIC FOR THEM TO APPROVE OUR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT, WE
PROVIDED A SUGGESTION IN A SENSE
THAT LOOK INTO OUR PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT AND APPROVE ITS
LANGUAGE, AND THEN WE WILL BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD TO STILL
OBTAIN PROJECT SPECIFIC THROUGH
A DIFFERENT PROCESS. IT'S A MORE
STREAMLINED PROCESS BY JUST
PROVIDING A JUSTIFICATION, SO
THOSE ITEMS WILL WE WERE ABLE TO
ADDRESS AND THEN COME INTO
CERTAIN UNDERSTANDING IN TERMS
OF ITS NOT DELAYING ANY
PROCUREMENT OF L, A METRO
BECAUSE ONE OF THE ISSUES ALSO
IS. PROCUREMENT CYCLE TAKES TIME
IF THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT
YOU'RE MISSING, BUT IF WE ARE
PROACTIVE IF YOU WILL, UM, THAT
WE HAVE A GENERAL UNDERSTANDING
WITH THAT FUNDING SOURCE OF A
QUICK TURNAROUND, THAT REALLY
CHANGED THE DYNAMIC AND WE HAVE
NOT SEEN ANY HINDRANCE IN TERMS
OF ANY FUNDED PROJECT THAT WE
HAVE THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO GIVE US AN APPROVAL IN
LESS THAN 30 DAYS. YOU FOR THAT
MR FLORES AND MR HINDS, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADD? YES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR IN TERMS OF WHAT?
WHAT SLOWS PROJECTS DOWN. UM Y,
YOU KNOW THE LACK OF A COMMUNITY
BENEFITS AGREEMENT OR NEUTRALITY
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS MEAN
THAT YOU KNOW, YOU RUN INTO
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH SKILLED WORKERS TO WORK
ON A PROJECT. THAT'S A MAJOR
OBSTACLE TO SPEEDING THINGS UP.
YOU RUN INTO LABOR STOPPAGES
BECAUSE WORKERS DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHTS AND BENEFITS THAT THAT
THEY NEED. AND ULTIMATELY, YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THIS DRIVES LACK OF
CONSENSUS IN BEING ABLE TO
CREATE NEW POLICIES TO HELP THE
STATE HIT ITS CLIMATE GOALS. AND
SO BY HAVING THESE THINGS IN
PLACE ON THE FRONT END, UM WE
CAN REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT SLOWING THINGS DOWN, BUT IN
FACT, WE'RE SPEEDING UP THE
PROCESS OF FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE. YES, SENATOR. CORTESE,
PLEASE. YES THANK YOU, I. I
WASN'T SURE FOR A MOMENT IF YOU
WERE DONE, THANK YOU. UM I. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT IT WAS ONE
OF MY QUESTIONS, AND I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER. UM AND
IT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AT A NUMBER OF
LEVELS, YOU KNOW PRECISELY WHAT
YOU JUST INDICATED, AND I
WOULDN'T HONESTLY KNOW THAT OR I
MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY BELIEVE
THAT MYSELF. UNLESS I HAD SEEN
IT. I'VE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH
. YOU KNOW, TO SEE IT HAPPEN TO
SEE IT WORK. UM, AND THOSE OF US
WHO WERE AROUND WHEN
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE IN
THEIR HEYDAY, WHATEVER PROBLEMS
THEY HAD, AND I COULD LIST THOSE
UM LABOR STANDARDS, YOU KNOW,
WASN'T ONE OF THEM. WE WERE ABLE
AND COMMUNITY BENEFITS WASN'T
ONE OF THEM. WE WERE BASICALLY
ABLE TO DO BOTH THOSE THINGS
WITH THAT MODEL, WHICH IS JUST
BASICALLY ANOTHER. ANOTHER
DEVELOPMENT AND PROCUREMENT
MODEL. I MEAN, IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST FUNDING COMING FROM A
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN WHERE WE'RE
GETTING IT RIGHT NOW. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GETTING IT FROM, UH, FROM
OURSELVES THROUGH OUR OWN
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE THROUGH
OUR CLIMATE PACKAGE AND THROUGH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WHICH
LEADS ME TO MY QUESTION. THE
LABOR CENTER PRESENTED. TO THE
LABOR SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE.
SOME TIME AGO AFTER WE
COMMISSIONED THEM TO DO SOME
WORK. UM AND PRESENTED A WHOLE
VOLUME A WHOLE BODY OF WORK. BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY EMPHASIZE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN, WAS THAT
PREDOMINANTLY THE TWO ACTS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. REQUIRED
LABOR STANDARDS AND WHERE THEY
DIDN'T ALLOW. THEY ALLOWED. THEY
DID. THEY ALLOWED AUGMENTATION
OF THOSE LABOR STANDARDS AT THE
STATE LEVEL, MEANING A MORE
STRINGENT STANDARD IF NEED BE,
AND WHERE THEY DIDN'T EXIST.
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN A QUESTION
MARK, BUT IT LOOKED LIKE THAT
WAS IN VERY, VERY FEW AREAS.
SMALL GRANT PROGRAMS AROUND E VÆ
S¼ AND SUCH. WHAT IS YOUR TAKE
ON THAT? YOU MUST BE YOU KNOW?
BOTH OF THEM AT SOME POINT WELL
STUDIED ON. YOU KNOW, MATCHING
THOSE DOLLARS AND I'M REALLY
INTERESTED FROM HEARING FROM
YOU. BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU IF
YOU'RE WORKING WITH P A S¼, IF
YOU'RE DOING EVERYTHING YOU JUST
DESCRIBED, AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
ARE, UH, I GOTTA BELIEVE THAT
YOU'RE NOT FORGO FEDERAL MONEY
WHILE YOU'RE DOING IT. BUT I, I
WANT TO HEAR IT FROM YOU. AND I
THINK, LOOK, I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION HERE JUSTIFIABLY
AND RIGHTFULLY HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT. BUT I THINK IT'S
PARTLY OUR JOB ON THE
LEGISLATIVE LEVEL TO DO THIS
KIND OF WORK AND, YOU KNOW,
DISPEL KINDS OF CONCERNS. I AM
TRYING TO DISPEL THOSE CONCERNS.
BUT IF THEY'RE REAL, LET ME
KNOW. YOU KNOW IF THOSE ARE IF
THAT'S A PROBLEM, LET ME KNOW.
UM SENATOR JUST TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION. UM UH,
YOU YOU'RE ASKING IF THE FACT
THAT THERE AREN'T CERTAIN LABOR
STANDARDS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IS AN OBSTACLE FOR CALIFORNIA.
LET ME CLARIFY THIS BECAUSE IT'S
PERFECT FOR YOU. GIVEN WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM. YOU SEE,
LABOR CENTER GAVE US AN A NUMBER
OF ALMOST $37 BILLION IN IMPACT.
POSITIVE IMPACT TO MANUFACTURING
IN CALIFORNIA COMING FROM, UM
THE BIO AND THE IRA TOTAL
COMBINED ALMOST 37 BILLION.
THINK THERE IS A CONCERN. YOU
KNOW, IN THIS BUILDING. CERTAIN
LEVELS. THAT UM, WE NEED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE DOLLARS.
THAT'S A SHARED CONCERN. BUT
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL CONCERN
THAT I. TRYING TO SORT OUT WITH
YOU RIGHT NOW, UH, WHICH IS THAT
THAT MONEY UM. THAT WE MAY BE
PREEMPTED SOMEHOW FROM FROM
TAKING DOWN SOME OF THAT MONEY.
UM, IF WE AS AS A LEGISLATURE IN
THE SPIRIT OF SB 150 MOVE
FORWARD WITH LABOR STANDARDS AND
AN EQUITY OVERLAY. LIKE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS. ON THOSE
MANUFACTURING DOORS IF WE TAKE
DOWN $36,000,000,037 BILLION OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS MATCH IT UP.
HOWEVER, WE DO IT WITH OUR OWN
PROGRAMS. ARE WE PRECLUDED FROM?
OVERLAYING. LABOR STANDARDS.
LIKE YOU'VE JUST BEEN
DESCRIBING. THAT'S ALL I'M
ASKING. AND THIS IS IT'S A
MANUFACTURING QUESTION. YES
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SO UM, MY
COLLEAGUE UH, MADELINE JANIS I,
I THINK ANSWERED PART OF THIS IN
HER TESTIMONY AS WELL. WHICH IS
YOU KNOW THEY THEY ARE MODELS
FROM THE FEDERAL FUNDING
DISBURSEMENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN LOOK TO, UM SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
UM, IN THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
FUNDING THAT IT BATTERY
MANUFACTURERS ARE APPLYING FOR
THERE IS A COMMUNITY BENEFITS
PORTION OF THE APPLICATION WHERE
A COMPANY WILL GET 20 POINTS UP
TO 20 POINTS. UM, FOR DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS OF, YOU KNOW, HAVING A
COMMUNITY BENEFITS PLAN. UM AND
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA COULD
COULD ADOPT. UM, I, I THINK IN
TERMS OF OTHER, UH, FUNDS IT
IT'D BE A CASE BY CASE, YOU KNOW
, UM, BASIS, BUT, UM, HOPEFULLY
SOME MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE GOING
TO SPEAK ON LATER. PANELS CAN
ALSO ADDRESS THAT CONCERN. I
THINK WHAT WE'RE HEARING IF I
CAN JUST FOLLOW UP THROUGH THE
CHAIR IS SOMEWHERE BETWEEN IT
AND LET ME MAKE SURE I'M NOT
MISSTATING WHAT YOU KNOW. LET ME
REPHRASE WHAT I SAID EARLIER
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME DOUBT OR
GRAY AREA IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
WHAT WE CAN DO IN TERMS OF LABOR
, A CALIFORNIA LABOR STANDARDS
OVERLAY LIKE POS, FOR EXAMPLE,
ON THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS AND IT
WOULD BE GREAT FOR US, IF NOT
TODAY. YOU KNOW, IN YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THIS HEARING, IT
WOULD BE TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL.
IF EITHER OF YOUR SHOPS YOU
KNOW, HAS BACKGROUND ON THAT
THAT YOU CAN FORWARD TO US. YOU
KNOW, AFTER THIS HEARING, WHICH
WE COULD SHARE, NOT ONLY WITH
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
COMMITTEE, THE TWO COMMITTEE
STAFFS BUT ALSO WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT LARGE, YOU KNOW?
IN THE SENATE BECAUSE IT THAT
QUESTION IS PIVOTAL AND IT YOU
KNOW, I WANT TO ON THE ONE HAND
GIVE YOU KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION
HERE. THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH, YOU
KNOW, CREDIT FOR YOU KNOW?
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT. WE DON'T
WANT TO FOREGO DOLLARS, BUT IT'S
PIVOTAL OBVIOUSLY, BECAUSE IF WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD OR IF WE CAN
VERY, VERY CLEAR ON WHERE AND
HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD. IT
MOVES US. WHERE YOU HAVE ALREADY
BEEN INTO. INTO A VISION, A
SHARED VISION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON MOVING FORWARD
INTO THIS INTO MANUFACTURING TO
THE TUNE OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF INVESTMENT WITH LABOR
STANDARDS AND, UM, AND AN EQUITY
LENS IN PLACE IN AS LONG AS
WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT. YOU KNOW,
DISQUALIFYING OURSELVES FOR
THOSE DOLLARS? UM THAT IN OF
ITSELF, I THINK IS SLOWING US
DOWN RIGHT NOW. SO AGAIN, UH,
NOT TO BE REDUNDANT, BUT
ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN HELP
PROVIDE US, YOU KNOW, AS
SOMEBODY SAID EARLIER, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE YOU'RE ON THE GROUND.
YOU'VE DONE IT. UM YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A CERTAIN PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT SCALE. BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. YOURSELVES UM, WE LIKE
TO SEE YOU KNOW, WERE YOU ABLE
TO MAXIMIZE LABOR STANDARDS ON
THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS AND IF
THERE WERE PLACES WHERE YOU ARE
ABLE TO DO IT, I THINK WE REALLY
NEED TO KNOW THE DIFFERENCE. AND
JUST TO KIND OF PROVIDE A WHAT
WE HAVE DONE FOR L A METRO, UH,
WHEN WE DO RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDS
IN THE PAST, YOU KNOW THE
COMMITTEE DO KNOWS THE
GEOGRAPHIC, UH, PROHIBITION THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS, BUT
THROUGH THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW REC, UH,
RECIPIENT OF ANY PUBLIC DOLLARS
IN TERMS OF AGENCY, WHETHER IT'S
BEING USED FOR ROLLING STOCKS OR
CONSTRUCTION GAVE US THE ABILITY
TO IMPLEMENT A LOCAL HIRE
COMPONENT IN IT SO BY THEM,
ELIMINATING GEOGRAPHIC HIRING
PREFERENCE, WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONFORM WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT AGAIN, THAT
PROVISION IS STILL ON THE PILOT
PHASE, WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO
EXPIRE ON 2025 IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN, BUT YET AGAIN TO YOUR
POINT, UH, SENATOR ONCE THAT
RULE HAD BEEN RESCINDED, THEN WE
GO BACK TO THE TO THE ORIGINAL
PLATFORM OF GEOGRAPHIC. UM
PROHIBITION IF YOU WILL, BECAUSE
OF THE GAS TAX. THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE TO REALLY
CONSIDER THE WHOLE UNITED STATES
RATHER THAN HAVING GEOGRAPHIC
HIRING PREFERENCE, SO THAT'S ONE
THING THAT I POINTED OUT EARLIER
IF THERE COULD BE SOME
ASSISTANCE IN TERMS OF
LEGISLATION PER S¼ E, UM, THAT
CAN BE SENT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FROM A PILOT
COMPONENT TO MAKING THIS
PERMANENT THAT TRULY WOULD BE A
GREAT HELP. FOR THE REGION
ITSELF THAT ARE RECIPIENTS OF
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS TO BE ABLE
TO BENEFIT WORKFORCE COMPONENT
IN THAT PARTICULAR REGION. THANK
YOU. OF COURSE, MY ORDER BOOK
THERE. I APPRECIATE YOUR HELP
WITH ALL OF THAT. AND YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CORY AND THANK YOU, MR FLORES.
AND MR HENLEY FOR YOUR AMAZING
TESTIMONY TODAY. LAST THING I DO
HAVE A HANDOUT BECAUSE OF SOME
SUCCESS STORIES THAT I WANTED TO
SHARE TO THE COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. YES. THANK YOU. SO UH,
WE'RE GETTING CLOSE. UH, FOLKS,
WE'RE ON OUR THIRD PANEL. UH OUR
THIRD PANEL IS THE UPDATE ON S¼
B 150 IMPLEMENTATION FROM OUR,
UH STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. UH, PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND HAVE A SEAT AT THE
FRONT TABLE. THANK YOU. IN THIS
PANEL WE WILL HEAR FROM OUR
PARTNERS. UH AT VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS, AND I
KNOW THEY ARE COMING UP AND
TAKING SEATS AND HOPEFULLY WE
HAVE ENOUGH CHAIRS FOR
EVERYBODY. WITH US TODAY IS
UNDERST JACKIE ROBERTS WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. ALONG WITH WE GOT DOUBLE
DUTY HERE. UH UH. DEREK KIRK,
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
CLIMATE, LABOR AND WORKFORCE AT
THE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. WE HAVE
ANGELA SHELL PROCUREMENT
DIVISION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. KEVIN KISH,
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT, AND CURTIS
CURTIS. I DON'T WANT TO MISS NÓ
NOT TODAY. THANK YOU, UH CURTIS
NATIN, CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD, AND THE
UNDERST MARK TOLSON, UM, WITH
OUR CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE. UM WE'LL START WITH YOU,
MISS ROBERTS. UH, AND, UH THEN.
YOU ALL CAN JUST GO IN THE ORDER
THAT YOU FEEL IS BEST. GOOD TO
SEE YOU. I'M GLAD YOU WERE ABLE
TO MAKE IT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON OR EVENING. MADAM
CHAIR, THE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JACKIE ROBERTS AND I AM THE
UNDER SECRETARY OF THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT S¼ B 150, AS WELL
AS CURRENT STATE PARTNERSHIPS TO
ADVANCE TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES.
THE S¼ P 150 PROCESS HAS BEEN A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SHOWCASE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
EXISTING HIGH WORKFORCE
STANDARDS, AS WELL AS TO
HIGHLIGHT THE WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS DIRECTED HIS
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE IN
ADVANCING AND MAXIMIZING STATE
AND FEDERAL DOLLARS. LAST MAY,
WHEN HE ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND CREATED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STRIKE TEAM. HAVE
RESULTED IN A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT. ALL OF OUR
EXECUTIVES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THIS FUNDING COMING TOGETHER AND
REALLY LOOKING AT ALL OF THE
VARIOUS FUNDING MECHANISMS AND
WHERE WE CAN HAVE THE MOST
IMPACT AND ENGAGE WE MEET
REGULARLY AS WELL AS WORKING
ACROSS NOT JUST OUR
ADMINISTRATION, BUT ALSO OUR
PARTNERS OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION, SO IN ADDITION TO
SUBJECT MATTER WORKING GROUPS
WITH THE STRIKE TEAM, WE ALSO
CREATED AN EQUITY BRIDGE WORKING
GROUP THAT HAS ESTABLISHED
PROJECT PRIORITIES TO ENSURE
BENEFITS FLOW TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES, ESSENTIALLY IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE JUSTICE 40
INITIATIVE THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORWARD
AS WELL AS FOCUSING ON
PRIORITIZING GOVERNMENT
ENGAGEMENT WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS, AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. FOR OUR
AGENCY SECRETARY KNOX SERVES AS
AN EXECUTIVE SPONSOR, AND WE
PARTICIPATE AT EVERY LEVEL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROMOTING
THE PRIORITY TO TRAIN AND, UH
IDENTIFY PLACES TO RETAIN
WORKERS AND GOOD JOBS. LABOR
AGENCY HAS LED THE EFFORT TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESS WORKFORCE NEEDS AND TO
ACCELERATE TRAINING AND
UPSKILLING OF WORKERS. THERE ARE
FOUR WORKFORCE ENTITIES UNDER
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. SOME ARE
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU, CURTIS. UM THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD, THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS, OUR
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE SERVICES
BRANCH, AS WELL AS OUR
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. PART
OF OUR WORK AT THE AGENCY LEVEL
IS TO IDENTIFY WHICH ENTITY IS
BEST POSITIONED TO TAKE ON ANY
GIVEN PROJECT WHEN WE HAVE SO
MANY DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES,
BOTH FROM THE FEDERAL AND STATE
LEVEL A FEW SUCCESSFUL EXAMPLES
JUST TO GIVE YOU A TASTE OF WHAT
WE ARE WORKING ON INCLUDES A █20
MILLION DOLLARS HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP FOR OIL
WELL CAPPING THAT IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
CALM WHEN WE SAW AN INCREASE IN
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING
GOING TO THE WORK OF CAPPING OIL
AND GAS WELLS. WE ALSO
IDENTIFIED THAT WE NEEDED TO
INVEST IN WORKER TRAINING, AND
TO DATE APPROXIMATELY 11 MILLION
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED AND GRANT
RECIPIENTS HAVE PARTNERED WITH
BOTH OPERATING ENGINEERS AND
LABORERS TO DESIGN AN
APPRENTICESHIP CURRICULUM FOR
NEW AND TRANSITIONING WORKERS.
THE WORK FOR DEVELOPMENT. THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD ALSO
SUPPORTS OTHER HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS AND
APPLICANTS IN ENGAGING WITH
WORKER REPRESENTATIVES,
NONPROFIT AND COMMUNITY-BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS TO
ENSURE ENGAGEMENT WITH AND
SUPPORT FOR WORKERS FROM
DISADVANTAGED UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES. ANOTHER GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING IS WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
FOUR NEW SEMICONDUCTOR RELATED
INNARDS. EACH OF THOSE FOUR
COMPANIES THAT HAVE PARTNERED
WITH US ARE ALSO PARTNERED WITH
THE FOOTHILLS COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WAS THE REPORT AS THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PARTNER. THIS
COLLEGE IS ALSO A RECIPIENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE GRANTS AND HAS
APPLIED FOR THE U. S, D O L
STRENGTHEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TRAINING GRANT. BOTH OF THESE
GRANTS ARE INTENDED TO HELP
BUILD CAPACITY OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ADDRESS IDENTIFIED
EQUITY GAPS AND MEET THE SKILL
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS OF EMPLOYERS
AND IN DEMAND INDUSTRIES WILL
ALSO DEVELOPING CAREER PATHWAYS
THAT LEAD TO QUALITY JOBS,
PARTICULARLY FOR INDIVIDUALS
FROM HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THESE COMPANIES
THAT WE HAVE PARTNERS WITH ON
THE APPRENTICESHIPS CAN ALSO USE
THESE AS A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
POTENTIAL FEDERAL TRIPS AND
SCIENTISTS GRANT APPLICATIONS IF
THEY CHOOSE TO APPLY FOR THOSE
WE ALSO RECENTLY HAD AN HRT P
PLANNING GRANT OF $500,000 THAT
WENT TO PARTNERSHIP WITH SPARKS.
SO YOU HEARD FROM BEFORE, SO I
WON'T GO INTO THAT ONE. AND WE
HAVE ALSO PARTNERED WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE
APPLICATION FOR THE SOLAR FOR
THE U. S. EPA SOLAR FOR ALL
GRANTS INCLUDED $15 MILLION THAT
ASIDE FOR WORKER TRAINING IF
APPROVED BY THE EPA. THESE FUNDS
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY ED D.
IN COLLABORATION WITH OUR
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL AND
THE FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS FUNDING
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO APPLICANTS AND
AWARDEES AND DEVELOPING
ACCESSIBLE TRAINING PROGRAMS AT
CAPITOL RECRUITMENT STRATEGIES
AND PATHWAYS TO HIGH QUALITY
JOBS AND CAREERS ALIGNED WITH
EVOLUTION OF THE SOLAR AND
STORAGE SECTOR. NEXT MONTH. THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL WILL
CONSIDER AN INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH ENERGY COMMISSION
TO FUND 3 MILLION IN AN
ELECTRICAL VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAINING PROGRAM.
IF APPROVED, THIS WILL FOCUS ON
TRAINING STATE CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIAN'S AND EMPLOYERS AND
TRAINING IS LOCATED IN URBAN,
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AND EACH OF THESE
EXAMPLES LABOR AGENCY WORKED
WITH STATE OUR OTHER PARTNER,
STATE AGENCIES TO ENSURE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDED A FOCUS ON
REACHING DISADVANTAGED WORKERS
IN COMPLIANCE WITH BOTH FEDERAL
AND STATE PRIORITIES. THIS WORK
IS ALIGNED WITH THE PRIORITIES
SET FORTH IN SP 150. I'M GOING
TO TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE DEREK
KIRK TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF RSP
150 STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS. GOOD EVENING CHAIRS AND
SENATORS. MY NAME IS DEREK KIRK
AND I SERVE AS THE ASSISTANT
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF CLIMATE
ECONOMY AT THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. I
LEAD THE AGENCY'S EFFORTS TO
ALIGN WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS IN
POLICIES WITH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, PRIMARILY THROUGH
THE GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA JOBS.
FIRST INITIATIVE. I ALSO SERVE
AS A CO LEAD OF MULTIPLE WORKING
GROUPS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
INFRASTRUCTURE STRIKE TEAM THAT
UNDERSECRETARY ROBERTS MENTIONED
COLLABORATING WITH STATE
AGENCIES ON THE INCLUSION OF
WORKFORCE INTO INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. I WANT TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE FOR YOU ALL ON THE SP
150 STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT THE
LABOR AGENCY CO LEAD ALONGSIDE
OUR PARTNERS AT THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY, THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES, AS WELL AS THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY, WHO WE SAW FIT
TO BRING IN BEFORE WE KICKED OFF
THE PROCESS, KNOWING THEIR
INCREDIBLE ROLE IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. IN
DECEMBER, 2023 AND JANUARY 2024.
THE INTERAGENCY TEAM LED FIVE
STAKEHOLDER SESSIONS WITH THREE
SECTOR SPECIFIC SESSIONS ON
CONSTRUCTION, TRANSPORTATION,
MANUFACTURING AND CLEAN ENERGY.
THE FOURTH SESSION WAS FOCUSED
ON EDUCATING STAKEHOLDERS ON
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAWS AND THE
WORK OUR STATE ALREADY DOES AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE LIMITATIONS
THAT WE HAVE THE LAST SESSION
SESSION WAS AN OPEN DIALOGUE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS. EACH OF
THESE SESSIONS HAD APPROXIMATELY
60 TO 90 PARTICIPANTS VIRTUALLY
FOR THE FIRST THREE AS WELL IN
VIRTUALLY AND IN PERSON FOR THE
FINAL TWO. PARTICIPANTS
REPRESENTED LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES LABOR ORGANIZATIONS,
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS,
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS,
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
POPULATIONS HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. WE ALSO RECEIVED
SUBSTANTIVE WRITTEN FEEDBACK AND
ARE REVIEWING THAT FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE ALIGNED
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND GUIDANCE AS
WELL AS FOR FEASIBILITY TO
IMPLEMENT. SOME OF THE HIGH
LEVEL INFORMATION ON THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
OUR STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDES
RECOMMENDATIONS TO DEVELOP A
LOCAL HIRE REQUIREMENT REQUIRE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS REQUIRE
CONTRACTORS TO EMPLOY
APPRENTICES IN THE EXECUTION OF
THEIR CONTRACTS, REQUIRING THE
INCLUSION OF NON UNION UNION
APPRENTICES IN THE WORK
REQUIRING CONTRACTORS TO COMMIT
TO HIRING DISADVANTAGED WORKERS
AT A MINIMUM RATIO. UM REQUIRING
CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR TRANSPORTATION, CHILD CARE
AND SAFETY, AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING NEW AND ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS AGAIN. A LIST OF SOME
OF THE HIGH LEVEL POINTS IN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE RECEIVED
ONE OF THE KEY MESSAGES I WANT
TO END ON BEFORE HANDING IT TO,
UM DEPUTY DIRECTOR SHELL IS
REALLY IN THIS PROCESS WE
UNDERSTOOD AND HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND IN OUR
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH EACH
OTHER THAT THERE IS REALLY NO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
THE VARIOUS FUNDING STREAMS,
HOWEVER, WITH THE STRUCTURE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SET UP
WITH CONSISTENT COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN AGENCIES. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE EQUITY
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. IS THIS
WORKING? CAN YOU HEAR ME? WE CAN
SWAP OUT. THIS ONE. THIS ONE'S
WORKING. OKAY THERE WE GO.
NORMALLY I'M PRETTY LOUD, SO ALL
RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY. MY NAME IS ANGELA SHELL,
AND I AM THE STATE'S CHIEF
PROCUREMENT OFFICER, AS WELL AS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
PROCUREMENT DIVISION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
MY ROLE IS TO OVERSEE THE
STATE'S PROCUREMENT OF GOODS AND
SERVICES, INCLUDING ISSUING
PROCUREMENT POLICY AND MANAGING
THE STATE STANDARD CONTRACT
TERMS AND CONDITIONS. THIS DOES
NOT INCLUDE PUBLIC WORKS,
CONTRACTS OR GRANTS. UM, AND
THOSE CONTRACTING PROGRAMS ARE
ADMINISTERED BY THE SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENTS WITH THAT AUTHORITY
TO AWARD PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
AND GRANTS. SO TODAY, I'D LIKE
TO JUST PROVIDE YOU WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S EXISTING
CONTRACT TERMS AND CONDITIONS
THAT ARE EITHER DIRECTLY RELATED
TO CALIFORNIA LABOR STANDARDS OR
ARE IN SUPPORT OF OR COMPLEMENT
THOSE STANDARDS AS WELL AS ANY
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS THAT THE
STATE CURRENTLY HAS IN PLACE. SO
FOR ALL STATE CONTRACTS, ALL
TYPES OF STATE CONTRACTS, THERE
ARE BASED CONTRACT TERMS AND
CONDITIONS AND DEPARTMENTS CAN
THEN ADD IN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH ALL OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. SO GENERALLY THERE
IS A REQUIREMENT FOR THE VENDOR
TO BROADLY ADHERE TO ALL STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LAWS, REGULATIONS,
RULES AND ORDERS AND THAT
INCLUDES MINIMUM WAGE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE FOUND IN
INDUSTRIAL WELFARE COMMISSION
ORDERS THAT INCLUDES THE EIGHT
HOUR WORK DAY, THE 40 HOUR WORK,
WEEK, MEALS AND REST PERIODS AND
THE PAID SICK LEAVE PROGRAM FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THERE
IS ALSO A REQUIREMENT FOR
VENDORS TO ADHERE TO SAFETY AND
ACCIDENT PREVENTION REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE SET FORTH AGAIN IN THE
CONTRACT IN STATE REGULATIONS
AND STATE LAWS. ANY VIOLATION OF
THESE RULES AND REQUIREMENTS
UNLESS PROMPTLY CORRECTED IS
GROUNDS FOR TERMINATION OF
CONTRACT FOR DEFAULT. THERE'S
ALSO REQUIREMENT FOR EXAMINATION
AND AUDIT OF CONTRACT RECORDS,
BOTH FOR PRIME VENDORS AND SUB
VENDORS. THREE YEAR REQUIREMENT
AND THE STATE HAS THE ABILITY TO
GO IN AND INTERVIEW EMPLOYEES
DIRECTLY AND THEY CAN INSPECT
ANY CONTRACT RELATED RECORDS,
INCLUDING THOSE RECORDS THAT ARE
RELATED TO WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS. THERE'S ALSO
REQUIREMENT FOR DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT FREE WORKPLACE IS
SO NO UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION OR
HARASSMENT AGAINST EMPLOYEES OR
APPLICANTS DURING THE EMPLOYMENT
OR EVALUATIONS OF APPLICANTS. UM
WORKERS. I'M SORRY. BUSINESSES
ARE REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
SIGNATORY LABOR ORGANIZATIONS OF
THIS REQUIREMENT ON STATE
CONTRACTS, AND IT DOES REQUIRE
THIS CLAUSE TO BE IN ANY
SUBCONTRACTS ON STATE CONTRACTS.
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT FOR A
SWEAT FREE CODE OF CONDUCT FOR
WORKPLACES. THIS MEANS THAT NO
WORK IN WHOLE OR IN PART, BY OR
WITH THE BENEFIT OF SWEATSHOP
LABOR FORCED LABOR. CONVICT
LABOR, INDENTURED LABOR UNDER
THE PENAL SANCTIONS, ABUSIVE
FORMS OF CHILD LABOR OR
EXCELLENT EXPLOITATION OF
CHILDREN IN SWEATSHOP LABOR, SO
THAT'S A REQUIREMENT IN STATE
CONTRACTS. THERE'S ALSO SPECIAL
TYPES OF CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS.
THERE ARE IN ADDITION TO THESE
ABOVE CONTRACTS, SO WE DO HAVE
PERSONAL SERVICES CONTRACTS THAT
HAVE A SET REQUIREMENT FOR WAGES
AT A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF WHAT
THE STATE WORKFORCE PAY IS.
THERE IS HEALTH CARE BENEFITS
ALSO ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
PERSONAL SERVICE CONTRACTS, AND
THEN THERE'S MONTHLY COMPLIANCE
REPORTING TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR STATE DEPARTMENTS
USING THOSE PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS. FOR PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACTS, THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR APPLICABLE
PREVAILING WAGES THAT CAN
INCLUDE BENEFIT PACKAGES OR CASH
. IN LIEU OF THOSE PACKAGES.
THERE ARE APPRENTICESHIP
MINIMUMS, AND THERE ARE MONTHLY
PAYROLL REPORTING AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS COMPLIANCE CHECKS. WE
ALSO HAVE A HIGH ROADS, JOBS,
LANGUAGE THAT IS REQUIRED FOR
ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT VEHICLES
AS WELL AS OUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
SUPPLY EQUIPMENT. THAT'S OVER 10
MILLION THE SUPPLIES TO DGS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION, ONLY THESE HIGH
ROADS JOBS REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR
NO MISCLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
COMPLIANCE BY THE PRIME AND ANY
SUBS WITH ALL APPLICABLE STATE,
FEDERAL, STATE AND LOCAL LAWS
PERTAINING TO PAID SICK LEAVE,
INCLUDING ANY ANTI RETALIATION
PROVISIONS THAT ARE CONTAINED IN
THESE LAWS. COMPLIANCE BY THE
PRIME IN ANY SUBS WITH ALL
APPLICABLE SAFETY AND HEALTH
LAWS AND REGULATIONS, AS WELL AS
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
SET FORTH IN THE LABOR CODE.
THIS IS AGAIN NONDISCRIMINATION
FOR COMPLAINTS FOR SAFETY
VIOLATIONS. COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL A. D A LAWS. THESE
CONTRACTS ALSO REQUIRE THAT THE
VENDORS ENTER INTO LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENTS WITH EXISTING
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THEN THERE'S
ANNUAL REPORTING, DEMONSTRATING
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE
REQUIREMENTS AND A $10,000
WITHHOLD FROM VENDOR PAYMENTS
FOR FAILURE TO COMPLY. FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED CONTRACTS. IN
ADDITION TO OUR STANDARDS, STATE
REQUIREMENTS. CONTRACTS WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS ALSO INCLUDE
NONDISCRIMINATION AND EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT, OPPORTUNITY
REQUIREMENTS, TRAINING AND
PROMOTION, APPRENTICESHIP
REQUIREMENTS, ANTI RETALIATION
FOR REPORTING OF LABOR STANDARD
VIOLATIONS, AND THEN IF THEY'RE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS, THERE
ARE ALSO FEDERAL PREVAILING
RATES REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN,
LASTLY FOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE. THERE ARE REFERRALS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS FOR INVESTIGATIONS.
THERE'S CONTRACTS, SANCTIONS AND
OR TERMINATION OF THE CONTRACT.
THE STATE DOES HAVE THE ABILITY
TO HOLD RESPONSIBILITY HEARINGS
FOR VENDOR FOR VENDORS WHO DO
NOT COMPLY OR HAVE A HISTORY OF
NOT COMPLYING WITH THE STATE'S
CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO TERMINATION FOR
DEFAULT FOR VENDORS WHO FAILED
TO ADHERE TO ANY OF THE CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS ON THE STANDARD
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXIST TODAY.
I'M HAPPY, HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR I CAN DEFER TO THE
NEXT ON THE PANEL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OH, OKAY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. SMALL EQUIVALENTS SHARE.
WHAT HAD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS KEVIN
KISH. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OR CRD.
WE ENFORCE CALIFORNIA'S ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS, CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS AND A NUMBER OF
CONTEXT, THE RELEVANT ONES FOR
OUR DISCUSSION TODAY. OF COURSE,
OUR LAWS THAT APPLY TO WORK
PLACES LAWS THAT APPLY TO ALL
STATE FUNDED ACTIVITIES AND
PROGRAMS AND CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS
THAT APPLY TO STATE CONTRACTING.
EACH YEAR, OUR DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATES THOUSANDS OF
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE FILED WITH
US. WE MEDIATE AND SECURE
SETTLEMENTS FOR AS MANY OF THOSE
AS POSSIBLE AND WE PROSECUTE
CIVIL ACTIONS IN COURT INTENDED
TO BROADLY BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS.
WE CONDUCT EXTENSIVE EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES WE COLLECT
AND ANALYZE NEARLY 30,000 PAID
DATA REPORTS EACH YEAR. FROM
LARGE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS WITH
THE GOAL OF IDENTIFYING AND
REDUCING SEX AND RACE BASED PAY
DISPARITIES. AND JUST IN THE
PAST YEAR WE LAUNCHED THE
CALIFORNIA VERSUS HEAT, RESOURCE
LINE AND NETWORK CONNECTING
PEOPLE TARGETED FOR HATE WITH
SERVICES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES,
AND WE BEGAN OFFERING CONFLICT
RESOLUTION SERVICES DIRECTLY TO
COMMUNITIES. EXPERIENCING
TENSIONS RELATED TO HATE AND
DISCRIMINATION. THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS WE ENFORCE
ARE AMONG THE STRONGEST IN THE
NATION, ALMOST ALL CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS ARE LEGALLY REQUIRED
TO DO A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
CONSIDERED RECOMMENDED OR
PROMISING PRACTICES FOR
PROMOTING EQUITY AND REDUCING
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
AND WORKPLACES HAVE A LONG LIST
OF THEM. I THINK MANY OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THEM. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE, WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES ALL
EMPLOYERS HAVE FIVE OR MORE
EMPLOYEES TO HAVE A WRITTEN ANTI
DIS CRIMEN ATION POLICY. UM,
THAT IS AGAINST DISCRIMINATION,
HARASSMENT AND ALSO, RETALIATION
IN THIS POLICY MUST BE
DISSEMINATED TO EMPLOYEES BE
HANDED OUT TO THEM IN A LANGUAGE
THEY UNDERSTAND. IT MUST
DESCRIBE HOW EMPLOYEES CAN FILE
COMPLAINTS, IT MUST GUARANTEE A
FAIR INTERNAL COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION PROCESS. IT MUST
DESCRIBE REMEDIES, AND IT MUST
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
CONTACTING OUR DEPARTMENT, AMONG
OTHER REQUIREMENTS. AS WE DEPLOY
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THE PLANNING
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
. WE HAVE CONSULTED WITH THEM TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS, AND THE
GOAL, OF COURSE, IS TO MAXIMIZE
BENEFITS TO HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED, MARGINALIZED
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES. WE DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF ENFORCEMENT TOOLS THAT WE CAN
USE TO PROTECT WORKERS AND
EMPLOYMENT, CONTEXT AND
EMPLOYERS THAT ARE RECEIVING
THESE FUNDS, INCLUDING
INDUSTRIES OF PARTICULAR
INTERESTS UNDER SP 150,
INCLUDING CONSTRUCTION AND
MANUFACTURING, SO WE ACCEPT
COMPLAINTS. FIRST OF ALL, NOT
JUST IN THE EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT
BUT ALSO COMPLAINTS INVOLVING
STATE CONTRACTOR NONCOMPLIANCE
WITH CERTAIN LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
AROUND ANTI DISCRIMINATION THAT
I MENTIONED. AS WELL AS
COMPLAINTS ALLEGING ALLEGING
DISCRIMINATION IN ANY STATE
FUNDED ACTIVITY OR PROGRAM. THIS
IS GOVERNMENT CODE 11135, WHICH
IS THE STATE EQUIVALENT OF THE
FEDERAL TITLE SIX. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU THAT IN THE
EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT, WHICH IS
WHERE WE RECEIVED THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT
COME IN THE DOOR WHEN WE RECEIVE
A COMPLAINT FROM A WORKER. ONE
OF THE THINGS WE FIND OUT
AFFIRMATIVELY IS WHETHER THAT
EMPLOYER IS A STATE CONTRACTOR.
AND IF THEY ARE AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION, WE CAN CONFIRM
WHETHER THE EMPLOYER HAS THE
REQUIRED POLICIES AND RECORDS
AND TRAINING RECORDS. AND
DEPENDING ON THE FACTS OF THE
CASE, WE CAN ANALYZE DISPARITIES
AND HIRING AND PROMOTIONS AND
COMPENSATION AND BENEFITS AND
LOOKING AT THESE DISPARITIES, WE
CAN USE THE PAY DATA THAT I
MENTIONED, WHICH IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
EMBEDDING EQUITY AND THESE
INVESTMENTS. AND SO JUST LOOKING
AT EMPLOYERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY, LARGE EMPLOYERS WHO
SUBMIT PAY DATA TO US WE SEE
THAT RELATIVE TO THEIR OVERALL
REPRESENTATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE. THERE ARE FEWER BLACK
WORKERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
SECTOR. YOU HEARD THIS FROM MISS
SOLOMON ON THE FIRST PANEL AS
WELL. WE KNOW THAT RELATIVE TO
THEIR OVERALL REPRESENTATION IN
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE. THERE
ARE MORE HISPANIC WORKERS AND
THE CONSTRUCTION SECTOR AND THAT
BOTH BLACK AND HISPANIC WORKERS
ARE OVERRUN. SCENTED IN LOW WAGE
POSITIONS IN THIS INDUSTRY AND
IN THE LOWEST PAY BANDS AND WHEN
IT COMES TO PAY DISPARITIES, WE
KNOW THAT BLACK AND HISPANIC
WORKERS ARE EARNING LESS PER
DOLLAR THAN WHITE WORKERS IN
EVERY JOB CATEGORY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR. AND THAT
THE PAY GAP PAY GAP IS WIDEST IN
THE LOWEST PAID POSITIONS FOR
SERVICE WORKERS, SO THIS DATA
ALLOWS US AT CRD TO IDENTIFY
WAGE PATTERNS FOR ENFORCEMENT OF
EQUAL PAY IN. IT ALSO ENCOURAGES
EMPLOYERS TO SELF ASSESS. WE
OFTEN SAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
THAT YOU CAN'T FIX SOMETHING
THAT YOU DON'T SEE AND SO JUST
THE ACT OF COLLECTING THE DATA
AND REPORTING IT PROMOTES
VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE WITH EQUAL
PAY AND ANTI DISCRIMINATION
LAWS. FINALLY GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS
HAVE AFFIRMATIVE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION OBLIGATIONS THAT
GO BEYOND THOSE APPLICABLE TO
ALL EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE. AND
AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY, ANYONE
WHO HAS A FEDERAL CONTRACTOR
ABOVE A CERTAIN MONETARY
THRESHOLD IS SUBJECT TO
AFFIRMATIVE AUDIT BY THE OFFICE
OF FEDERAL CONTRACT COMPLIANCE
PROGRAMS. AND ARM OF THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. CRD HAS
LONG HAD STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
PROACTIVELY AUDIT THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION PROGRAMS OF
PUBLIC CONTRACTORS. FUNDING FOR
THIS COMPLIANCE PROGRAM, AS YOU
KNOW, WAS ELIMINATED IN THE MID
NINETIES. WE CONTINUE TO ENFORCE
ANTI DISCRIMINATION REQUIREMENTS
THROUGH THE INVESTIGATION OF
COMPLAINTS THAT I PREVIOUSLY
DESCRIBED. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS, AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. NOW WE'RE AT
THE END.
GOT US. SLIDE. IT'S NOT WORKING.
OH, THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING.
GOOD EVENING, MADAM CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS CURTIS, CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING OUR
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING
ON SB 150 IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS OUR HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS PROGRAM
SLIDE DECK HERE. ALSO, THAT WILL
BE, UM WORKING FROM YOU DON'T
SEE IT UP ON THE SCREEN YET.
THERE WE GO. ALRIGHT MY COMMENTS
THIS EVENING WILL FOCUS ON HOW
THE STATE IS COLLABORATING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
, CALTRANS AND OTHER RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE ALLOCATION
OF FEDERAL I J FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY HOW WE ARE WORKING
TO ENSURE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE ALLOCATED AND TO OUR
COMMUNITIES EQUITABLY AND OUR
PLANS TO DEVELOP A HIGH ROAD
WORKFORCE THAT UPLIFTS
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. I'LL SET THE TABLE
FOR THIS DISCUSSION WITH
ANSWERING THE QUESTION. WHAT IS
HIGH ROAD HIGH ROAD IS DEFINED
IN THE CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CODE 14005 AS A SET OF
ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC GROWTH,
ECONOMIC EQUITY, SHARED
PROSPERITY AND A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT. STRATEGIES INCLUDE,
BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
INTERVENTIONS THAT ONE IMPROVED
JOB QUALITY AND JOB ACCESS,
INCLUDING FOR WOMEN AND PEOPLE
FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
POPULATIONS TO MEET THE SKILL
AND PROFITABILITY NEEDS OF
EMPLOYERS AND THREE MEET THE
ECONOMIC, SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY. WITH THIS SET OF
STRATEGIES LOOKS LIKE IN A FIELD
OF PRACTICE IS ALSO DEFINED IN
SUBSETS OF THE SAME CODE SECTION
, WHICH DEFINES HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS, OR H R T.
P S H. R T P IS DEFINED AS AN
INITIATIVE OR PROJECT THAT MODEL
STRATEGIES FOR DEVELOPING
INDUSTRY BASED WORKER FOCUSED
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS, INCLUDING
LABOR MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIPS.
HR TPS OPERATE VIA REGIONAL
INDUSTRY OR SECTOR BASED
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS COMPRISED
OF EMPLOYERS, WORKERS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES, INCLUDING
ORGANIZED LABOR. NEEDED BASED
ORGANIZATIONS, EDUCATION,
TRAINING AND SOCIAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS AND LABOR MARKET
INTERMEDIARIES. HR TPS
DEMONSTRATE JOB QUALITY
STANDARDS AND EMPLOYMENT
PRACTICES. AND A VARIETY OF WAYS
AS DEFINED IN THE CODE. HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CAREERS, OR
HRC, CSR HRT PS THAT ARE
EXCLUSIVE TO CONSTRUCTION. THESE
ARE DEFINED IN SUB T 14 005 AS
HIGH ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
THAT INVEST IN REGIONAL TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS COMPRISED OF LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS.
WORKFORCE COMMUNITY AND
EDUCATION INTERESTS THAT CONNECT
TO STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT UTILIZE THE
STANDARD MULTI CRAFT CORE
CURRICULUM OR THE THREE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP OR APPRENTICESHIP
, READINESS TRAINING CURRICULUM
AND PROVIDE A RANGE OF
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IN CAREER
PLACEMENT ASSISTANCE TO WOMEN
AND PEOPLE FROM UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
THE INTENT OF HRC SEE IN THE
CONTEXT OF SB 1150 IS THREEFOLD.
WANT TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR
QUALIFIED CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE FEDERAL I,
I J FUNDED TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS TO PROMOTE EQUITY IN
ACCESS TO STATE APPROVED JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WITH A
FOCUS ON WOMEN WORKERS FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES,
VETERANS AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. AND THREE PUT MORE
PEOPLE TO WORK MORE MONEY IN THE
POCKETS OF CALIFORNIANS AND MORE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND REGIONS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT. MOST.
THE CW DB WORKS CLOSELY WITH
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND CURRENTLY
OVERSEES AND FUNDS 13 REGIONAL
HRC SEE PARTNERSHIPS COVERING
ALL 58 COUNTIES. WITH LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS, JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS, LOCAL
WORKFORCE BOARDS, COLLEGES AND
OTHER EDUCATION PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS,
ALL AT ONE REGIONAL TABLE TO
COORDINATE AND DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMMING THAT MEETS
THE NEEDS OF EMPLOYERS, WORKERS
AND COMMUNITIES. HRC SEE
TRAINEES ARE PROVIDED WITH
VARIOUS OPPORTUNITIES TO FURTHER
THEIR CAREER GOALS WITHIN THE
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR, INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO EMC THREE
TRAINING. ACCESS TO STATE
APPROVED JOINT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN THE TRADES AND
PLACEMENTS AND IN THIS CASE
SPECIFICALLY ON CALTRANS
PROJECTS. TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS
OF TRAINEES. HRC CS PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT WILL
INCLUDE THE ISSUANCE OF CRITICAL
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO ENABLE INDIVIDUALS
TO SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATE IN
TRAINING. SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
CHILDCARE STIPENDS, TOOLING WORK
, CLOTHES, TRANSPORTATION, EVEN
UNION DUES TO GET THEM STARTED.
ACCESS TO THE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES IS CRUCIAL FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT, SUCH AS
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND WOMEN. BOTH
PRIORITY POPULATIONS UNDER H. R.
C. C. THESE SERVICES CAN ALSO
CONTINUE IN A LIMITED FASHION
AFTER PROGRAM COMPLETION TO
SUPPORT PLACEMENT INTO
APPRENTICESHIPS TO ENSURE
RETENTION. HRC SEE ALSO ENSURES
THAT THE ENTITIES WITH VERIFIED
EXPERIENCE SERVING HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE
TO PROPERLY ADMINISTER THEIR
PROGRAMS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND UNIQUE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. THESE INCLUDE
COORDINATING PARTNERS PROVIDING
CASE MANAGEMENT, MENTORING
TRAUMA AND FOREIGN COUNSELING,
MATH AND LANGUAGE, REMEDIATION
AND OTHER ASSISTANCE TO
PARTICIPANTS TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL PARTICIPATION IN
PLACEMENT. SB 150 REQUIRED
CALTRANS TO SET ASIDE A TOTAL OF
50 MILLION OF FEDERAL FUNDS FROM
THE I J TO BE ALLOCATED OVER
FOUR YEARS TO SUPPORT HRC. SEE.
PARTNERING WITH CALTRANS TO
DEVELOP AN INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT
WHERE CALTRANS SEEKS THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE CW DB TO
ADMINISTER THE HRC C PROGRAM ON
THEIR BEHALF. AND SPELLS OUT THE
ROLES OF EACH ENTITY. THE CW DB
WILL UTILIZE THE EXISTING HRC
SEE SOLICITATION AND AWARD
PROCESS. THERE ARE COLLEAGUE
GRANT SYSTEM. FOR ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES TO APPLY FOR AN ACCESS
FUNDING. THE CW. DB WILL ALSO DO
OUTREACH TO ENSURE THAT
PROVIDERS AND RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS ARE AWARE OF THE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITY. CONVENED
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE, SOLICIT
AND SCORE APPLICATIONS RECOMMEND
AWARDS TO THE SECRETARY FOR
FINAL APPROVAL AND DEVELOP AND
EXECUTE GRANT AGREEMENTS FOR HRC
CS ACROSS THE STATE. C W. D B
WILL ALSO PROVIDE GRANT
MANAGEMENT AFTER GRANT
AGREEMENTS ARE EXECUTED. THIS
INCLUDES SUPPORTING GRANTEES TO
ENSURE THAT GRANT GOALS AND
DELIVERABLES ARE DOCUMENTED AND
ON TRACK. MENTORING AND TRACKING
BUDGETS AND FISCAL SPENDING.
MANAGING INVOICE, SUBMISSION,
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
DATA COLLECTION AND MANAGING
CLOSE OUT PROCESSES. C W. D B
WILL RECEIVE 50 MILLION OVER
FOUR FISCAL YEARS. STARTING IN
FISCAL YEAR 2425 AND CONTINUING
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR 2728. PART
OF THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. THE
50 MILLION WILL ALSO COVER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EVALUATION AS WELL AS COVERING
CWD BE STAFFING COBB COSTS. WE
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
CALTRANS ON THE DRAFT SCOPE OF
WORK AND RELATED FORMS TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE C W.
D B WILL REPORT TO CALTRANS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH FEDERAL GUIDANCE
ADDRESSING EXPENDITURE AMOUNTS,
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT PARTICIPANTS
IN TRAINING OUTCOMES AND OTHER
BENEFITS IDENTIFIED BY THE
PROJECT, CALTRANS AND OR THE CWD
B. THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS HOW HIGH ROAD
STRATEGIES AND HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS HAVE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HELP MEET THE
DEMAND FOR SKILLED LABOR THROUGH
THE LENS OF EQUITY, JOB QUALITY
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE. ALRIGHT
YEAH. GOOD EVENING CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS AM MARKT OLSON AND THE
UNDER SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY WILL BE THE LAST OF OUR
PANEL HERE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE TODAY
AND GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY SHARE HOW CALISTA AS WELL
AS OUR DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING
TO CREATE JOBS AND PROVIDING
WORKLOADS TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
HAVE HEARD FROM SOME OF OUR
OTHER PANELISTS HERE. THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE ON
THE WORKFORCE SIDE, BUT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM TO
DO MORE WITH THE OPPORTUNITIES
BEFORE US. ONE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES IS THE, UM,
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW OR
THE IJ. WE ANTICIPATE OVER $41.9
BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
CALTRANS. WE SO FAR HAVE
INVESTED ABOUT $7 BILLION THAT'S
GENERATED ABOUT 90 PLUS 1000
JOBS. FOR THAT ABOUT 13,000 JOBS
FOR EVERY BILLION DOLLARS
ISSUED. CALTRANS HAS THREE
PROGRAMS THAT WE PRIMARILY FOCUS
ON WITH RESPECT ARE CONTRACTING
TO ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES.
THOSE ARE FEDERAL DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM, THE
STATE SMALL BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM IN OUR DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAMS. A
COUPLE OF THINGS TO HIGHLIGHT
FOR YOU IS THAT NEARLY 30% OF
ALL OF OUR CONTRACTS LAST YEAR
WENT OUT TO SMALL BUSINESSES,
AND WE AWARDED OVER $1 BILLION
THIS PAST YEAR, WHICH WAS A
RECORD FOR US. THE OTHER PIECE
WITH RESPECT TO THE IJ FUNDED
CONTRACTS. WE ARE ABLE TO HAVE
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE GOALS AND THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR 2023 22.3% OF ALL OF
OUR CONTRACT DOLLARS WERE
COMMITTED TO DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES, WHICH
SURPASSES THE TRIANGLE GOAL OF
22.2. J ALONE INCLUDES OVER $800
MILLION AND DEDICATED
INVESTMENTS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN USD, CURRENTLY
HAS 40 PROGRAMS ACROSS FIVE
MODES OF VIJAY AS PART OF THE
JUSTICE 40 INITIATIVES. A COUPLE
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS THAT I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON. WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN A VARIETY OF GRAND
OPPORTUNITIES, ONE OF WHICH IS
$400 MILLION FOR THE NAVY
PROGRAM, THE NATIONAL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INITIATIVE AS WELL AS
$150 MILLION IN FUNDING FOR THE
MESA EASTPORT OF ENTRY PROJECT
THROUGH THE INFRA PROGRAM. BOTH
OF THOSE INCLUDE WORKFORCE AND
JUSTICE 40 REQUIREMENTS,
INCLUDING COMMUNITY BENEFITS
AGREEMENTS, PRE APPRENTICESHIP.
AND INVESTMENTS FOR JUSTICE. 40
TARGETED COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY FOR MESA EAST. AND
THAT WILL INCLUDE A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT. WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RISING CAREER
PROGRAMS, AS WELL AS A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AIMED AT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT OUR PRE
APPRENTICESHIPS EFFORTS ACROSS
OUR AGENCY. ALSO, CALTRANS
ANNUALLY PROVIDES PRE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING. AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TARGETED TO
AT RISK AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. A COUPLE EXAMPLES
OF THAT ARE HEAVY EQUIPMENT IN
CONSTRUCTION TRADES ACADEMY,
WHICH PROVIDES THE ALREADY
ACCELERATED TRAINING AND HEAVY
EQUIPMENT OPERATION. TO DATE,
THERE HAVE BEEN 40 GRADUATES,
ACTUALLY WITH 100% GRADUATION
RATE, AND THOSE ARE PROVIDING
JOB PLACEMENT SERVICES AND
SUPPORT FOR GRADUATES AS WELL.
WE'RE ALSO EXCITED WITH THE
PROGRESS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD, THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING DIVERSITY FUND
PARTNERSHIP. WHICH MR KNUTSON A
PREVIOUSLY SPOKE ABOUT ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL ON THE AUTHORITY HAS
PARTNERED WITH THE CITY OF
SELMA, THE PRESIDENT OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION, A
NUMBER OF OUR LOCAL TRADES
COUNCILS. TO ESTABLISH OUR
CENTRAL VALLEY TRAINING CENTER.
12 WEEK CREATION PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM NO COST
PRE APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
PROGRAMS AIMED AT SERVING
VETERANS AT RISK YOUTH,
MINORITIES AND LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, PROVIDING THEM WITH
HANDS ON CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
TRAINING. AND SINCE THE START OF
THAT PROGRAM, HOW THE TRAINING
CENTER HAS GRADUATED 151
STUDENTS WITH MORE THAN 1000
ENQUIRING ABOUT THE PROGRAM, AND
SO A LOT OF INTEREST ABOUT 10
COHORTS HAVE GONE THROUGH SO FAR
. NEARLY 60% OF THOSE
PARTICIPANTS ARE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. JUST ON THE
BROADER JOB FRONT FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY HAS CREATED MORE
THAN 12,900 JOBS, BUILDING HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. UM AND IN ADDITION THAT
EQUATES TO ABOUT 1300
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS DISPATCHED
DAILY ALONG THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT. I WANTED TO TOUCH AS
WELL ON SOME OF THE COMPLIANCE
AND ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS, WHICH
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE WORK
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
BEYOND THE FUNDING AND JOBS
GENERATED. CALTRANS IS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING ITS
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS
COMPLY WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
LABOR STANDARDS. ACCOMPLISHES
THIS THROUGH ITS DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS PROVED
LABOR COMPLIANCE PROGRAM. SO ALL
KYLE. TRANS PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS INCLUDE CONTRACT
LANGUAGE, ADDRESSING STATE LABOR
STANDARDS AND NONDISCRIMINATION.
ALL PROJECTS FUNDED THROUGH
FEDERAL HIGHWAYS ALSO REQUIRE
FEDERAL LABOR STANDARDS. BOTH
REQUIRE PAYMENT OF WAGES AND
BENEFITS FOR WORK PERFORMED
APPRENTICESHIP. WORKERS'
COMPENSATION INSURANCE,
NONDISCRIMINATION AND SUBMISSION
OF SURGICAL CERTIFIED PAYROLL
RECORDS. SO THEY CALTRANS LABOR
COMPLIANCE MONITORS AND FORCES.
THIS THEY DO. CONTRACTOR AND
PROJECT REGISTRATION. PRE JOB
MEETINGS WITH THE CONTRACTOR ON
SITE DOCUMENTATION OF ACTIVITIES
PERFORMED THE REVIEW, CONFIRM
AUDIT AND INVESTIGATE
CONTRACTORS AND THEIR PAYROLL
RECORDS. THEY IDENTIFIED
VIOLATIONS FOR NONCOMPLIANCE.
THEY WILL SUBMIT CASES TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER. FOR
UNRESOLVED VIOLATIONS AND JUST
OVERALL FROM THE 2022 TO 2023
FISCAL YEAR, CALTRANS REPORTED
THAT IT COLLECTED $807,000 IN
RESTITUTION AND WAGES RECOVERED
FOR WORKERS. THEY ALSO SUBMITTED
A TOTAL OF 16 WAGE CASES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TOTALING OVER 1.1
MILLION IN WAGES AND PENALTIES
THAT ARE AWAITING HEARING. YEAH
SO A FEW OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT BEYOND THE WORK
THAT I JUST DISCUSSED, CALTRANS
IS DEVELOPING AN ADDITIONAL
STRATEGY WITH RESPECT TO LOCAL
HIRE CALTRANS. THEY'RE DRAFTING
A LOCAL HIRE AND TARGETED
WORKFORCE CONCEPT, WHICH
INCLUDES THE LOCAL HIGHER
PERCENTAGE WITHIN QUALIFYING ZIP
CODES. IN A TARGETED WORKER GOAL
TO HIRE WITH TO HIRE THOSE WITH
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. ALSO THE
DRAFT PROPOSALS IN THE COMMENT
PHASE STILL BEING WORKED THROUGH
. WE WANT TO DO THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ENGAGING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEN WE WILL
PILOT THE IMPLEMENTATION.
ANOTHER PIECE TO THIS IS
DEVELOPING A WORKFORCE,
DEMOGRAPHIC TRACKING AND
REPORTING TOOL. ALSO CALTRANS
LABOR COMPLIANCE OFFICE UTILIZES
SOFTWARE TO COLLECT SUBMITTED
PAYROLLS THAT COME IN WEEKLY FOR
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO EXPAND THAT TO OTHER
TYPES OF CONTRACTS BEYOND JUST
CONSTRUCTION ALSO BE REPAIRED
INSTALLATION, ARCHITECTURAL AND
ENGINEERING CONTRACTS. WE'RE
CURRENTLY EXPANDING THAT.
CAPABILITY FOR DEMOGRAPHIC
REPORTING AND CONFIGURING THE
SOFTWARE FOR ADDITIONAL TRACKING
AND REPORTING AND REPORTING OF
WORKERS, ETHNICITY AS WELL AS BY
ZIP CODE TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
WORKERS ON PROJECTS. LASTLY A
PROJECT SPECIFIC FEDERAL ON THE
JOB TRAINING GOALS BEING SET. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CALTRANS
IS EVALUATING AND WANTS TO BUILD
UPON THEIR EXISTING POLICY TO
EXPAND MORE ON THE JOB TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES. I WANTED TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO THE UNITED STATES
EMPLOYMENT PLAN. HIGH SPEED RAIL
IS ALSO LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGIES. ONE BEING THE U. S
EMPLOYMENT PLAN. WALLET IS
VOLUNTARY. AT THIS POINT, UM,
CALTRANS. I'M SORRY. HIGH SPEED
RAIL IS USING THAT AS ONE OF ITS
MULTIPLE STRATEGIES AND
SUPPORTING JOB RETENTION AND
CREATION, WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT,
TRAINING AND OUTREACH AND LOCAL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT GOALS. AND
I'LL WRAP UP WHICH IS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE AND
COMING UP WITH THE STATEWIDE
APPROACH. SO AS WE WORK TO
ADDRESS THE GOALS OF I J.
SEVERAL CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. ONE IS JUST THE
COORDINATION, UM, LOOKING AT A
STATEWIDE POLICY AND HOW THAT
INTERACTS WITH LOCAL HIGHER
POLICIES WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS, MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS NO CONFLICT BETWEEN
THOSE REQUIREMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO WAGE RATES AS WELL AS WORKING
CONDITIONS. ADDITIONAL
MONITORING AND ENFORCEMENT
REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
AS WELL AS THOSE DATA COLLECTION
TOOLS THAT ARE REFERENCED.
INDUSTRY ALIGNMENT AND HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY CREATE THOSE
PATHWAYS TO EMPLOYMENT,
INCLUDING GOALS AND TRAINING.
LACK OF ALIGNMENT CREATES
BARRIERS TO EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE ALLOCATION OF THOSE
LIMITED RESOURCES FOR TRAINING
AND APPRENTICESHIP. AND THEN, AS
MR KIRK REFERENCED EARLIER, JUST
THAT ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
ALWAYS BECOMES CHALLENGING,
GIVEN THE DIVERSE NATURE OF
PROJECT SIZE AND TYPE, AS WELL
AS BY GEOGRAPHIC REGION, CERTAIN
LABOR STANDARDS MAY BE EASIER TO
IMPLEMENT. ENFORCE ON LONG LEAD
MEGAPROJECTS VERSUS SMALLER
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO WITH THAT, I WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. WELL I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANELISTS
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I'M GOING TO
COME OVER TO THE DIOCESE AND ASK
MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALSO WAITING WITH
US. I KNOW THIS IS LONG MEETING.
UM I WANTED TO ASK SPECIFICALLY,
YOU KNOW THE SENATORS HERE IN
THE PAST YEAR AS WELL AS
OBVIOUSLY SOME SENATORS WHO HAVE
LED THE EFFORT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS THEIR ENTIRE CAREER. TO BE
HONEST, I HAVE BEEN WORKING TOO
KIND, TOO KIND OF UPLIFT THE
WORKING COMMUNITY, RIGHT? AND WE
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE STATE IN
THE NATION, AND YET WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT HOLES WHEN WE ARE
TRYING TO CONTINUE MOVING
WORKERS FORWARD. UM. YOU KNOW,
REGARDLESS OF SB 150, WHICH YOU
GUYS HAVE PROVIDED BACKGROUND
AND SOME OF YOUR OWN SPECIFIC
EFFORTS IN YOUR DEPARTMENT AND
SO FORTH. WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE IS
THE LOWEST COMMON DENOMINATOR?
BETWEEN LABOR BUSINESSES. AND
THE WORKERS. THAT EVERYONE
AGREES ON THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. SLASH THE
ADMINISTRATION. HIGH LEVEL. I
DIDN'T JUST NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION. I'M
SORRY. THE LOWEST COMMON
DENOMINATOR BEING EVERYTHING
THAT EVERYONE AGREES ON THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY LABOR
ADMINISTRATION AND SO FORTH. I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S I WOULD
SAY AT LEAST BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK WE'VE SEEN IN THIS AND
THE 60 TO 90 PARTICIPANTS WE HAD
THERE ISN'T A COMMON EVERYONE
AGREES ON ONE APPROACH OR ONE
STANDARD, I WOULD SAY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE,
OUR PRIORITIES OBVIOUSLY WERE
ALIGNED WITH WHERE THE GOVERNOR
HAS BEEN IN THE PRIORITIES. HE
HAS SET AND EQUITY AND, UH,
IMPACT POSITIVE IMPACT TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AS A
PRIORITY, AND THAT'S HOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AS A WHOLE AND HOW
WE ARE THAT'S THE LENS THROUGH
WHICH WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
FEEDBACK WE RECEIVED FROM ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS, MY PEN. OKAY WELL, I
APPRECIATE THAT. BUT THE CONCERN
HERE IS WE'VE HAD, YOU KNOW,
YEARS OF CONVERSATION. WE KNOW
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS EVEN TODAY FROM
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. DIFFERENT
UNION EFFORT, DIFFERENT, UM,
EFFORTS ACROSS THE BOARD. AND
YOU KNOW, I KIND OF WANT TO JUST
DRILL DOWN AS TO WHAT ARE THE
MOST BASIC THINGS THAT AN
AVERAGE EMPLOYEE NOT EVEN
NECESSARILY, YOU KNOW, PROTECTED
BY LABOR AND ESTABLISHED LABOR
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE, AS I SAID
EARLIER, TESLA IN MY DISTRICT,
NOT UNIONIZED, RIGHT, SO THOSE
WORKERS THEY MATTER, RIGHT? I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE UPON THAT
RIGHT. SO WHAT CAN WE DO TO
ENSURE THAT THE EVERYDAY WORKER
REGARDLESS OF UNIONIZED OR NOT?
IN THESE INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
GETTING MILLIONS, IF NOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. HOW CAN WE
PROTECT THEM? HOW CAN WE UPLIFT
THEM? HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT
ALSO, THESE INDUSTRIES GROW WITH
THE POTENTIAL OF BEING
UNIONIZED. THAT IS THAT IS THE
QUESTION ACROSS THE BOARD. WE
CAN HAVE MILLIONS OF THESE
MEETINGS, BUT THAT IS WHAT
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW. AND I'LL
JUST CHIME IN BRIEFLY AND PLEASE
, YOU KNOW, OTHER PANELISTS CAN
SPEAK TO IT AS WELL. I MEAN, I
DO THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, KIND
OF. IT'S JUST THE BASE LEVEL A
LOT OF THE WORK THAT WE DO WITH
RESPECT TO GIS ENSURING
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE AND PEOPLE ARE
GETTING PAID THE APPROPRIATE
WAGES. THAT'S JUST KIND OF THE
BASE OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO WITH
RESPECT TO NOT ONLY CALTRANS I'M
DOING THEIR LABOR ENFORCEMENT
AND COMPLIANCE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS, EVEN
GETTING TO THINK LIKE YOUR
QUESTION ON TESLA. I THINK IT
GETS ABOUT A KIND OF COMES DOWN
TO, YOU KNOW, FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR WORKERS. WHAT ARE
THEIR NEEDS? YOU KNOW, IT IS
HARD TO COME UP WITH JUST A
BLANKET. I KNOW YOU'RE KIND OF
LOOKING FOR JUST WHAT IS THAT
BASED THING THAT EVERYONE NEEDS,
BUT I THINK IN THAT EXAMPLE THAT
YOU BROUGHT UP HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GETTING UP AT FOUR IN THE
MORNING HAVING TO TRAVEL TWO
HOURS TO WORK. IS IT SOMETHING?
WHERE IN THAT CASE REALLY THAT
TRANSPORT IS KIND OF KEY FOR
THEM, OR THE OPPORTUNITY WERE
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT WORKING. YOU
KNOW, YOU KNOW, FIVE DAYS
THEY'RE ABLE TO WORK FOR TENDS
TO MINIMIZE THAT IMPACT ON THEM.
SO I THINK FROM PROJECT TO
PROJECT COMMUNITY COMMUNITY, IT
IS GOING TO VARY A LITTLE BIT.
NOT TO SAY THAT WE CAN'T COME UP
WITH. I THINK THE ANSWER YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR, BUT I THINK IT IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME DELIBERATION
AND HOPEFULLY IN THE REPORT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO PUT
FORWARD FOR YOU ALL WILL BE ABLE
TO DRILL INTO THAT A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT LOVE FOR MY COLLEAGUES
SAID TIMING AT THE EVIDENCE
ROBOTS SO IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
KIND OF MOVING. WITH THIS IS MY
CONCERN HERE, RIGHT? SO THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU RAISED AND I
RAISED EARLIER OF POTENTIAL
EMPLOYEES BEING SEVERAL HOURS
AWAY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY BEING
BUSSED RIGHT? SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT QUALITY OF LIFE WAKING UP
AT FOUR AM, I DON'T KNOW WHO
LIKES TO DO THAT. BUT GOOD FOR
THEM, RIGHT? UM BUT WE ARE NOW
TRYING TO SAY THAT WHAT THOSE
WORKERS NEED IS TRANSPORTATION,
POTENTIALLY TO THESE JOB HUBS,
RIGHT? WHEN IN REALITY, THERE'S
PLENTY OF PEOPLE IN THE EXACT
BAY AREA RIGHT THAT NEED JOBS,
RIGHT? SO WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
MOVING TARGET RATHER THAN THE
PROBLEM AT HAND. RIGHT SO FOR ME
, IT'S TESLA NEEDS TO PAY. UM A
DECENT SALARY FOR EMPLOYEES TO
RECRUIT LOCALLY. FROM THE BAY
AREA. AND OF COURSE, IF THEY
NEED MORE WORKERS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, AND THEY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING MORE WITH THE BAY AREA
THAT YOU KNOW THAT IS MET, BUT
WE'RE LIKE WE AS POLICYMAKERS
CANNOT KEEP MOVING WITH THE BALL
ALL THE WAY TO THE BAND AID
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE THE
WORKAROUNDS THE FIXES END UP
BEING AGAIN. ABUSED. WE ARE NOT
DOING THE STANDARD OF WHAT DO WE
NEED TO HOLD THESE EMPLOYERS
RESPONSIBLE OF WHICH TO ME, AND
I'M JUST SAYING FROM LOCAL LEVEL
ON COUNCIL, THE CONCERN WAS
ALWAYS ENSURING THAT FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES HAVE HEALTHCARE. HAVE
YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF HOURS
THAT THEY HAVE TO WORK? DECENT
PAY. AND. POTENTIAL RETIREMENT
BENEFITS AND MUCH MORE. THOSE
ARE THE BASICS OF LITERALLY
EVERY SINGLE EMPLOYEE,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO BUST OR NOT. RIGHT SO
INSTEAD OF MOVING AND GIVING
THESE NICE LITTLE KIND OF
BENEFITS OF LIKE, OKAY, WE CAN
BUST YOU FOR THREE HOURS OF YOUR
DAY. WE CAN DO THIS. WE CAN
PROVIDE THESE LITTLE TINY
SERVICES. WE ARE ACTUALLY
EMPOWERING EMPLOYERS. TO KIND OF
CONTROL THE SITUATION, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN THE TECH INDUSTRY,
THEY WILL DO YOUR LAUNDRY. THEY
WILL PROVIDE CHILDCARE. THEY
WILL DO EVERYTHING SO YOU STAY
LONGER IN THE BUILDING. RIGHT?
TO WORK MORE HOURS. TRACKING
YOU. WHICH DOORS YOU OPEN THE
WHOLE NINE. SO I KIND OF WANT TO
NIP ALL OF THAT IN THE BUD AND
SAY, WHAT ARE WE DOING AS THE
LOWEST COMMON DENOMINATOR TO
PROTECT ALL WORKERS, REGARDLESS
OF THEIR INDUSTRY, REGARDLESS OF
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, DO WE HAVE
ANYTHING WITH ALL THE HOURS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS TOPIC? I
WOULD SAY THE BASELINE FOR FROM,
I WOULD SAY, PROBABLY FROM THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY PERSPECTIVE AND CRD KIND
OF, YOU KNOW, ALSO AS AN
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY, OBVIOUSLY
OUR PRIORITY IS THAT THERE ARE
HEALTHY, SAFE WORK ENVIRONMENTS
WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE PAID THE
WAGE THEIR OWN AND WE HAVE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS TO
PROTECT AGAINST WAGE THEFT AND
TO HAVE ANTI RETALIATION. SO AT
A BASELINE, THAT HEALTHY AND
SAFE WORK ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WORKERS PAID THE WAGES THEY ARE
OWED AND IN A WORKPLACE THAT IS
SAFE IS A PRIORITY WITH THAT. WE
HAVE JUST ASKING FOR A BASELINE,
RIGHT? I THINK WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS HOW DO YOU ADD
ADDITIONAL, UM LAYERS AND
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS TO TAKE
THAT A STEP ABOVE AND WE DO THAT
THROUGH, UM, FOR TRAINING
PURPOSES. YOU'VE HEARD US TALK
ABOUT OUR HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS ARE HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL WAYS TO
BRING IN A WORKFORCE THAT IS AT
A LOCAL LEVEL FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION SIDE. WE HAVE ZERO
TRAINING CONSTRUCTION CURVES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT ARE TAKING PLACE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, THAT IS A
PIPELINE TO TRY TO GET WORKERS
INTO THAT FIELD THAT HAS A
PREVAILING WAGE AND IS FAMILY
SUSTAINING IN MANY WAYS AND
PROVIDES THE BENEFITS AS YOU
DISCUSSED. WE'RE LOOKING AT
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE THAT CAN BE
APPLIED ELSEWHERE. BUT I THINK
WHAT WE'LL HEAR US SAY AND WHAT
WE HAVE SAID, IS THAT THERE
ISN'T A KIND OF ONE SIZE. FITS
FOR EVERY TYPE OF FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT HAS COME IN OR
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE
COME FROM THE FEDS SO THAT WE'RE
ALSO ADJUSTING TO WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING US TO DO AS WELL ON THE
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE PUT IN
PLACE AS WE DO THAT THAT GIVES
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHERE
ARE THE PLACES THAT WE CAN APPLY
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS FROM A
CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE FOR OUR
PRIORITIES AS WELL, WHICH MIGHT
BE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN SOME
OF OUR STATE PARTNERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. BUT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE, IT'S A THOSE ARE
THE LEVERS WE CAN COMPOSE RIGHT
SO BECAUSE WE WERE TALKING SO
BROADLY OF ALL THE INDUSTRIES
POSSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA BEING THE
FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY, LET'S
NARROW IT DOWN IF WE NARROW DOWN
TO THE TOP 10 INDUSTRIES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE 21ST,
CENTURY NUMBER ONE GROWING
INDUSTRIES, WHICH THERE'S PLENTY
OF DATA THERE, NUMBER TWO IS THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED BASELINE IN WHAT WE
SEE TODAY, SO NOT TO HIT UP
TESLA ALL THE TIME. BUT YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE THAT IS AN
INDUSTRY OR BUSINESS. THAT IS
VERY LARGE. THEY ARE SELLING
VEHICLES LEFT AND RIGHT, THEY
GET THE PERKS OF THE FEEDBACK.
UM, YOU KNOW FROM THE REBATES AS
WELL AS EVEN AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LEVEL, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A LOT OF INCENTIVES FOR
THESE PARTICULAR BUSINESSES AND
INDUSTRIES. PLUS IT IS A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR BUSINESS
THAT ONE PARTICULAR BUSINESS, SO
WHETHER WE'RE IDENTIFYING FROM
HOW MANY EMPLOYEES YOU HAVE, OR
THE DOLLAR IN PROFITS THAT
BUSINESS MAKES RIGHT WHICH ARE
MORE EASILY ABLE TO BE TRACKED,
AND NOT NECESSARILY ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BUT A BUCKET. RIGHT WE
ARE GOING. WE AND I'M JUST GOING
TO PUSH BACK BECAUSE I GET
FRUSTRATED WHEN WE USE THE FANCY
WORDS OF WE'RE FOCUSED ON EQUITY
OR FOCUSED ON THIS AND WE'RE
FOCUSED ON THIS WHEN WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE BASICS IN
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN AROUND
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE THAT HAVE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM, YOU KNOW, DEALING WITH
LAWSUITS, DISCRIMINATION AND
MUCH MORE. AND WE ARE NOT
HITTING OUR TARGETS THERE. AND
YET, WE CAN'T EVEN IN ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE A COMMON THEME OF WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM EVERYBODY,
WHICH AGAIN HEALTHCARE BASIC PAY
TO YOUR POINT, HEALTHY AND SAFE
STANDARDS. LOCALLY QUALITY OF
LIFE. YOU KNOW, I CAN NAME THEM
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD, SO I'M
HOPING THAT WHEN WE'RE HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS WE FOCUS ON
WHERE DO WE SEE AGREEMENTS
MOVING FORWARD? AND, OF COURSE,
THE CERTAIN INDUSTRIES WE CAN
ADD TO IT AS WE MOVE ALONG, SO
THAT'S MY INTENTION. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU GUYS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
D'ORSO COMMENT, UM, I DON'T MEAN
TO ANSWER THE YOUR QUESTION. UM
MY COLLEAGUE BUT THE U. C.
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER DID A
REPORT THAT WAS JUST RELEASED IN
SEPTEMBER AND HAS. ON THERE. THE
SECTORS. DO NOT HAVE LABOR
STANDARDS AS FAR AS OUR
REQUIREMENTS. AND IT'S $40
BILLION WORTH. $40 BILLION
WORTH. OF CONTRACTS OR SOME
FINANCIAL, UM, BENEFIT THAT THEY
GET FROM THE STATE FROM THE
STATE $40 BILLION. AND. THE
THOUGHT THAT ALL OF THAT WOULD
BE DONE WITHOUT LABOR STANDARDS.
BUT THEN WITHOUT LABOR STANDARDS
IS THE MOST TROUBLING OF ALL. WE
KNOW WHAT THE LARGER SECTORS ARE
RIGHT HERE. AND THAT'S WHAT IS
B. 150 WAS TRYING TO ADDRESS IS
THE FACT THAT WE ARE
FINANCIALLY. WORKING YOU KNOW,
GIVING CONTRACTS GIVING
SUBSIDIES HAVE BEEN GETTING TAX
CREDITS, BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
CONTRACTS I MEAN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. THANK GOD
BECAUSE THEY HAVE PLS WERE USED
TO DOING THAT. WE WANT THEM
THROUGH THE YEARS THERE IS LESS
OF THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A WORKFORCE
STANDARDS. JUST 2 BILLION OF
THAT, BUT MANUFACTURING WITHOUT
WORKFORCE STANDARDS 13 BILLION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE Z THE ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUILDING
APPLIANCES AND TECHNOLOGY $13
BILLION WORTH THAT DO NOT HAVE
LABOR STANDARDS. UM OPERATIONS
WITHOUT WORK FOR STANDARDS,
WATER AGENCY ENERGY PLANT
OPERATIONS, TRANSPORTATION
OPERATIONS, $13 BILLION WORTH OF
CONTRACTS THAT DO NOT HAVE LABOR
STANDARDS. NOW I APPRECIATE ALL
OF WHAT YOU UM OUR GUESTS HERE
AND LEADERS AND EXPERTS RAISED
AS FAR AS LABOR LAW. THOSE LABOR
LAWS ARE MINIMUM. WITH VERY RARE
EXCEPTIONS. THAT'S THE MINIMUM.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE MINIMUM
DOES NOT MEET THE NEEDS OF HIGH
ROAD WHAT A FAMILY NEEDS. IT
JUST DOESN'T TO YOUR TO YOUR
POINT, MADAM CHAIR AND I JUST
IT'S WE NEED TO GO BEYOND WHAT
IS THE MINIMUM WAGE. BUT IS THE
MINIMUM EIGHT HOURS? YOU KNOW,
AFTER OVER TIME, THAT JUST IS
NOT CUTTING IT. SO THE PURPOSE
OF SB 150 WAS TO LOOK AT THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER
INVESTMENTS. AND LOOK AT. HOW DO
WE CREATE FROM THAT? JOB QUALITY
. HOW DO WE CREATE FROM THAT
EQUITY AND QUALITY? UH TRAINING
AND YOU KNOW, THERE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES OF THAT, BUT WE WANT
THE SYSTEM. THE SYSTEM TO LOOK
AT ALL THOSE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND SAY, HOW CAN WE DO BETTER
FOR CALIFORNIA? AND SO I DON'T
HAVE A PARTICULAR QUESTION,
MADAM GOOD CHAIR, BUT I JUST
CARE OR CULTURE. UM BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT JUST AS A
GENERAL REMARK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR DORIS. OH AND I
WANT TO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND. GIVING US WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS A STATUS REPORT ON YOUR DEEP
LOOK AT HOW WE CREATE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR LABOR AND
EQUITY STANDARDS FOR OUR NEW
GREEN ECONOMY. AYE. UM I HAVE
MANY QUESTIONS AND MANY CONCERNS
, BUT I JUST DON'T KNOW IF YOU
ALL KNOW HOW IMPORTANT YOU ARE.
TO COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE SOUTHEAST SIDE
OF MY DISTRICT WHEN I THINK
ABOUT SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
AND SOME OF THE POOR SINCE ITS
TRACKS IN THE NATION. HOW
IMPORTANT YOU ARE TO NOT TALKING
TO ME IN THIS BODY ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE ALREADY DOING, BECAUSE WE
FEEL IT EVERY DAY ON THE GROUND
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND IT'S NOT
YOUR INTENTION THAT THESE
POLICIES BECAUSE OF HOW THEY
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED BECAUSE OF
INSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS OF GENDER
AND RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
BECAUSE OF ENFORCEMENT TOOLS
THAT HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
DISAPPEARED. IT'S NOT YOUR
FAULT. THAT WE HAVE THE
SITUATION IN OUR DISTRICT WHERE
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST ON HOUSED
POPULATION. MANY OF THEM WORKING
FULL TIME BUT CAN'T EARN ENOUGH.
AFFORD THEIR RENT. UM. YOU'RE
IMPORTANT TO THIS. YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE THAT BY NOT
DOING WHAT IS ALREADY BEEN DONE,
WHICH IS PRIMARILY WHAT I'VE
HEARD. AND IT IS NOT WORKING.
NOT JUST IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY,
BUT FROM L. A COUNTY TO TURLOCK.
BECAUSE OUR COLLEAGUES AND I
TALK ABOUT IT EVERY DAY, AND WE
ARE STRUGGLING EVERY DAY AND A
DEFICIT. BECAUSE THE PERSONAL
INCOME AND THE SALES TAX REVENUE
IS NOT COMING IN BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE IN FISCAL
CRISIS. SOUTH CENTRAL HAS BEEN
DYING ON THE VINES. SINCE THE
INDUSTRIALIZATION. WE HAVE THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL COMMERCIAL
CORRIDORS. THEY'VE BEEN TURNED
INTO POST OFFICES. SOME OF THEM
ARE SWEATSHOPS, WHERE WORKERS
ARE STRUGGLING TO HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF STANDARD AND HERE WE
ARE LOOKING AT $41 BILLION AND
INVESTMENT, AND WE ARE STILL
HEARING WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
DOING, WHICH IS NOT WORKING. I
APPRECIATE IT, MR KIRK. YOU
LISTING OUT ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE SHARED ALL THE
DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES. ALL THE
DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES THAT WE
CAN BUILD A NEW TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUES POINT, A NEW MINIMUM
STANDARD. YES. THAT PUTS
CALIFORNIA ON A PATHWAY TO WHAT
WE KNOW WE CAN BE, WHICH IS A
GOLDEN STATE WHERE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AND OPPORTUNITY
IS REAL AND REALIZE WHAT WE'RE
ALREADY DOING IS NOT PRODUCING
THAT, AND I WANT THAT TO BE
UNDERSTOOD. I RESPECT HRT PS. I
RESPECT HRT PS. HR TPS ALONE,
WILL NOT ADDRESS THE CRISIS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE DEALING
WITH EVERY DAY AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION AS WE WORK
TOGETHER. YOU ARE. YOU ARE A BIG
PART OF THE SOLUTION. AND WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE. I DON'T THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR LAST
HEARING BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE
TO GET CLOSER TO THE FIX. AND
THE FIX IS REAL LABOR STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR. AND MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SEE OUR NEXT
PANEL. SPEAKERS TO RAISE THE
STANDARD AND TO BUILD A NEW
TOOLS, WHICH THE COUNTY METRO
GAPE THAT CAN BE SCALED. AND
IT'S NOT THIS PROGRAM AND THAT
PROGRAM AND THIS PROGRAM AND
THAT PROGRAM THAT DO NOT ANY WAY
RELATE TO EACH OTHER, IN WHICH
WAY WE CANNOT FULLY MEASURE. IT
IS A WAY OF THINKING ABOUT
POLICY. TRACKING AND MONITORING
AND COLLABORATIONS THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE, AND I JUST DID NOT
HEAR IT TODAY. I DID NOT HEAR IT
AFTER FIVE OR SIX CONVERSATIONS,
AND I THINK WE HEARD FROM THE
FIRST PANEL THAT THERE WERE
ISSUES WITH THOSE HEARINGS. IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY WERE
SCHEDULED. IN TERMS OF HOW FOLKS
WERE INVITED THAT THEY WERE HELD
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HOLIDAY AND
AGAIN THAT WHAT WAS SHARED IN
TERMS OF NEW STEPS WERE NOT
INCLUDED. I WANTED TO THANK
CALTRANS AND UNDER SECRETARY
UNDERSECRETARY TOLLEFSON FOR
SHARING SOME OF THE WAYS IN
WHICH THAT LIST IS BEING
INTEGRATED AND THOSE STEPS AND I
WAS ALSO, YOU KNOW, HEARING SOME
OF THE ENFORCEMENT TOOLS THAT
YOU'RE USING TO ACTUALLY BRING
THESE WAGE THEFT CASES, AND IT'S
NOT JUST PUTTING SIGNAGE UP. IT
IS NOT JUST PULLING, PUTTING UP
SIGNAGE. YOU LAID OUT SOME TOOLS
AND PARTNERSHIPS AND ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE WORKING TO
GET US TO A POINT WHERE WE ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE COMPLIANCE
AND STANDARDS, AND WE HAVE TO DO
THAT IN OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE TOO MANY
WORKERS. TOO MANY SCHEMES AND
THIS IS TOO BIG OF AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR US TO RELY ON
SIGNAGE ALONE. WE HAVE TO BE
PROACTIVE. PROACTIVE AND HOW WE
ARE CREATING THE VALUE BASED
CONTRACTING. THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU KNOW, I
WANT TO I REALLY WANT TO HEAR.
UH, HOW YOU WILL SYNTHESIZE
TODAY'S HEARING THE FUTURE
HEARINGS, THE FUTURE DISCUSSIONS
. HOW WILL YOU SYNTHESIZE THIS
AND ALSO THE WORK THAT YOU SAID
THAT IS BEING DONE INTO A
TEMPLATE OF STANDARD THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND
AND SEE IN THIS NEW ECONOMY, IF
NOT WILL BE HERE. 40 YEARS FROM
NOW, LIKE WE'VE DONE WITH FIGHT
FOR THE 15 TRYING TO BUILD A
STANDARD INTO SERVICE. THAT
PEOPLE CAN LIVE AND SUSTAINED IN
PRIVATE. WE CANNOT AFFORD TO DO
THAT. AT THIS MOMENT THIS
MOMENT, WE CAN DO IT RIGHT NOW.
SO I WANT TO HEAR HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO SYNTHESIZES INFORMATION
. HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET TO A
STANDARD THAT WE CAN REGULATE,
RECOGNIZE AND PRODUCE REPORT
THAT SAYS 60% OF OUR FUNDS ON
THIS PROJECT WENT DIRECTLY TO
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS. THAT WE
HAD 60% OF THE WORKERS BE BLACK
ENOUGH COLOR. WOMEN THAT WE
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
BECAUSE WE CAN SEE THAT WOMEN
PARTICIPATED AT A HIGHER LEVEL
AND WE CAN MEASURE TRACK
EVALUATE AND COURSE CORRECT IN
REAL TIME. SO THAT WORKERS CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE OPPORTUNITY.
I JUST HAVE TO ASK, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO GET THERE TO RAISE THAT
MINIMUM STANDARD TO HAVE A LABOR
AND EQUITY? RUBRIC. THAT WILL
APPLY ACROSS THE BOARD, NO
MATTER WHAT THE PROJECT IS,
WHETHER IT'S IN METRO, THEY'RE
BUILDING RAILCARS. AND THEY'RE
BUILDING. TRACKS. VERY DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES. BUT THEY ARE
FIGURING OUT ONE TEMPLATE TO
TRACK MONITOR AND IMPLEMENT. SO
IF YOU COULD PLEASE SHARE WHAT
WILL BE THE NEXT STEPS FOR US.
TO UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS FOR
SYNTHESIZING AND DELIVERING WHAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS ASKED FOR,
WHICH IS A RECOMMENDATION ON HOW
WE EMBED DIRECTLY LABOR AND
EQUITY STANDARDS INTO ALL OF OUR
FEDERAL CLIMATE, RESILIENT
FUNDED PROJECTS. ON A HIGH LEVEL
. I THINK ONE THING THAT WE SAID
REPEATEDLY IN OUR STAKEHOLDER
INTERACTION WAS WE LOOK AT THIS
AS ONGOING CONVERSATIONS, RIGHT?
WE HAVE DELIVERABLES AND WE HAVE
FEEDBACK AND SUBSTANTIVE
FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED THAT
WE'RE TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
COLLECTIVELY, BUT THIS IS NOT TO
YOUR POINT. THE ONLY PLACE THIS
CONVERSATION IS NOT GOING TO END
HERE RIGHT? LIKE WE KNOW, EVEN
DURING THIS PROCESS. THE FEDS
CAME OUT WITH ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS OR GUIDANCE
SPECIFIC TO FUNDING THAT'S BEING
ROLLED OUT. THAT MIGHT CHANGE
HOW WE LOOK AT THAT. PART OF
FUNDS AGAIN. SO WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE ARE REVIEWING WHAT WE'VE
RECEIVED. WE ARE ALSO TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION. THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE IN THE HEARINGS
ARE OUR MEETINGS. WE HELD THEM
AND THEN COMING UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THIS POINT
THAT AGAIN, I THINK WE DON'T. WE
ALSO DON'T THINK THIS IS THE END
OF THE CONVERSATION. I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOMETHING. THAT ADDRESSES EVERY
QUESTION ON EVERY PROPOSAL, BUT
WE DO WANT TO HAVE A SUBSTANTIVE
PATH FORWARD THAT WE WANT TO PUT
FORWARD. SOME THAT MARK OUTLINED
FOR THE CALTRANS IS LOOKING AT A
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND ALSO, I
THINK, JUST COLLECTIVELY ACROSS
THE BOARD, THAT'S OUR INTENT, AT
LEAST AT THIS POINT. DID YOU?
I'LL JUST ADD. I THINK SO MUCH
OF THIS IS LEARNING FOR ALL OF
THE AGENCIES THAT ARE ENGAGED IN
THIS PROCESS AS WELL. AND WE
HAVE SEEN AN IMMENSE COMMITMENT
FROM ALL OF THE AGENCY STAFF
THAT ARE NAVIGATING THROUGH THE
VAST AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT INTO TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO DO WHAT? WHAT?
YOU'RE ASKING WHAT THE GOVERNOR
IS ASKING AND WHAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE ASKING AND NOT
TO REITERATE SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT UNDERSECRETARY
ROBERTS NOTED, BUT THERE'S SOME
REALLY EXCITING EXAMPLES,
PARTICULARLY IN THE ENERGY AND
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SPACED AND
NOT TOUCH ON TRANSPORTATION
AGAIN AROUND AS THE EXAMPLE OUR
APPLICATION OR $400 MILLION
APPLICATION TO THE U. S.
ENVIRONMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY. AROUND SOLAR,
RESIDENTIAL, SOLAR AND BATTERY
STORAGE. THOSE AGENCIES WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR OWN TO
IDENTIFY A MECHANISM TO PULL
FUNDING OUT OF THAT, OR OR TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING IN THAT
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT WORKFORCE
TRAINING, WHICH WE KNOW IS THAT
IS A BARRIER TO ACCESS TO THE
QUALITY JOBS THAT ARE SUPPORTED
IN THERE. UM AND TO COMMIT TO
ENGAGING WITH ALL OF US THROUGH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND REGULAR
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT NEEDS
TO BE INCLUDED IN ALL OF THESE
NEXT STEPS. ANOTHER GREAT
EXAMPLE THAT THE UNDER SECRETARY
NOTED IS AROUND ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAINING PROGRAM.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS HAS
RAISED THEIR HAND INSTEAD, WE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THIS. AND
SO THEY HAVE ENGAGED WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL, WHICH
HAS A REALLY RICH HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH LABOR AND WITH
INDUSTRY. BUSINESS PARTNERS TO
BUILD AND DESIGN CURRICULUM AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES. AND SO THERE IS A
REALLY STRONG COMMITMENT FROM
ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES THAT ARE ENGAGED IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STRIKE TEAM THAT
ARE RECEIVING OR SUPPORTING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THESE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION AND
LEARNING TOGETHER. WHAT THAT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. SO I'D
LIKE TO COMMENT, UM YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I OFTEN
SEE HERE AND YOU KNOW, I HAVE
INITIATED A LOT OF BILLS AND
THEN FIND A SPONSOR LATER RIGHT?
AND THE REASON WHY IT'S BECAUSE
I'M TRYING TO FIND THAT MIDDLE
GROUND. I LISTENED TO EVERYBODY
AND VERY REASONABLE ON THE
APPROACH. RIGHT CLEARLY, WE WANT
TO SUPPORT OUR BUSINESSES. WE
DON'T WANT TO STIFLE THEIR
GROWTH. WE DON'T WANT TO HARM
THEIR POTENTIAL. WE WANT TO
REMAIN ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD. WE KNOW
THAT WE ALL AGREE UPON. ON THAT.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT,
UM WE HAVE DIGNITY FOR WORKERS,
RIGHT? ONE OF THE TALKING
POINTS. I HAVE HEARD A LOT AND I
GET FRUSTRATED WITH IS BECAUSE
WE OFTEN SAY WE ARE THE FOURTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
RIGHT? BUT. WHAT GOOD IS IT IF
WE ARE THE FOURTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD? AND DON'T
HAVE THE BEST QUALITY OF LIFE WE
CAN HAVE FOR EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIA. AND THE REASON WHY I
GET FRUSTRATED ON YOU KNOW
PEOPLE STANDING ON THEIR
SOAPBOXES REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THEIR BACKGROUND IS RIGHT? I
DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY DOESN'T HAVE TO AGREE
WITH EACH OTHER. BUT THERE ARE
AREAS THAT WE CAN POTENTIALLY
WORK TOGETHER ON. AND MY
FRUSTRATION IS I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
HAVING THIS LONG CONVERSATION
AND KICKING THE CAN TO JUST
CONSTANTLY TALK ABOUT IT. WHEN
WE HAVE ALL THE TOOLS IN FRONT
OF US. WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. PLENTY OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT WE CAN
PARTNER WITH THAT SERVE LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS THAT SERVE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU KNOW LITERALLY ARE FOLKS
THAT WANT TO EVENTUALLY GET A
JOB. NEED THE TRAINING HAVE THE
TOOLS THERE? I MET WITH OUR CSU
PRESIDENT IN THE EAST BAY. WHO,
YOU KNOW, THE CSU EAST BAY INN
IN HAYWARD IN PARTICULAR, I
THINK ABOUT 86% OF THE STUDENTS
ARE FIRST GENERATION SLASH
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND THEY HAVE A
CAREER EMPOWERMENT CENTER THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO UTILIZE, AND
THEY'RE DESPERATE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE PARTNERSHIPS OUT
THERE, RIGHT AND WE DON'T SEE
ANY REQUIREMENT FOR BUSINESSES
TO PARTNER WITH THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOLS AND BE THAT PIPELINE
PART OF THAT PIPELINE, RIGHT
COMMUNITIES OF COLORS ALSO
STRUGGLE TO GET JOBS AFTER
GRADUATING OR LET'S BE HONEST,
NOT NOT EVERYBODY IS GOING TO
AFFORD A DEGREE, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE. SO
APPRENTICESHIPS. HOW DOES THAT
WORK? THAT SHOULD ALSO
POTENTIALLY BE THROUGH OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM, LET ALONE
PARTNERSHIPS THROUGH LABOR AND
SO FORTH. UM WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WE ARE FOCUSING ON A COUPLE OF
THESE INDUSTRIES AND AGAIN,
THESE INDUSTRIES RECEIVE
MILLIONS, IF NOT BILLIONS. AFTER
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF YEARS OF
FUNDING, BOTH FROM THE STATE AS
WELL AS THE FEDS, AND THERE ARE
NO REAL REQUIREMENTS TO SEE WHAT
THEY CAN DO SO THE EXAMPLE THAT
I GIVE IS THAT IF WE DO HAVE
FOCUS ON QUALITY OF LIFE. WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN? WHAT DOES THE
BASIC STANDARD FOR QUALITY OF
LIFE RIGHT, LET'S LET'S JUST
TALK ABOUT THAT. WHAT TYPE OF
SOCIETY ARE WE TRYING TO CREATE,
RIGHT? HOUSING COMMUNITY MEMBERS
, LETTING THEM BE ABLE TO AFFORD
RENTS. THAT ARE SKYROCKETING AND
THAT IS AN INDUSTRY THAT NEEDS
TO BE CURBED AS WELL. RIGHT AND
I OFTEN STATE THIS BECAUSE
NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE THE MOST
BASIC. IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT OF
US. WE DON'T NEED ANOTHER 20
PANELS OR STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION. WE ALL
AGREE ON THESE THINGS. AND YET
HMM. THE CONCERN AND THE FEAR IS
WE DON'T WANT TO INTRODUCE
SOMETHING THAT PUTS SOMEBODY AT
A DISADVANTAGE. BUT IF THERE ARE
RECORD PROFITS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES. WHEN DOES THE
GOVERNMENT AND POLICY MAKERS
ACTUALLY STEP IN TO PROTECT ALL
PEOPLE? RIGHT? WE BELIEVE AND MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WILL AGREE
IN, YOU KNOW, AND ADAM SMITH'S
INVISIBLE HAND THEORY, RIGHT? WE
GET THAT, BUT AS POLICYMAKERS,
OUR JOB IS TO IMPLEMENT POLICY
THAT PROVIDES SAFEGUARDS. FROM
EXCESSIVE GREED. AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE. COMMUNITIES AREN'T
LEFT BEHIND, AND I DON'T SEE
THAT AT ALL. AND LIKE, LITERALLY
, THERE WERE SEVERAL PANELS THAT
JUST HAPPENED TODAY AND THEY
WERE REPETITIVE. THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A CLEAR THIS IS WHERE WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD. NONE OF
THEM. AND THAT'S DISAPPOINTING
FOR ME TO SPEND SEVERAL HOURS
LISTENING TO THIS AND STILL HAVE
NOT SOMETHING LIKE TANGIBLE THAT
WE CAN ALL WORK ON. AND YES, THE
POLICIES THAT WE ARE PUSHING
FORWARD AND MAYBE WANT ALL OF US
HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS AS WELL.
AH MAYBE SCARY, BUT AGAIN,
FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY AND WE'RE
NOT PILOTING. WHAT CAN WE DO?
HOW CAN WE REDUCE OUR
HOMELESSNESS? HOW CAN WE ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE HOUSED? HOW CAN
WE ENSURE THAT WE HAVE BETTER
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR EVERYBODY,
AND THAT EDUCATION SYSTEM IS
CRADLE TO GRAVE. EVEN MID CAREER
PROFESSIONALS. SINGLE MOMS. HOW
CAN WE GET THEM ON BOARD? SO THE
DIGNITY OF WORKERS IT'S STILL
NOT UNDERSTOOD AS TO WHAT ARE WE
REALLY GOING TO DO? AND MAYBE
YEAR BY YEAR WE FOCUS ON ONE
INDUSTRY. MAYBE WE FOCUS ON ONE
ARENA. IT'S JUST HOUSING. AND WE
CURVE AS MUCH AS WE CAN IN
REGARDS TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
DEGREED THERE. RIGHT SO I'M A
LITTLE FRUSTRATED. I DO PLAN,
YOU KNOW, AND I'M NOT MARRIED TO
ANY POLICIES THAT WERE
INTRODUCED. I'M NOT, YOU KNOW,
SPECIFICALLY BEHOLDEN TO ONE
PARTICULAR GROUP OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. I WANT TO HAVE AN
HONEST CONVERSATION OF WHAT CAN
WE DO TOGETHER WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WERE DISCUSSED
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
HAVE SHARED THEIR OPINION? NOT
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO GET 100.
OF WHAT THEY WANTED. BUT WHAT
CAN WE DO TO WORK TOGETHER AND
MOVE FORWARD? SO THAT THAT IS
THE PART THAT I WANT TO HAVE
THAT GENUINE, HONEST
CONVERSATION AND NOT JUST
TALKING POINTS OR LIP SERVICE OR
KEEPING THE STATUS QUO, WHICH I
WILL SAY YEAR OVER YEAR JUST
SEEMS LIKE THAT. SO THAT'S MY
TWO CENTS. OKAY IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT IS THE END OF OUR
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU, PANELISTS
FOR YOUR INFORMATION, AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR NEXT
CONVERSATIONS TOGETHER. UM WE
ARE GOING TO CALL UP COLLEAGUES.
OUR FINAL PANEL OF THE EVENING.
GETTING IT DONE. GETTING IT
DONE. PANEL. WHERE DO WE GO FROM
HERE? PLEASE STEP FORWARD AND
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE. WE ARE
HAPPY. TO WE ARE HAPPY TO INVITE
SARAH FLOCKS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE AND STRATEGIC
CAMPAIGNS DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
CHRIS HANNON, PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING TRIP
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. AH TAMINA KADDOURI WITH
BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE, AND I WANTED
TO JUST MAKE NOTE THAT EVAN
MONTI WILL COULD NOT JOIN US
TODAY FROM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES BUREAU CONTRACTS
ADMINISTRATION, BUT THANK YOU,
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE AND
CLOSING US OUT ON A POSITIVE
NOTE. WE CAN GET THIS DONE. UM
SO WE WILL START WITH MISS
CHATTERING AND, UM AND THEN YOU
WALK IN MAYBE YOU GO TO THE LEFT
. SOUNDS GOOD CHECK. CAN YOU
HEAR ME? CLEARLY COLIMA? YES
BRING THEM THAT, MICHAEL. LITTLE
CLOSER. CLOSER. PERFECT OKAY,
THIS IS BETTER. OH, YEAH, THAT'S
GOOD, OK? UM GOOD EVENING, MADAM
CHAIR. SENATORS MY NAME IS
TAMINA. CHOUDHARY I'M THE
CALIFORNIA STATE POLICY MANAGER
FOR A BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE. BLUE
BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE IS A QUALITY
IN OF LABOR UNIONS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADVOCATE FOR
CLEAN TRANSITION. UM TRANSITION
TO CLEAN ECONOMY, UH, WITHOUT
LEAVING WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES
BEHIND. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
REGARDING THE CRITICAL ISSUE OF
LABOR STANDARDS IN THE CONTEXT
OF SB 150. AS WE WANT. 50
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT STEP
FORWARD IN ENSURING THAT OUR
STATES INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MANUFACTURING
AND NOT NOT ONLY CREATE JOBS BUT
HIGH QUALITY FAMILY SUSTAINING
JOBS THROUGH THE MONUMENTAL
INVESTMENT STEMMING FROM BILL
IRAN AND CHIPS ACT. THAT END,
STATE AGENCIES PLAY A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN UPLIFTING WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES BY DEVELOPING
PROGRAMMATIC. PROGRAMMATIC
REQUIREMENTS AND GUIDELINES TO
IMPLEMENT THESE LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA. AGENCIES CAN
ESTABLISH APPLICATION CRITERIA
REQUIRE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT,
WHICH IS IT STILL. IS THAT
BETTER? OKAY? UM PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT, WHICH, UM, PADDLE HIS
FRIEND SPEAKERS IN PREVIOUS
PANELS HAVE TALKED ABOUT UM,
AGENCIES CAN ESTABLISH
APPLICATION CRITERIA, WHICH ALSO
REQUIRE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
UM TO ENSURE THAT COMMUNITY
INTERESTS ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
IN LARGE DEVELOPMENT, UM, OR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS BY
REQUIRING OR INCENTIVIZING,
CIBA'S AGENCIES CAN ENSURE THAT
DEVELOPERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR PROVIDING THE BENEFITS THEY
PROMISE, AND THE COMMUNITY
GROUPS HAVE A SAY IN DEVELOPING
THIS PROCESS IS APPLICATION
CRITERIA REQUIREMENT CAN ALSO
ENSURE THERE'S UTILIZATION OF
UNION AFFILIATED TRAINING,
REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP AND
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THEY CAN ALSO ENSURE THEIR
SAFEGUARDS AGAINST WORKER
MISCLASSIFICATION. IN MY
COMMENTS TODAY, I WILL FOCUS ON
HOW STATE AGENCIES CAN DEVELOP
MECHANISMS TO ENSURE STANDARDS
ARE ADHERED TO, BECAUSE WE ALL
KNOW THAT IT'S ONE THING TO
APPLY CRITERIA AND APPLICATION.
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO ENFORCE
THEM. ONE OF THE WAYS THIS CAN
BE DONE IS THROUGH MONITORING
AND REPORTING AGENCIES CAN
DEVELOP A ROBUST FRAMEWORK FOR
ONGOING MONITORING AND REPORTING
OF WORKFORCE STANDARDS.
COMPLIANCE. FOR THEIR FUNDED
PROJECTS. THIS FRAMEWORK COULD
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT IN LABOR
PRACTICES. SOME OF THESE
MECHANISMS MAY INCLUDE REGULAR
COMPLIANCE AUDITS. THEY CAN
CONDUCT PURITY. AUDITS OF
PROJECTS TO ASSESS ADHERENCE TO
LABOR STANDARDS. THEY CAN SET UP
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK LOOPS, FOR
EXAMPLE, CREATE CHANNELS FOR
WORKERS AND STAKEHOLDERS DO
REPORT CONCERNS AND PROVIDE
FEEDBACK ON LABOR PRACTICES.
THEY CAN ESTABLISH CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS REQUIRING PROJECTS
WITH DEFICIENCIES TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLANS. THEY CAN ALSO ESTABLISHED
PERFORMANCE. BENCHMARK BENCHMARK
AND SAID CLEAR LABOR COMPLIANCE
BENCHMARKS FOR PROJECTS AND
TRACK PROGRESS OVER TIME. AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS GOLD. NO GO
DECISION POINTS, WHICH ARE ALSO
INCLUDED IN THE JOBS INITIATIVE
QUALITY CHECKLIST PUBLISHED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. AND
JOBS AND GOOD JOBS IN FEDERAL
INVESTMENT TOOLKIT. UH, STEP
PUBLISHED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AND LABOR. I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT I MEAN BY GO AND
NO, GO DECISION POINTS. UM FOR
INSTANCE, UM, IF AN AGENCY IS TO
DEPLOY THREE PHASE PROJECT GO,
NO GO DECISION POINT IN PHASE
ONE. IT WILL REQUIRE. FOR
INSTANCE, WE TAKE PLS AN EXAMPLE
. IT WILL REQUIRE P L. A TO
ENSURE THAT LÀ ESTABLISHED THAT
COVERS ALL ASPECTS OF LABOR
MANAGEMENT WAGES, WORKING
CONDITION, DISPUTE RESOLUTION
AND SAFETY STANDARDS FOR THE
PROJECT. IN PHASE TWO
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEARLY AS
INTENDED WILL BE ENSURED, UM, SO
THE AGENCY WILL COLLECT EVIDENCE
THAT ALL CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS ARE COMPLYING
WITH THE TERMS OF THE P L. A. IT
COULD ALSO REQUIRE THE EMPLOYER
TO SET UP MONITORING AND
REPORTING SYSTEM. ESTABLISH
TRANSPARENT MONITORING SYSTEM TO
TRACK LABOR, COMPLIANCE, SAFETY
AND STUDENTS, ETCETERA. THIS IS
THIS IS A NO GO IF BY THIS TIME
A CLEAR MONITORING AND
EVALUATION SYSTEM HAS NOT BEEN
DEVELOPED BY THE EMPLOYER IF YOU
GRADUATES INTO PHASE THREE
AGENCY CAN REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE COMPLIANCE EVALUATION.
THAT IS A PROOF OF ONGOING
ADHERENCE TO LABOR AGREEMENT IN
SAFETY STANDARDS. COMPARABLE
MODEL IN CALIFORNIA. UM BUT NOT
APPLE TO APPLE IS THE, UM
CALIFORNIA COMPETE. STATE COOKS.
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDITS,
WHICH ALSO KNOWN AS C. C T C
PROGRAM, WHICH IS ADMINISTERED
BY THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. THE
C C T. C IS C C T. C IS DESIGNED
TO ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES TO
EITHER COME TO CALIFORNIA OR
STAY AND GROW WITHIN THE STATE.
THE PROGRAM ENSURES THAT
BUSINESSES ADHERED TO THEIR
COMMITMENT TO YEARLY MILESTONES
THROUGH A STRUCTURED PROCESS IN
STAGES. STAGE ONE IS AGREEMENT
AND COMMITMENT. BUSINESSES ENTER
INTO A FIVE YEAR AGREEMENT WITH
THE C C T. C AS PART OF THIS
AGREEMENT THEY COMMIT TO MEETING
SPECIFIC YEARLY MILESTONES
RELATED TO FULL TERM EMPLOYMENT
THAT IS CREATING JOBS, SALARY
LEVELS THAT IS ENSURING
COMPETITIVE COMPENSATION.
PROJECT INVESTMENT INVESTING IN
GROWTH. IN STAGE TWO IS CLAIMING
THE CREDIT. EARN THE ALLOCATED
CREDIT FOR A GIVEN YEAR.
BUSINESSES MUST MEET THE
MILESTONES DURING THE TAXABLE
YEAR. IN STAGE THREE IS REVIEW
PROCESS BY F. T B. THE FINANCE
FRANCHISE. TEXT BOARD REVIEWS
TAXPAYER RECORDS TO VERIFY
COMPLIANCE WITH CREDIT AGREEMENT
THE REVIEW FOCUSES ON VERIFYING
THAT YEARLY MILESTONES MENTIONED
EARLIER. IT IS NOT A TAX AUDIT,
BUT ACCURATE RECORDS ARE
ESSENTIAL. STAGE FOUR IS THE
REVIEW OUTCOME. AFTER THE REVIEW
F T B INFORMS THAT BUSINESS
WHETHER IT IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE CREDIT AGREEMENT IF IT'S IF
THERE'S A POSSIBLE BREACH IF TV
PROVIDES INFORMATION, EXPLAINING
THE BASIS OF THEIR DETERMINATION
, MISS CHOWDER IS GONNA ASK YOU
TO WRAP YES. SEVEN MINUTES IN
THE LAST POINT AND IN STAGE FIVE
IS VERIFICATION AREAS, THE FDP
VERIFIES. UM EMPLOYMENT AND
COMPENSATION LEVELS THAT IS
PAYROLL RECORDS, HIGHER DATES,
WAGES, ETCETERA AND PROJECT
INVESTMENT. UM IN CONCLUSION, UH
, AS MANY SPEAKERS HAVE SAID
THIS BEFORE ME. IT'S ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY FOR A STATE
TO DESIGN AN INCLUSIVE SYSTEM
THAT IS INTENTIONAL ABOUT
ADVANCING THE WELFARE OF ITS
WORKER. UM AND I THINK, UM AH,
IT HAS A LOT OF POTENTIAL AS WE
WON 50. IT'S REALLY UP TO US TO
ACTUALLY APPLY THOSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MR HANNAN. THANK
THANK YOU. HONORABLE CHAIR. UH
CO CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UH,
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIA EXCITED AND
HONORED TO BE HERE. YOU KNOW, TO
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF, UM AND
ALSO RESPECTFUL AND GIVE TIME
FOR COMMENTS. I'M GOING TO TRY
TO KEEP IT PRETTY SIMPLE. THE
POLICY THAT WE NEED AH, FROM
GOVERNMENT. FOR CONSTRUCTION. WE
NEED PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS.
AH ANY TIME THAT WE HAVE PUBLIC
FUNDS OR WE'RE DOING THE
CONSTRUCTION BY THE PUBLIC
AGENCY IF WE'RE GIVING THINGS
LIKE TAX BREAKS TAX INCENTIVES.
AND THERE'S NOT A DIRECT PUBLIC
FUND. WE NEED A COME UP WITH
BENCHMARKS AND DELIVERABLES FOR
TRAINING AND APPRENTICESHIP
COMPLETION, SUCH AS A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE AND FOR
JOBS BEYOND CONSTRUCTION, AND WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT EVERY
ONE OF THESE JOBS, WHETHER THEY
BE IN MANUFACTURING SERVICE,
PUBLIC SECTOR OR EVEN OUT OUR
LOCAL GROCERY STORE. WE NEED
LABOR PEACE. TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE AN EQUITABLE
STAKE. WE HAVE TO HAVE LOCAL AND
NOT JUST LOCAL, BUT TARGETED
HIRING GOALS. ON THE BUILDING
TRADES AGREEMENTS LIKE THE L. A
METRO AGREEMENT, FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS
STARTED OUT AS A FIVE YEAR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT THAT
TOOK A TON OF INPUT, UH FROM THE
COMMUNITY FROM THE AGENCY
NEGOTIATED WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES. BACK AND FORTH A TON OF
ENGAGEMENT. IT WAS A FIVE YEAR
AGREEMENT. THAT AGREEMENT HAS
SINCE BEEN RENEWED FOR ANOTHER
10 YEARS BECAUSE IT'S WORKING
BECAUSE WE'RE EXCEEDING ALL OF
OUR LOCAL AND ALL OF OUR
TARGETED HIGHER GOALS. THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO HAVE
GOALS AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
MEET AND EXCEED THOSE GOALS.
EQUITY OR OR QUALITY. THIS HAS
TO BE THROUGH UNION MEMBERSHIP.
ONE OF THE STATS. I HEARD A
PREVIOUS SPEAKER TALKING ABOUT
WERE. INDIVIDUALS HAVE COLOR,
NOT RECEIVING THE SAME WAGES.
LATINO AND BLACK. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVING
OVERREPRESENTATION IN LOW WAGE
JOBS OR IN THE LOWER WAGE JOBS
THROUGH UNION MEMBERSHIP.
WORKERS HAVE TO HAVE A SAY IN
THAT WORKERS NEED UNION
MEMBERSHIP AND IN OUR TRADES
UNION JOURNEY PERSON GETS THE
PAY THE SAME REGARDLESS OF
GENDER, REGARDLESS OF RACE,
REGARDLESS OF ETHNICITY, THEY
GET PAID THE SAME FIRST LEVEL
APPRENTICE GETS PAID WHAT A
FIRST LEVEL OF APPRENTICE GETS
PAID. A SECOND LEVEL GETS PAID
WHAT A SECOND LEVEL GETS PAID
REGARDLESS OF WHAT GENDER
REGARDLESS OF WHO YOU KNEW. WHO
DIDN'T KNOW, BUT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A UNION CARD. AND IT HAS TO
BE FOR A CAREER. YOU CAN'T DO IT
FOR ONE JOB. WE CAN'T HAVE A
PREVAILING WAGE JOB AND
PREVAILING WAGE. BE THE
PREVAILING WAGE AND YOU, YOU GET
IT FOR TWO WEEKS, TWO MONTHS OR
NINE MONTHS. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THAT FOR A CAREER AND THE ONLY
WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO
THAT CAREER IS FOR US TO GET THE
WORD OUT. IT SHOULD BE IN
SCHOOLS. EVERY LOCAL SCHOOL
SHOULD TALK ABOUT IT. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MENTIONED BEFORE IT SHOULD BE IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IT SHOULD
ALSO BE WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. EVERYWHERE WHERE
PEOPLE GATHER. WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT GOOD JOBS WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT, ALTHOUGH ALL THE OPTIONS
NOT JUST COLLEGE, NOT JUST, UM
NOT JUST, UM OPTIONS FOR A
SELECT FEW. IT HAS TO BE REAL
OPTIONS FOR EVERYBODY, AND IT
HAS TO BE CLEAR. WE CAN'T BE
UNCLEAR WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IT
HAS TO BE, UH, FROM THE WORKERS
THAT HAS TO BE THROUGH A UNION.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A UNION CARD.
YOU CAN'T TALK UP. YOU KNOW, I
HEARD, UH, YOU KNOW SOME NON
UNION EMPLOYERS. ALL OF THOSE
WORKERS ARE IMPORTANT, BUT WHEN
THEY SPEAK UP AND THEY'RE
TERMINATED, THEY NEED A UNION TO
BE ABLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
AND I KNOW THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHERE FORTUNATE FOR
A LOT OF THINGS, BUT THERE'S FAR
TOO MANY PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO FAR TOO MANY THINGS.
IT'S NOT JUST A GOOD CAREER AND
A GOOD WAGE. IT'S NOT JUST
HOUSING. IT'S NOT JUST HEALTH
CARE. IT'S NOT JUST ANY ONE
THING. PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AH.
ARE LACKING ACCESS TO TOO FAR
TOO MANY THINGS AND FAR TOO MANY
OF THOSE THINGS CAN BE FIXED
THROUGH A UNION JOB. WE CAN'T
HAVE UNION JOBS IF PEOPLE AREN'T
EMPOWERED IF THEY DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THEM IF THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GET IN THEM, SO I'M GONNA
PAUSE MY COMMENTS. WE CAN TALK
ABOUT DIFFERENT WAYS TO UM YOU
DON'T EMPOWER PEOPLE TO GO AFTER
A CAREER IN THE TRADES, WE CAN
TALK ABOUT HOW TO UNIONIZE IN
THE WORKPLACE, BUT I'M GOING TO
STOP RIGHT HERE AND YOU KNOW,
AND HALF TIME FOR QUESTIONS.
SORRY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MADAM COACH, CAN YOU HEAR ME? OK
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. SARAH
FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION, AND I JUST WANT TO
START BY THANKING YOU ALL FOR
STARTING THIS PROCESS FOR MOVING
SB 150 FOR HAVING THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE THE YEARS AND
DECADES BEFORE THIS TO ENSURE
THAT PUBLIC DOLLARS CREATE GOOD
UNION JOBS WITH EQUITABLE
ACCESS. UM AND I HAVE. I'M
ACTUALLY VERY LUCKY BECAUSE I'M
THE LAST SPEAKER, SO I DON'T
HAVE TO BREAK ANY NEW GROUND. I
GET A REALLY SUMMARIZE A LOT OF
THE MODELS THAT ARE ALREADY OUT
THERE AND A LOT OF THE
INCREDIBLE WORK OF GROUPS AND
UNIONS AND THE TRADES THAT HAVE
ALREADY HAPPENED AND ARE ALREADY
HAPPENING AND THESE ARE LESSONS
THAT WE CAN TAKE AND REALLY MOVE
FORWARD WITH SO THAT WE ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS MOMENT.
SO ONE. WE DO HAVE MODELS. WE
HAVE THE ARCHES COMMUNITY
BENEFIT AGREEMENT. WE HAVE THE
U. S EMPLOYMENT PLAN WHICH JOBS
TO MOVE AMERICA INNOVATED. WE
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY,
WHICH HAS AN INCREDIBLE
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLAN
REQUIREMENT. 20% OF SCORES FOR
COMPANIES THAT ARE APPLYING FOR
THOSE FUNDING. AND WE HAVE POWER
IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND WE HAVE OUR ROLE
AS A MARKET PARTICIPANT IN
PROCUREMENT IN FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT ARE FOR PROCUREMENT, BUT
FOR STATE DOLLARS TO FOR ALL THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE'RE GOING TO
BUY FOR ALL THE BATTERY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THERE SHOULD BE
LABOR STANDARDS ON ALL OF THE
PUBLIC FUNDING THAT IS GOING OUT
FOR THE CREATION OF JOBS. UM AND
SO. AND THE OTHER THING IS IN
TERMS OF FLEXIBILITY AND SENATOR
COURT EASY HAD THIS QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO IN THE
STATE TO PUT THESE STANDARDS ON
ON FEDERAL DOLLARS OR STATE
DOLLARS, AND MADELINE JANIS
MENTIONED THAT THIS THE OFFICE
OF MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET IS
COMING OUT WITH NEW RULES AROUND
THE UNIFORM GUIDANCE, AND THIS
IS WHAT IS GOING TO OPEN UP THE
ABILITY OF THE STATES TO PUT
MORE STANDARDS ON FEDERAL
DOLLARS. THE LEGACY HAS BEEN
THAT THE OLD GUIDANCE THIS WAS
UNDER THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS VERY RESTRICTIVE. IT
DIDN'T DO IT. LET ALLOW US TO DO
A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO DO THAT IS GOING TO
CHANGE AS THESE NEW RULES COME
OUT. SO I'M GOING TO GO INTO
SOME OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN
TERMS OF LABOR STANDARDS, BUT MY
FIRST RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE IS
THAT WE TAKE SOME OF THESE TOOLS
THAT HAVE SOME OF THESE
STANDARDS. WE DEFINE THEM, AND
WE CODIFY THEM ONE OF THE
AMAZING THINGS THAT THE BUILDING
TRADES HAVE DONE IS THAT THEY
HAVE THESE TOOLS, PREVAILING
WAGE PROJECT, LABOR AGREEMENTS,
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
AND WE CAN SEE AND PUT ON
PROJECTS. WE NEED THAT
EQUIVALENT FOR MANUFACTURING
OPERATIONS IN SERVICE. AND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP THAT PUT
INTO STATUTE SO WE CAN PICK IT
UP AND PUT IT TO THE DIFFERENT
FUNDING THE FUNDING THAT EXISTS
IN THE FUNDING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IN THE FUTURE. SO I'M
JUST GOING TO GO INTO ONE TOOL
AND KIND OF WALK THROUGH HOW YOU
COULD USE THIS TOOL TO PUT
STANDARDS IN IT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY. THEY
REQUIRE COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS.
20% 20% IS THE SCORE. AND WHAT A
COMPANY HAS TO DO. NUMBER ONE.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE SPECIFIC,
MEASURABLE AND ACHIEVABLE GOALS
IN THEIR OBJECTIVES SO THAT YOU
CAN SEE THEM AND YOU CAN SCORE
ON THEM AND HAVE COMPLIANCE. THE
OTHER THING THEY DO IS THEY
REQUIRE LABOR AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. COMPANIES HAVE TO
PLAN HOW THEY'RE GOING TO ENGAGE
WITH LABOR AND COMMUNITY. THIS
IS ACTUALLY ANECDOTALLY WE KNOW
RESULTED IN COMPANIES REACHING
OUT TO LABOR AND COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS. BECAUSE THERE IS
THAT REQUIREMENT. WE'VE SEEN
THIS WITH THE CHIPS ACT FUNDING
THROUGH CALIFORNIA COMPETES.
THEN YOU START TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. YOU START TO HAVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AS A
PROJECT IS DEVELOPING FROM THE
BEGINNING. THE OTHER THING THAT
YOU CAN SEE IN, UM IN THESE
PLANS IS THE WORKFORCE STANDARD
SIDE OF COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET UNION
JOBS. BECAUSE THERE IS NO
REPLACEMENT FOR A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT AND
LEGISLATION IS NOT GOING TO
ORGANIZE WORKERS, BUT WE CAN
CREATE THAT ENVIRONMENT FOR THIS
TO HAPPEN. THERE COULD BE
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS. REQUIREMENTS FOR
LABOR. PEACE FOR NEUTRALITY FOR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
OR FOR THE COMMITMENT FOR
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO FREELY AND
FAIRLY FORM A UNION. QUALITY JOB
STANDARDS. WHAT ARE THE METRICS
THAT WE WANT TO SET FOR? WHAT
ARE THE WAGES? WHAT ARE THE
BENEFITS LEVELS? WHAT ARE THE
OTHER STANDARDS THAT WE WANT TO
PUT IN THERE TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE RETENTION AND ADVANCEMENT
AND GOOD SECURE JOBS? AND THEN
ALSO WORKFORCE EQUITY STANDARDS.
WHAT ARE THE SPECIFIC,
MEASURABLE AND ACHIEVABLE GOALS
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO SET TO
HIRE, RECRUIT AND ADVANCE
WORKERS FROM MARGINALIZED AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OR
UNDERREPRESENTED WORKERS. OR
HOWEVER, WE WANT TO DEFINE THEM
IN THE CODE. UM AND THE COMPANY
HAS TO ONE SHOW. THEY'RE GOING
TO MEET THOSE METRICS. AND MAYBE
THEY DEVELOP A PLAN THAT THEY
SHOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PARTNERING WITH LABOR AND
COMMUNITY TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS
AND THAT CAN BE SCORED ON WE CAN
MAKE THIS SO IT ACTUALLY MATTERS
. AND THEN THE OTHER THING IS
JUSTICE 40 JUSTICE 40 INITIATIVE
. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
SAID 40% OF THE BENEFITS OF
THESE FEDERALLY FUNDED PROJECTS
HAVE TO FLOW TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. HOW IS
CALIFORNIA GET TO DEFINE THAT?
HOW ARE WE GOING TO SAY? YES
JUSTICE 40 SHOULD BE PART OF IT.
AND HOW ARE YOU COMPANY GOING TO
SHOW THAT THAT HAPPENS? UM AND
THEN ALSO TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SENATOR
YOU'VE SAID THIS OVER AND OVER.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET SEE THAT
THESE COMPANIES ARE MEETING
THESE STANDARDS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS SOME KIND OF
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE THAT
NEEDS TO BE BUILT IN ONE OF THE
REALLY GOOD WAYS TO DO THIS IS
TO MAKE ALL OF THIS PUBLIC MAKE
THESE COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC HAVE PRE
AWARD DISCLOSURE. SO IF THEY
DON'T HAVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
COMMUNITY, THEY CAN FIND A
COMMUNITY PARTNER. HOPEFULLY A
UNION UM AND ALSO MAKE THIS PART
OF THE CONTRACT SO IT'S NOT JUST
A PLAN. IT'S A PLAN THAT IS PART
OF THE CONTRACT FOR YOU TO GET
THIS FUNDING. UM AND THEN ALSO,
WE NEED TO HAVE SUPPORT FOR
AGENCIES. NOT EVERY AGENCY KNOWS
HOW TO DO THESE THINGS. WE HAVE
TO HAVE STATE SUPPORT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE, AND THEN
WE ALSO NEED TO SHOW GOOD
COMPANIES THAT MEET THESE
STANDARDS. LIKE THE AKASH
SEMICONDUCTORS THAT HAS PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS WITH BOTH LABOR
IN THE TRADES AND CW, A SPARKS
THAT HAS NEUTRALITY AGREEMENT
WITH THE W B Y D THAT HAS HAS
HAD INCREDIBLE PARTNERSHIPS. HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE
IS SUPPORTING THEM AND DIRECTING
RESOURCES IN KIND OF WRAP AROUND
SERVICES TO THEM SO THAT WE CAN
GROW GOOD COMPANIES AND GROW
INDUSTRIES DURING THE RECESSION?
UM, A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE LIKE WE
NEED TO CUT RED TAPE. WE NEED TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR COMPANIES TO
COME HERE. THERE'S TOO MANY
REGULATIONS. NO THE REGULATIONS
ARE THE BASELINE THAT MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE FOURTH LARGEST
ECONOMY WITH GOOD ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS RATHER THAN CUTTING
RED TAPE. LET'S ROLL OUT THE RED
CARPET. LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT
ARE THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE THE GOOD COMPANIES
THAT MEET THE HIGHEST STANDARDS
ARE ABLE TO GROW AND EXPAND OR
ARE INCUMBENT COMPANIES I KNOW,
GILLICK TESTIFIED AT A RECENT
HEARING ABOUT WANTING TO EXPAND.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
INCUBATING A HIGH ROAD ECONOMY,
A NEW AND EMERGING ECONOMY THAT
BENEFITS THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN THE MOST LEFT BEHIND
AND IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO I'LL JUST END THERE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL
BRING IT TO OUR SENATORS. DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SANDRA ALLEN. I WILL THANK YOU
FOR THAT INFORMATION AND FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
FOR THE STATE TO CONSIDER, AND I
, WE ARE, UM IT IS OUR BENEFIT
TO HAVE PARTNERSHIPS TO HELP US
THINK THESE VERY COMPLEX STEPS
THROUGH. I WONDERED IF YOU COULD
. AND MAYBE THIS IS SOMETHING
ALL OF THE PANELISTS, BUT I'LL
START WITH YOU. MS FLAX. HOW
WOULD YOU ADVISE WE DIRECT
SENATORS. DIRECT AGENCIES TO
ENSURE LABOR AND EQUITY
STANDARDS ARE IN PLACE AND
ENFORCED. YOU HEARD THE PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION AND WE STILL ARE
FOCUSING ON WHAT IN SOME WAYS ON
THE THINGS WE'RE ALREADY DOING.
HOW WOULD YOU ADVISE THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING THE MOMENT AND
SINCE WE'VE ALREADY LET OUT 7
BILLION DOLLARS WITHOUT ANYTHING
. HOW DO WE ADVISE? HOW WOULD
YOU ADVISE THE AGE OR DIRECT
ADVISE US TO DIRECT THESE
AGENCIES TO MEET THE MOMENT?
WELL, I THINK YOU'RE DOING IT.
UM SP 150 PROCESS IS GREAT. I
KNOW. A NUMBER OF SENATORS HAVE
INCREDIBLE BILLS THAT HAVE
STANDARDS IN THEM. I DO THINK UM
, THERE IS SOMETHING TO BE SAID
ABOUT DEFINING AND CODIFYING
SOME OF THESE STANDARDS SO THAT
THEY ARE VERY CLEAR AND APPLY TO
SPECIFIC PARTS OF MONEY. THERE'S
SOMETHING TO BE SAID FOR NOT
HAVING A ONE SIZE FITS FITS ALL
APPROACH. BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
STANDARDS AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE
CRITERIA AND I THINK PUTTING IN
HERE'S WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE ON
THESE PARTS OF MONEY. THESE ARE
THE STANDARDS THAT WE AGREE ON.
THIS IS WHAT IS IN THE STATUTE.
WE CAN GET YOU SOME SUPPORT TO
BE ABLE TO, AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THAT
LEVEL OF EXPERTISE AND SUPPORT
WHETHER IT'S COMING FROM LABOR
AGENCY OR WHATEVER IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. UM AND THEN IT REALLY
IT HAS TO BE VALUED. IT HAS TO
BE SCORED AT A LEVEL WHERE LABOR
IS EQUIVALENT. TO I DON'T KNOW
ANY OTHER TECHNICAL PART THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE LOWEST
RESPONSIBLE, BITTER, BUT WE HAVE
THINGS LIKE BEST VALUE.
PROCUREMENT UM, WHERE THESE
LABOR STANDARDS AND EQUITY
STANDARDS ARE WAITED AND TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT. THEY ARE PART OF
CONTRACTS. THEY ARE SOMETHING
THAT ARE ENFORCED ON THAT IF
THERE'S ANY KIND OF CLAWBACK OR
RECAPTURE THAT IT CAN BE ON THE
BASIS OF NONCOMPLIANCE WITH THAT
, UM AND THEN I THINK YOU FIGURE
OUT HOW YOU DO THAT DATA
SUBMISSION AND TRANSPARENCY, BUT
TRANSPARENT PROCESSES ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY IF
YOU WANT TO ALSO HAVE SOME PRE
AWARD. UM SO THAT THERE AREN'T
BAD ACTORS OR COMPANIES WHERE
THERE'S PROBLEMS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN IDENTIFIED, SO THERE'S THAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITY INPUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S YOU
KNOW, THAT'S NOT THE DEAL IS NOT
INKED. YES THANK YOU. I AGREE
WITH SARAH. I THINK YOU KNOW, WE
DO NEED TO CODIFY SOME OF THESE
THINGS. WE KNOW WHAT BEST
PRACTICES ARE, YOU KNOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, ARCHES. THERE WAS A
QUESTION BY, UM BY ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EARLIER. YOU
KNOW, WE WANT TO CAPTURE AS MANY
OF THESE FUNDS COMING TO US. AND
WE DON'T WANT TO BE
UNCOMPETITIVE ON ARCHES. IT'S
THE LARGEST HYDRATED IT TIED FOR
THE LARGEST AWARD FOR HYDROGEN
HUB IN THE COUNTRY AND TIED WITH
TEXAS FOR $1.2 BILLION INTEND TO
AWARD IT HAS A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT ON EVERY SINGLE
PROJECT REGARDLESS OF SIZE.
EVERY SINGLE PROJECT HAS A, UM A
WITH LOCAL HIGHER ALSO. THEY
ALSO HAVE LABOR PEACE. AND WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LABOR PEACE
JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE WANT
NEUTRALITY. WE WANT VOLUNTARY
RECOGNITION. AND WE WANT A
PATHWAY TO A CONTRACT. WE DON'T
WANT NINE YEARS OF GOING BACK
AND FORTH, NOT GETTING TO A
CONTRACT, AND WHEN WE GET A
CONTRACT, WE WANT FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES. WE WANT HEALTH
CARE, QUALITY HEALTH CARE, AND
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
RETIRE IN CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW,
WE PARTNERED WITH AND ON TOP OF
THAT 1% OF THE TOTAL. BUDGET IS
GOING INTO COMMUNITY BENEFITS.
AND IT'S NOT SET WHAT THOSE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS ARE BECAUSE
THERE'S DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT
NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE. IF
YOU'RE IN A RURAL AREA OF THE
STATE, MAYBE, UH, YOU KNOW TO
ARE THE MOST NORTHERN PARTS. YOU
KNOW THE NEEDS OF THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE GREAT THE
NEEDS OF DISPLACED INDUSTRIES
LIKE LOGGING AND FISHING.
THEY'RE STILL FISHING, BUT BUT
THOSE ARE OUR PRESSURE POINTS.
IF YOU GO INTO OUR METROPOLITAN
AREAS IN OUR URBAN AREAS, THEY
HAVE DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT
NEEDS THAN OUR SUBURBAN AREAS,
SO THOSE COMMUNITY BENEFITS THAT
ARE PART OF EVERY PROJECT. AND
REMEMBER AS A $1.2 BILLION
AWARD. THERE'S 10 TIMES THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN PRIVATE
FUNDING. ONE OF THE REASONS FOR
THAT IS A BEST PRACTICE IN THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, WHERE
IF COMPANIES TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT TAX CREDIT, THEY GET A FIVE
TIMES BUMP TO PAY. DAVIS BACON
OR PREVAILING WAGES AND HIGHER
APPRENTICESHIP UTILIZATION. YOU
CAN USE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS
TO ACCOMPLISH THE PAYMENT OF
THOSE WAGES AND THE UTILIZATION
OF APPRENTICES AT THAT LEVEL.
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE CODIFYING. THERE WAS
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR PROJECTS
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
GOING TO CONSTRUCT OF $35
MILLION OR MORE TO HAVE A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT. WE
SHOULD BE DOING THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. THE UC SYSTEM KNOWS
THAT THAT WORKS. WE PARTNERED
TOGETHER ON IT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS A PARTNER IN
ARCHES. THEY KNOW THAT IT WORKS.
WE KNOW THAT IT WORKS. WE SHOULD
CODIFY IT ACROSS. YOU KNOW,
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT AREAS. WE
SHOULD PARTNER TOGETHER. WE
SHOULD GO AFTER THINGS LIKE
MANUFACTURING TOGETHER. WE
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION TOGETHER
MORE OFTEN, WE SHOULD DO THESE
THINGS MORE OFTEN. I THINK IT
MAKES US MORE COMPETITIVE, SO WE
HAVE THE BEST PRACTICES ON
HOUSING. WE HAVE ONE OF THE
LARGEST HOUSING MEASURES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. NOW IN, UH,
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THAT
HAS A PROJECT LABOR GROUP FOR
SOME PROJECTS, AND THEN HAS NO
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT FOR
SMALLER PROJECTS. THE PEOPLE I
PROJECTS CAME BACK CHEAPER PER
UNIT AND WE EXCEEDED OUR LOCAL
HIGHER GOALS ARE APPRENTICESHIP
UTILIZATION GOALS ARE LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIP GOALS AND ARE
TARGETED WORKER GOALS AND YOU
CAN LOOK AT THE DASHBOARD TODAY.
IT'S UPDATED REAL TIME. WHAT
THOSE MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF
HOURS WORKED IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND THE AND THE
THAT'S THE BEST PRACTICE. LET'S
LOOK AT THAT ACROSS MORE ASPECTS
, AND WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THAT
A UNION CARD AND WORKER
INVOLVEMENT AND WORKERS HAVING A
VOICE. THEY'RE GOING TO TELL US
WHAT WE NEED. YOU CAN SEE IN OUR
OUR SISTERS AND BROTHERS IN THE
IN THEIR STAND UP CAMPAIGN.
THEY'RE NOT SHY. WHEN THEY HAVE
A UNION CARD, THEY CAN STAND UP.
WELL, LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE UNION REPRESENTATION AND
MORE AREAS AND I THINK THE BEST
WAY TO DO THAT IN MANUFACTURING
WHEN WE'RE GIVEN WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
BUSINESSES HERE. WE NEED LABOR
PEACE AND ALLOW IF ASKED TO COME
UP WITH WHAT LABOR PIECES AND
WHEN THE WORKERS AREN'T
SATISFIED THAT THERE'S LABOR
PEACE. THERE IS NOT LABOR PEACE.
WORKERS HAVE TO HAVE
SATISFACTION IN THAT AND THEY'LL
TELL US WHEN THAT WHEN THAT
COMES, SO I 100% AGREE WITH SO
MANY THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID,
BUT WE HAVE TO CODIFY THEM. THIS
THIS COMMITTEE IS GREAT. MAYBE
THE TOOLKIT THAT COMES OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE. MAYBE, AND, UH
PORTION OF ONE OF OUR AGENCIES
LIKE WHERE WE DO THOSE THOSE
GREAT HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. MAYBE THAT'S AN
ENVELOPE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
THOSE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS THAT LEAD TO UNION
JOBS, SO THAT MAYBE THAT SHOULD
BE IN THE TOOLKIT COMING OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE. HOW FOR GENERAL
SERVICES TO FIGURE OUT THAT.
HEY, WE DON'T NEED A PHASE IN ON
THIS STUFF. WE NEED TO GET IT
GOING NOW BECAUSE THE LONGER
THAT WE WAIT THE LONGER THOSE
NEEDS AND THOSE UNMET NEEDS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW. SO
WHETHER IT BE GENERAL SERVICES,
WHETHER IT BE ON THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL FOR PROCUREMENT, YOU KNOW,
WE SHOULD HAVE COMPANIES THAT
ARE COMPETING AND EMBRACING
LABOR, PEACE AND BRACING WORKER
VOICE AND THEY SHOULD BE
COMPETING. THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
LINE IS GOING TO SPUR MULTIPLE
HIGH SPEED RAIL LINES, ALL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, AND WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING THING THAT THAT
HAPPENED WITH THE BRIGHT LINE
WITH THE COMING HIGH DESERT
CORRIDOR, AND THEY'RE GETTING
FEDERAL INVESTMENT AND IT'S
MAKING US MORE COMPETITIVE.
PEOPLE SHOULD EMBRACE THAT. AND
YOU KNOW, MAYBE A TOOLKIT AND,
UH AND A DEPARTMENT ON
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU. I'LL JUST ADD THAT WE
SHOULD NOT LOOK AT FEDERAL, UM
REQUIRED. WE SHOULD NOT WAIT ON
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS TO SET OUR
STANDARDS HERE IN CALIFORNIA. UH
THOSE RULES WERE SAID FOR THE
WHOLE COUNTRY, SO CALIFORNIA'S
ARE THOSE THEY ARE THE FLOOR,
NOT THE CEILING. AND
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY DOING
BETTER THAN, UH, SOME OF THOSE
FLOORS THAT ARE STUNNED BY THE
FEDERAL, UH, STANDARDS. SO I
THINK, UM, I WOULD JUST ADD
TOWARDS SARAH AND CHRIS SAID
THAT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CODIFY SOME OF THE, UH, ITEMS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT COMMUNITY BENEFIT
AGREEMENT. UM AND ALSO BUILD
CAPACITY OF THE AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE IDEAS
AND MECHANISMS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY. I THINK THAT'S A
BIG PIECE OF IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR ANSWERS. SENATOR
ALLEN, YOU HAD A QUESTION. JUST
A QUICK QUESTION. IT MAY BE
UNFAIR TO ASK THIS BECAUSE IT'S
REFERRING TO THE COMMENTS FROM
DR MAHAPATRA, WHO WAS THE ONE
PERSON WHO WASN'T ABLE TO BE
HERE. BUT YOU REFERENCE SPARKS
AS A AS A UNION SHOP AND I HAVE
TALKED TO SOME OF THE FOLKS
ABOUT THEIR WORK. HIS COMMENTS.
UM TALK ABOUT HOW BATTERY
COMPANY WE'RE LOSING JOBS TO
MICHIGAN, INDIANA, TENNESSEE,
NEVADA WASHINGTON. AND THERE'S
NEVADA WASHINGTON. AND THERE'S -REFERENCE TO THE STATES
PROVIDING RESOURCES FOR SETTING
UP PILOT MANUFACTURING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE, ESTABLISHED
MANUFACTURING FOR THE BATTERY
COMPANIES, AND THE CHALLENGE
REFERS TO THESE VALLEYS OF DEATH
, WHICH SEEMED TO BE ABOUT
TRYING TO GET PAST VARIOUS
STAGES OF INVESTMENT. UM YOU
KNOW, FROM THE PRIVATE EQUITY
STAGE AND THEN GROWTH, EQUITY
AND FEDERAL IN A AND CANADIAN
COMMENT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THESE
CHALLENGES HAS COMPANIES ARE
TRYING TO GET OFF THE GROUND,
AND THEY TAKE YOU KNOW THEY
HERE'S SOMEONE WHO'S TRYING TO
SET UP SHOP HERE AND DO HIGH
ROAD UNION MANUFACTURING AND YET
FINDING REAL CHALLENGE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AS IT IS. FOR A LOT
OF DIFFERENT REASONS. HIGHER
COST STATE AND YOU KNOW, AND YOU
REFERENCED SPARKS, CAN YOU CAN
YOU SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES OF THE COMPANY
GROWING AND WHAT SEEMS TO BE
GOING. WHAT WHAT IS IT ABOUT
THESE OTHER STATES THAT WE'RE
MISSING OUT ON WHEN IT COMES TO
THE GROWTH OF A COMPANY LIKE
THIS? THANK YOU. I CAN'T HAVE
NEVER RUN A COMPANY SO I CAN'T
SPEAK EXACTLY TO THE CHALLENGES.
BUT THIS GOES BACK TO
IDENTIFYING WHEN THERE IS A HIGH
ROAD COMPANY, A COMPANY THAT'S
WILLING TO MEET CERTAIN
STANDARDS THAT IS WILLING TO
PARTNER WITH THE UNION LIKE THE
AND HAVE A NEUTRALITY OF
NATIONAL NEUTRALITY AGREEMENT.
THAT WOULD BE A COMPANY WHERE
THE STATE COULD TARGET RESOURCES
. UM BECAUSE THERE'S THERE ARE
RESOURCES IN EVERY DEPARTMENT.
HOW DO WE FIGURE OUT HAVING ONE
DOOR ONE PLACE WHERE WE CAN
TARGET SOME OF THE RESOURCES AND
FIGURE OUT WHERE DO THEY NEED
FUNDING, I THINK WAS SPARKS.
PART OF IT IS THAT THEY GOT SOME
FUNDING FOR NET NEW JOB
CREATION. BUT THEY CAN'T START
HIRING PEOPLE UNTIL THEY'RE ABLE
TO PURCHASE THE MACHINERY THAT
THEY NEED TO ACTUALLY PRODUCE
BATTERIES. AND SO IT IS A
QUESTION ABOUT CAN WE SUPPORT
THESE COMPANIES THAT ARE WILLING
TO PARTNER THAT HAVE UNIONS THAT
HAVE COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND MAKE
SURE WE'RE ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE WE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS? I'M SURE A LOT OF THAT
IS ALREADY LIKE THE SENATOR SAID
, GOING OUT WITH LABOR STANDARDS
TO PROBABLY SOME LOW ROAD
COMPANIES. CAN WE MAKE SURE WE
PULL THAT BACK AND DIRECT IT?
TWO COMPANIES THAT ARE WILLING
TO CREATE GOOD UNION JOBS AND
MAKE SURE IT'S FOCUSED. PARTLY
IT'S ABOUT THE STATE ALSO HAVING
AN INDUSTRIAL POLICY. UM THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT BIGGER THAN JUST
LABOR STANDARDS. BUT HOW ARE WE
GOING TO SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF A
HIGH ROAD UNION? INDUSTRY IN
MANUFACTURING. HOW ARE WE GOING
TO REBUILD MANUFACTURING AND
REBUILD OUR MIDDLE CLASS? WHAT
DO YOU MEAN BY WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY? AN INDUSTRIAL POLICY THAT
GOES BEYOND LABOR CENTERS? WHAT
DOES THAT? WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
TO YOU? I WOULD SAY THAT IT
WOULD BE. HOW IS THE STATE GOING
TO SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF
MANUFACTURING, REBUILDING
MANUFACTURING IN THE STATE AND
SOME OF THESE EMERGING AND CLEAN
INDUSTRIES? E V S LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES, BUT HOW ARE WE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE TAKING
THE HIGH ROAD. JUST BECAUSE IT'S
CLEAN ENERGY OR CLIMATE JOBS
DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE GOOD JOBS.
THE ONLY REASON THAT THEY BECOME
GOOD JOBS IS BECAUSE THE
GUARDRAILS AND LABOR STANDARDS
ARE PUT IN AND BECAUSE WORKERS
ORGANIZE AND HAVE UNIONS. I
MEAN, THAT'S THE HISTORY OF THE
AUTO INDUSTRY. AND SO HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE GUARD RAILS
ARE IN PLACE, BUT ALSO THAT
THERE IS TARGETED FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND SUBSIDIES AND LOANS
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS WE'RE
ALREADY OFFERING? UM TO THE
COMPANIES THAT WE WANNA SEE,
GROW AND DEVELOP. I. I WOULD
JUST EXPAND ON THAT A LITTLE BIT
. I IS THE WE GET BACK TO THE
ECONOMY AND THE SCALE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS, YOU KNOW,
UTILIZING THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE. BUSINESS IS GOING TO
TAILOR TO WHAT THE END USER
NEEDS. AND IF THERE'S A
MARKETPLACE HERE, AND I THINK
YOU'VE SEEN SOME EXAMPLES OF
THAT, UH, SARAH MENTIONED BY Dð,
UH, THERE WAS A MARKETPLACE HERE
, UH, YOU KNOW, AND WE CAN USE
SOME OF THOSE THINGS WE
MENTIONED BEFORE THE SCORING OF
COMMUNITY BENEFITS USING THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS IN PROCUREMENT
WE HAVE. I BELIEVE THE LARGEST
UNIV. UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD HERE IN WE HAVE, UH, ONE
OF THE LARGEST ECONOMIES IN THE
WORLD WE HAVE, UM, WE HAVE SO
MANY ADVANTAGES. AND IF WE START
USING OUR OUR PROCUREMENT, UM
AND I THINK AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
WAS THE WAS THE BUS
MANUFACTURING IN LANCASTER,
CALIFORNIA. THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
UNION JOBS, AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT FACILITY.
NOW THEY'VE HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
NEGATIVE. UH FROM, UM I THINK
JUST, UM, YOU KNOW, KEEP
THROWING OUT. UM YOU KNOW, UH,
NARRATIVES AS FAR AS BEING TIED
TO A CHINESE COMPANY. IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT A STATE OWNED COMPANY.
IT'S UH, YOU KNOW, IT'S YOU KNOW
THOSE ARE LOCAL JOBS. AND IF WE
START DOING MORE OF THAT,
WHETHER IT BE WITH TRAIN
MANUFACTURING, WHETHER THAT BE
WITH, UH YOU KNOW, PROCUREMENT
OF A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS.
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS. UH YOU
KNOW, MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS ARE ARE
DONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
DOING MORE CONSTRUCTION THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE. YOU KNOW, LET'S
LOOK TO DO MORE OF THOSE THINGS.
SO I THINK THAT THOSE YOU KNOW,
IN ADDITION TO YOU KNOW SOME OF
THOSE THINGS TO CREATE A
MARKETPLACE. THE MARKETPLACE FOR
THOSE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS FOR
THE PRODUCTION OF HYDROGEN WHEN
THEY ARE DONE THIS WAY, YOU CAN
GET THESE BENEFITS SO USING
PROCUREMENT OR TO DRIVE THE
MARKETPLACE. I THINK THAT WOULD
HELP. ALSO YEAH. UM I'LL JUST,
UH, SECOND, CHRIS THERE, THERE'S
ALREADY INCENTIVES BUILT WITHIN
THE STATE FUNDING STREAMS FOR
COMPANIES TO HIRE DIVERSE
WORKERS, UH, FOR TRAINING
COMMUNITY BENEFIT AGREEMENTS.
IT'S REALLY UP TO THE STATE TO
CODIFY IT OR TO INCLUDE THEM, UH
, AS THEY'RE DISPERSING THIS
MONEY TO PUT IT IN A MOST
SIMPLEST TERM, THERE'S ALREADY
PROVISIONS WITHIN FEDERAL ON, UH
, BEER AND CHIPS FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN. SPARKS INCLUDED A
COMMUNITY SCORE IF THEY WERE
ALLOWED TO COMPETE ON A CONTRACT
. UH FOR A WITH A COMMUNITY
SCORE WITH THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT WITH THE
UAW. THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
ADVANTAGE TO COMPETE ON GOOD
PRINCIPLES. UH PRINCI PRINCIPLES
AND PROVIDING, UH, THINGS LIKE
HEALTH CARE, UH, WAGES, TRAINING
AND THINGS LIKE THAT, WHATEVER
THEY HAVE WITHIN THEIR
COLLECTIVE BARGAIN AGREEMENT
THAT WHEN THAT BE CONSIDERED IN
A SCORE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING THAT RIGHT
NOW ON MANY OF THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT, UH, WHERE
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO SCORE THAT
COMMUNITY? UH, IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO MEAN LABOR, BUT WHEN THINGS
LIKE LABOR CAN BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION, IT'S A WHOLE LOT
EASIER FOR WORKERS TO GET A
VOICE AND IT'S A WHOLE LOT
EASIER WHEN THE WORKERS HAVE
THAT INPUT INTO, UH, THEIR
CONTRACT THAT WE HAVE. WORKERS
GETTING WHAT THEY NEED AND
EQUITY THERE. SORRY. WHEN YOU
SAY SCORE COMMUNITY YOU YOU'RE
IS THAT A YOU? YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE
NOT REFERRING TO SCORING THE BID
RIGHT? OR OR AM I AN
UNDERSTANDING THE? YEAH WE WE'RE
WE'RE DOING WE'RE YOU KNOW,
WE'RE WE'RE PURCHASING A HUGE
AMOUNT, AND MANY OF THEM ARE
PRIVATE, UH, PURCHASES BUT GOING
INTO THE GREATER UH, WHETHER IT
BE THE GRID, YOU KNOW, WHOLE
HOST OF DIFFERENT THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. UH, IN IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT A PORTION OF
THE GRANT SO SOME OF IT GOES
OUT. THROUGH A FORMULA. SO
POPULATION, UH, COUNTIES OR
STATES OF THIS SIZE, GET X
AMOUNT FOR ROADS AND BRIDGES.
OTHERS GO OUT THROUGH A GRANT
PROGRAM AND WITHIN THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
SCORING ON YOUR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
LABOR. BUT THINGS LIKE LABOR, UM
AND, UH APPRENTICESHIPS AND
LOCAL HIRE, UH, COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS, EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
THOSE THINGS CAN TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION, SO WHEN WE'RE
PROCURING OUR. FOR OUR GRID, AND
WE'RE YOU KNOW, BATTERY STORAGE
OR WE'RE SOLAR PANELS. AND WE'RE
ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE PROCURING
THE POWER. UM AND MUCH OF THAT
IS THROUGH INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES REGULATIONS TO BE ABLE
TO SET YOU KNOW GUIDELINES AND
SCORES OF THAT NATURE. ALLOW
PEOPLE TO COMPETE ON THOSE
THINGS WOULD ALLOW US TO, YOU
KNOW, FOR YOU KNOW GOOD PLAYERS
LIKE SPARKS TO DO GOOD IN THIS
AREA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT RESPONSE. I DON'T SEE ANY
ADDITIONAL, UH, COMMENTS JUST
FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE
SCORE? WE HAD JUST THIS THIS
COMMUNITY SCORING MECHANISM JUST
FOR ME TO KNOW BECAUSE I I'M NOT
UP TO SPEED UM, THAT THAT'S
UNDER THE IRA OR THE IJ OR BOTH.
AYE. OR CHIPS. OK INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT ACT IN OTHER ACTS.
THERE ARE BONUSES FOR DOING
THINGS LIKE PAYING A PREVAILING
WAGE OR UTILIZING APPRENTICES
ABOVE A CERTAIN THRESHOLD.
THERE'S ALSO, UM. I DON'T HAVE
EVERY SINGLE GUIDELINE IN FRONT
OF ME. BUT WITHIN THE GRANT
PROGRAMS, UH, GRANT PROGRAMS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
CONSIDERING COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
, AND IT'S NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THE SCORE EITHER.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING AND FOR
THAT, UM, REALLY IMPORTANT, UM,
INFORMATION AND DETAIL AND I. I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE POINT
ABOUT INVESTING IN COMPANIES. WE
NEED STRONG COMPANIES. THAT ARE
REFLECTING THE VALUES OF
CALIFORNIA. UM AND NOT
PERPETUATING SOME OF OUR
ECONOMIC CRISES THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO DIG OUR WAY OUT OF,
AND HOMELESSNESS AND
UNDEREMPLOYMENT AND UM SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, UM, FOR OUR PANELISTS
FOR THAT WE ARE GOING TO, UM. I
TURN MY MIC BACK ON. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE NOW INTO PUBLIC COMMENT. UM
. NÓ AND WE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
FOR THE EXTRA COFFEE. YOU MUST
HAVE HAD EARLIER TODAY TO GET
YOU TO A 740 IN THIS HEARING.
MADAM CHAIR. CAN I JUST? I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE AND
WHO IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
DO THIS FROM BUT WE HEAR
EXAMPLES. ANECDOTALLY OF THIS IS
THE WAY IT WAS DONE HERE. THIS
IS THE WAY WE DID THERE. I WAS
INVOLVED WITH THE B Ó. I Dð AND
KINK, SHAO. I MEAN, THERE'S LOTS
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THROUGH OUR
COMMITTEE, UH OR THROUGH OTHERS
WE CAN GET STORIES LIKE THAT. SO
IT'S NOT JUST A ONE OFF. I THINK
WHAT SENATOR ALLEN WAS ASKING
ARE THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS
EVERYBODY WILL BE ASKING. LIKE
HOW DOES THIS WORK? AND UM,
ANYWAY, JUST SOMETHING. MAYBE
THAT COMMITTEE COULD DO
ABSOLUTELY. AND MAYBE WE CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE. AND UH
AND PARTICULARLY WITH, UH, OUR
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE COLLECTING
THIS INFORMATION TO ENSURE THAT
WE ACTUALLY ARE DOCUMENTING ALL
OF THE EXAMPLES, BUT CERTAINLY
FROM TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
SURE TO GET THAT INFORMATION. TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. SARAH DE
RASO. UM PLEASE STEP TO THE MIC.
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR. WE WOULD LOVE
TO SHARE YOUR INFORMATION. WE
WANT TO KEEP IT TO ONE MINUTE
JUST TO RESPECT UM THE REST OF
OUR TIME AND PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND, UM, AND YOUR COMMENT.
THANK YOU. OK, UM ONE MINUTE.
NOT A WHOLE LOT. SO MICHELLE
RUEL CAVA. I'M AT NIELSEN WORKS
PARANAL GROSS AND LEÓN. AND I
REPRESENT THE ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND UM, I THINK WHAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE. WE HAVE BEEN SYSTEMICALLY
EXCLUDED. FROM A LOT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS. I THINK IT'S
MOSTLY BECAUSE WE'RE MERIT SHOPS
AND, YOU KNOW, SOME PEOPLE THINK
THAT THAT IS NOT EQUIVALENT TO
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS. UM THE
REALITY IS THAT OUR EMPLOYERS
PAY PREVAILING WAGE. THEY YOU
KNOW, PARTICIPATE IN ALL OF THE
OTHER THINGS BESIDES BEING
NONUNION, THAT IS THE ONLY IF
YOU WANT TO CALL IT A NEGATIVE
OF OUR EMPLOYERS. BUT OTHER THAN
THAT, THEY ARE GREAT EMPLOYERS.
WE HAVE GREAT WORKERS. WE HAVE
STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIPS
AND THOSE APPRENTICES ARE
SYSTEMICALLY EXCLUDED FROM THESE
PROGRAMS. YOU CAN JUST LOOK AT
THE èC B FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL. IT DEFINES AN APPRENTICE
AS ONLY A UNION APPRENTICE. YOU
ARE EXCLUDING HUNDREDS, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF APPRENTICES. SO IF
WE COULD HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE AS A LATINA AS A WOMAN, I
KNOW IT'S HARD TO GET THAT I'D
LIKE MY CLIENT TO HAVE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. UM GOOD EVENING.
I AM KARIUS. I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING A B èC OR èC. I
AM A WORKER. UM LIKE I. WORKING
I'M IN A PART OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE KIND OF EXCLUDED FROM
THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT. AND, UM IF
THERE'S LIKE, ANY TYPE OF
LANGUAGE THAT IS KIND OF HOW
WOULD I SAY? EXCLUDING NON UNION
APPRENTICE, UH, GREATLY IMPACT,
YOU KNOW, MORE QUALITY OF
QUALITY OF LIFE AND YOU KNOW,
JUST KIND OF LIKE MY WORKING YOU
KNOW, RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMPANIES I WORK WITH IN THE
APPRENTICESHIP, SO YOU KNOW IT'S
KIND OF LIMITING. WHAT I CAN AND
CANNOT DO BY BEING NONUNION, SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING. MY NAME IS MATTHEW
SAPOA. I'M WITH THE ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
REPRESENT, UH 460 MEMBERS WHO
ARE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, AND
WE UPSKILL MORE THAN 300
APPRENTICES ANNUALLY IN THE
TRADES. OUR MAIN CONCERN, AS
ECHOED BY OUR PRENTICE, WHO IS
CURRENTLY IN OUR PROGRAM. IS
THAT THE FUNDING OF THE PROJECTS
COMING OUT OF S¼ B 150 WOULD
UNFAIRLY EXCLUDE OUR APPRENTICES
WHO COME FROM THE UNILATERAL
APPRENTICESHIP COMMITTEE
PROGRAMS. WE HAVE SEEN THIS AT
THE LEVEL. WE'VE SEEN IT WHEN
IMPLEMENTATION WITH THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL ALL WERE SIMPLY
ASKING IS ONE CHANGE IS THAT ALL
STATE AND FEDERALLY APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BE
ALLOWED TO WORK ON PUBLIC
PROJECTS? I WOULD LOVE TO REACH
OUT AND TO EXPLAIN OUR POSITION
FURTHER, BUT, UH, THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME. THANK YOU. HØI MY NAME
IS LISA. COUNTRYMAN KEROS. I'M
THE èC E Ó OF JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICE IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WE SERVE THE WHOLE
BAY AREA AS WELL AS THE INLAND
EMPIRE. I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL. I THINK IT COMES AT A
REALLY, OF COURSE EVERYONE'S
MENTIONED IT COMES AT AN
INCREDIBLY CRITICAL TIME. UM
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVEN'T
MENTIONED IN ADDITION TO A JUST
TRANSITION, WE ALSO HAVE MASSIVE
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE COMING, AND
SO IT REALLY CAN'T BE
OVERSTATED. HOW IMPORTANT THIS
MOMENT IS TO SEIZE AND ENSURE
THAT WE CREATE GREAT JOBS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THAT IS THE
WORK THAT JB S¼ DOES. AND I JUST
WANNA KIND OF ZOOM IN ON THE
FOLKS THAT WE WORK WITH AND HELP
GET TO OVER $100,000 A YEAR. UM,
IT IS A DEEP INVESTMENT IN THEIR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING, PROGRESS
AND SUPPORT. AND UH OH, SORRY
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE PROCESS,
AS YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SORT OF
BUREAUCRATIC LANGUAGE AND REALLY
MAKING A CHANGE AND DOING
SOMETHING REALLY DIFFERENT. IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER, UM ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE SERVING
ALL THE FOLKS THAT WE ARE
HELPING TO GET INTO GREAT MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS AND THE KINDS OF
SUPPORTS AND PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO GET THERE. SO I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK,
AND, UH, CENTER THE FOLKS THAT
WE'RE SERVING. THANK THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ROMAN
VOGELSANG WITH THE PRAYING
COMPANY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
, THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATIONS ASSOCIATION THAT
WORKS AT THE 45 LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA
. UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD A MEMBER
OF èC W A AS WELL AS A MEMBER
OF THE CONTRAST WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND MEMBER OF
THE SOUTH BAY WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARD HERE TO TESTIFY
, BUT THEY HAD TO CATCH THEIR
FLIGHTS BACK DOWN TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO THEY WERE UNABLE
TO DO SO. BUT REGARDLESS WE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THIS ROBUST DISCUSSION AND
I'LL MAKE SURE THAT YOU ALL HAVE
THEIR COMMENTS SUBMITTED IN
WRITING TO YOUR OFFICES. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, UH, LOOKS
LIKE THAT WAS OUR LAST PUBLIC
COMMENTS OR HAVING HEARD ALL OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY MEMBERS?
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BRING FORWARD
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE? THANK YOU,
UH, I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. UM I AM IN
AGREEMENT VERY, VERY
SPECIFICALLY THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT ALL WORKERS
WHETHER THEY ARE REPRESENTED BY
A LABOR GROUP ARE NOT, UM, THE
EFFORT FOR ME, IN MY GENUINE
OPINION IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE LISTENING TO OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. OUR UNIONS, UH, LABOR
AS A WHOLE THE WORKFORCE AND
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS DIGNITY. JUSTICE
AND FAIRNESS, UM, IN THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE
FORWARD, I WILL SAY THAT I AM
VERY MUCH COMMITTED TO THIS
EFFORT. I KNOW THAT THE SENATORS
HERE IN THE CAUCUS HAVE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD ON THIS. FOR
A VERY LONG TIME AS A NEW CHAIR.
YOU KNOW, WE WILL DEFINITELY GET
ACCLIMATED TO SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE AND WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION VERY DIRECTLY
AND VERY, UM, YOU KNOW,
SPECIFICALLY ON MAKING SURE THAT
WE KIND OF MOVE CALIFORNIA
FORWARD, SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
UH, MY COCHA AND THE SENATORS
THAT HAVE STAYED FOR SOME TIME
AS WELL AS BOTH COMMITTEE STAFF.
UM I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE TO PUT A
LOT TOGETHER FOR US. SO, UH,
AGAIN APPRECIATE AND APPRECIATE
THE PANELISTS. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU, UH, CO-CHAIR FOR
THOSE COMMENTS, AND I ECHO THE
SAME AND I'M SO GLAD THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CO-CHAIR THIS
FIRST IMPORTANT HEARING TOGETHER
. I JUST WANT TO SAY I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR HANGING
IN WITH US AND FOR OUR PANELISTS
FOR SHARING YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE WITH US. OUR GOAL IS
TO LOOK BEYOND S¼ B 150 TO
DEVELOP LABOR STANDARDS THAT CAN
BE APPLIED TO ALL OF OUR FUTURE
PROJECTS. WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IS ALSO A
MULTIPLIER THAT CALLS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED AND NEED COMMUNITY. UH,
OPPORTUNITY AND RESILIENT JOBS
AND CAREERS THE MOST. I LOOK
FORWARD TO COLLABORATING WITH
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO
SHARED INFORMATION AND THOSE WHO
SPOKE AND IT CERTAINLY, UM MY
GREAT, UH, SENATE COLLEAGUES.
UM, WE DO THIS. WE CAN DO THIS
TOGETHER, AND WE CAN DO THIS NOW
. UM TODAY'S HEARING IS NOT THE
END. UM, BUT IT REALLY IS A
DOUBLING DOWN ON OUR COMMITMENT
TO SEE THIS WORK THROUGH, UM
THIS YEAR AND AS LONG AS THERE'S
SOME MONEY COMING IN TO BUILD
THIS CLIMATE RESILIENCY, WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
LEADING THE WAY. SO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION AND
HAVE A GOOD EVENING.